To identify there was areas where maybe
he needs to be cleared. Absolutely.
Tuesday is when we have a.
one.
And uh, for that,
how long did you think the line happened?
It's a few a while.
Maybe it was a lot afternoon section. OK,
two months. So we'll um.
Well, tentative, tentative. Yeah,
because you know,
I just want to make sure we kind of give
him a target of when he's here.
Will you send him a meeting time to join
this?
So it shows up on his calendar and and we
have him here for that.
OK.
Did I think this this whole thing got
sent out to Jimmy? Is there any,
is there any times in the agenda that we
want to have Jimmy the elected components
aren't specifically requested plus so.
That would be the Wednesday. OK,
so this is the.
All right. Um.
Important stuff here launch with like the
beginning kind of plan with the already
have the that's where it's looking.
What's that? Sorry, sorry.
What else? What else,
month forbid so we we need to touch base
on?
I didn't see anything on work packages
and production planner for in the
schedule. Is that?
Unless I missed it and it is,
is that needed? Oh yeah, definitely.
The work packages we want to touch base
on. We have it,
but to implement the Gantt chart system
utilizing the work package to see what
next.
OK. That was something. Yeah,
I just didn't see anything that anywhere
on the schedule anywhere.
I don't know the schedule was up.
Big topic that you wanted or at least.
OK.
Yeah, Ricky, did you invoice us yet?
I won't do it till I leave. So no worries.
We're good. Yeah, yeah, no worries.
We're we're all good. So I ain't sweating.
All right. Well,
why don't you go ahead and just jump
right in the first section and we'll stay
here for a little bit and I can announce
any.
So it would be the duplicate praise.
Like I said,
I'm pretty confident that we've gotten
most of that. OK,
that's I don't know how much work that.
Not necessarily. Um.
But the.
The 08 What we've been doing with that
one is as we come across that.
And say that leads to where when we're
sending out our queues that when we catch
it. Yeah. OK, cool. If I apply, you know,
this, uh, or way to it,
it's obviously gonna show nothing.
So this is, yeah,
it's it's obviously not as early.
So that's what we're just going to. Yep,
finding how we've been handling it is
there.
A better process where there is a report
that that can be pulled for that that'll
show you all those items.
So like if you go to the drop down at the
top ships, great size,
maintenance drop down.
And then reports.
And you could filter for whatever shapes
you wanted to look at or anything and
then the next when you hit make report.
It sees where it's a 08 report. Yeah, OK,
some people automate that too.
They'll do like once a month or so.
Have it sent to somebody. Just hey,
here's all the new stuff from last month.
Yeah, but yeah.
Balance.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Now in here as well,
I think it's the top one,
the size list that would give you a
listing of all.
It doesn't show you the exceptions,
but it shows all of the.
Cross-sectional area,
all the the other component we were
talking that's next on there,
all of that stuff shows on that report.
So some some people like just using that
report to scan down through am I missing
cross-sectional area,
am I missing some flange width or
anything like that on any of.
The any of the pieces.
Do what? How easy is it? Almost too easy,
to be quite honest with you, it did.
Yeah.
Duplicate grades or grades being added to
carving when they should have been added
to a stainless call out.
So the permissions on that have changed
in type of special.
But it it is very simple to add one and
like on the imports,
you can add them on the fly on the
imports and that's really kind of part of
the problem is it's too easy and if
somebody's important and doesn't really
know what they're doing,
then a bunch of stuff gets added that
doesn't need to get added.
So it's almost too easy.
But yeah,
so I ask a stupid question at the 836.
Let's say tomorrow, let's say by 1670.
Maybe you just add all the same.
Is it one at a time or can you add like?
Yeah, it's like for the grades. Yeah,
it it's it's just a one at a time.
But now you talk about adding the sizes
to the grade.
Let's say you want an 8 by 20 piece
playing the master playing 8 by 20,
but you also want 10 by.
So OK,
the sizes are already in there or they
they should be.
Most of the sizes are already in there,
but when you have like the grade,
it would apply to all of those sizes,
but it's only gonna be within like that
specific call out.
So like this one's currently selected on
channels. So if we.
Add that grade to channels.
That doesn't necessarily mean it'll show
up for beams or angles. Yeah, we have to,
yeah,
you would have to go in and add it to
those ones as well. Yeah,
the grades are unique to the shapes.
So yes, the shapes. Yeah,
and you'll have a future problem I see
here.
Is if you do run some advanced stuff,
everything I see here is ASTM and we may
end up having ASME link. Yeah,
all of a sudden 836 with 836 initial
access 836. Yeah, it's minor.
But it'll make a difference.
OK.
Yeah,
so adding the grades are easy and
actually adding shapes are easy.
If you need,
if you wanted it to be a totally
different shape,
I mean it's it's very customizable.
So I mean I wondered about this, just the.
Suck suicide, Yeah.
Yeah.
So yeah,
the the it's still feel like the grades
are good. Cool.
So if I only assign it to a new grade,
So what I've been doing is once I assign
it to like for this example,
I believe 836 is gonna be at the top.
So the default, yeah,
I assign it to that and then I go in
there and actually remove it from there.
Yeah, yeah,
remove it from the abbreviation.
From the abbreviation. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
it makes sense.
Yes.
Keep in mind that.
Let's see here what what what your
detailers?
Are they using tackle structures?
I can't remember. Remind me.
So Miss DS, correct.
The current detailing set up is with
structures. OK,
just keep in mind that when your
detailers get on structures 2025.
You can share your grades and shapes and
finishes with them.
Have you have you guys seen that yet?
It's it was new as of 2025.
What the way that functions is when you
have a Trimble Connect project linked.
To this,
then you share that with the detailer.
The detailer links their model to that
Trim Connect project as well.
So that Trim Connect project is kind of
the bridge between the two packages.
Then you're able to share your
Shakespeare sizes with them so that if
they.
Choose a different grade than what you
have in your system.
It'll flag them and they got to change it.
Yeah.
Now there's just a slight amount of set
up on your side.
Let me show that to you real quick. Yeah,
that's good.
So it'll it'll make that screen on the
import that pops up that says I don't
recognize this shape or grade.
Pretty much that would be not exist in
this bar which we just received the file
last week.
We're we're working at Shep Steel. Yep.
And they sent us their model and we've
already had conflicting gray dimension
lengths. Yes Sir. So that.
That would be huge.
So we can flag it without coming through,
you know? Yeah, a day and a half. Yeah,
yeah, for sure.
So when when that happens, of course,
yeah,
detailers like to stay about 10 years
behind on their versions, I think. So,
you know,
it might be 10 years before you get there,
but they don't for sure go up to
maintenance and address book.
And then let's pull up one of your
detailers.
Yeah, they just opened there, Martin.
All right,
you see in the upper right corner info
sharing.
If you hit that drop down you can you can
choose to share your shapes, grade sizes,
your finishes and your ABM settings.
So ABM, the ABM,
the best bill section in here is.
Got revamped, which was good,
it needed to be.
And so you're able to set up like I don't
care about any changes to the advanced
bill that is if it shrinks by two feet,
I don't care,
but you can set parameters for what you
do care about so that the detailer even
then knows.
OK, cool. This shrunk by foot,
but they don't care about it because they
said it's telling that.
So you can share all that with them as
well. But anyhow, so.
Yeah,
now you can talk to the teachers also.
I can recycle. Yeah, yeah, it's.
I'm in the same books.
It is a little little fuzzy.
But later they start online,
which they express them,
but they just aren't you better than
online. Um.
So they can choose.
You come talking about the detail or is
that what you're talking about? Yeah,
let's say they will have what you will
say. Yeah, who's control?
So they can choose whichever one they
want, but it will. It'll it'll flag them.
Saying hey, this is not theirs.
And so now I haven't gotten an answer yet
because I don't have to take structures.
So I don't know take structures.
I haven't gotten an answer yet about OK,
does it completely stop them from sending
you the other stuff? I think it does.
It it stops them from sending a different
grade.
But they can actually,
when they do their detailing,
they can detail without those shapes and
grades.
But there's a there's a screen that says
here's all the ones that are wrong,
got a good change on.
So but so this one takes precedence in
other words, so.
Well, yeah, like like the chefs, you know,
they're controlling the detailing.
So therefore, yeah,
that you might have trouble with that one.
Do you have to align the shelf or do you
does it mean that to happen?
Do you align your database with the shelf?
No.
Our database is based off of our specific
job that we do.
We're we're particularly like a job shop,
right? But if we do have like their model.
Make it with them. Um,
then that's what we would align on that
specific project.
So along with that connector by the way
that where you where it pulls your stuff
over that will that will give you those
submittals here as well.
That's that's how that works.
So they would be when they start sending
you files.
They don't have to e-mail it to you
anymore,
just shows up in that list right there.
That's how that happens.
So that's that's the connector is what
it's called. So there and they got,
they get take less some videos out there
on that so you can kind of see that
functioning.
So you can see from the detailer's
perspective.
As well as your perspective,
but yet that submittals thing then will
be nice because then when they send you a
package,
you can pull it up and then choose to
import it straight from there.
But let's say that there are no drawings
in the package or something like that.
You can reject it. It goes back,
it goes back.
After them,
it flags them in tech structures and says
hey,
they rejected this one because there's no
draws.
So it kind of creates a log for you as
well. That simplified communication too.
Yeah, it does. Yeah.
So pushing your detailers to go there
will make communication a whole lot nicer.
So.
Medium.
No.
All right.
That means finishes would have to be
cleaned too.
It's a lot.
I wonder if you think about the so
bottoms, the bottoms through your tops.
Yes.
That's why you're trying to adjust that.
We put on an 84 inch TV set up that.
But it's because it's at an angle.
So you're either going to go to the fish
and fog clear or the not clear.
You're not even going to get all of it.
Will you move that,
move that down on your screen?
What do you have? Do we? No. Yeah.
Why don't you just take that folder on
the one in the middle of the page that
spots here and move this app like any?
And zoom it.
A little bit more clear.
OK.
Very little different.
Maybe cloud worse.
So the top is not if you have a good use.
OK,
so it's if I'm seeing the projector on
the wall, yeah.
We can see how it should be hanging out.
Next week's problem.
No, sorry.
That's.
Yeah.
Bites to.
Thank you.
Gotta go around this.
That's what you should give it before.
That would be the bottom left search bar.
Then it should get you back to fire
setting.
We're still.
Very good. I can't read it. Oh, yeah.
Definitely. You can read that. Sweet.
Yeah. I'll have it adjusted. Yeah. Yeah.
That's on the back, right? Yeah. Yeah.
Thank you.
Be some video.
Cool. So yeah, I made the note that,
you know, once we get our detailers,
you said it's the 2025. Yeah, yeah,
they'll have to be on 2025.
You're already where you need to be.
They'll just have to bump up. So.
OK.
We've been updated for a day.
Have you for a day?
OK, so anything new that might be missing,
please let us know. OK.
Have you noticed any or have any of your
other customers tune you into there being
any issues with this update or no there
there was on just 2025 I but first
service pack came out and fixed.
Thanks for such stuff. I would once again,
I've never knew up on the yeah,
on the personal wait for the service
first service back in that. Yeah,
the one thing that we noticed was there
was a a lag.
So it would come up with that then check
on not responding, but I think.
It was more of our service. I don't know.
I couldn't do anything without looking
and then just literally waiting. Oh wow.
Figure it out.
There's a, you know,
all the shops I get to,
there's a wide variety of speeds.
Some are like mega slow and some are like
super fast and I think it's more hardware
related than it is anything,
but now anyway, so.
Anyhow, OK,
the the the other side of the shapes
great sizes was all the we we touched on
it but the.
Making sure all the properties are
correct for anything that gets added like
the cross-sectional area and all of that
jazz because that's super critical for
estimating purposes.
Without all of that then some some labor
will not populate so.
Yeah,
go to dimensions and then just select the
dimension and hit edit dimension at the
bottom.
So like over here cross-sectional area
depth follow that all of that jazz is
critical to estimating because like as an
example cross-sectional area there is
used to populate the.
Time for cutting in estimating,
unless something's been changed in the
estimate set up in here,
but out-of-the-box without anything in
cross-sectional area,
you get nothing flange width that you
know it's not very often you don't be
adding. It's not like you're adding a new.
Beam size or anything.
That's like a real rare occurrence.
But in this particular case,
if you didn't have flange width,
you put a coat on something and
estimating you get no coat because it
actually looks at how far across the
flange is to in order to do the burn.
So these are actually very critical.
I went for years and years and didn't
fill out any of that except for the
weight, cause I was like, who cares?
And then my brother,
the head estimator at the shop I was at
called me one day and was like,
why do I not have cut on a bunch of these
things? And it's like, oh crap, so.
Yeah,
so it's kind of critical all that gets
filled out as well.
So do so do we need to go through the the
column sizes and populate values in in
this section they should be for for like
beans you you know what the.
I think New Koryamanu added three jumbo
bean sizes last year or something like
that.
But you know you're not adding beans like
hardly ever, so they're probably fine.
But like flat bar tends to get added
quite, you know,
like 1/2 size or something and so those
are pretty.
Those can be pretty critical. So yeah,
you'll just have to flip through and look
like this. Really.
I'm assuming it's not a legitimate size.
I got added on an import or something
that were the detail and sent you
something crappy or something.
I.
Yeah, there we go.
So is this something that we did? Yeah,
we we have been going through. Yes,
it's one of those active um like I was
saying in the beginning where if if it
showed up when we're sending our queues
that every zero we attached to it,
we know.
OK, cool.
We need to go back in there and figure
out, you know, all of this.
So once you have the values in here,
where is the math that says with these
values to calculate the cut time is so
you can measure that and figure out where
you need to to, you know, adjust.
Yeah.
So that's up in maintenance and
estimating, OK.
And then it's over in the labor
maintenance and labor standards at the
very bottom.
OK. So then like here,
like if you went to channel or something,
select on one of those,
you'll see a cut there,
see the cut there is 1.66 minutes.
So is and I think what you're asking is,
is that something we need to set or is
that?
Already a three set.
So if a sizes gets added,
which by the way you can see that first
size we were looking at for channel is
not showing up here.
So if a size gets added,
it doesn't necessarily get added to
estimating.
And I think the reason they do that is
because it's like for one thing,
you might get a bunch of crap in
estimating because you know you you do an
import from a detailer.
Sometimes they send you a bunch of crappy
sizes that aren't legit, right?
The other thing is they're not going to
guess at what times you want on it.
So we could go here though and down at
the bottom we say add and we can add any
new channels that are not here,
but they are in the Shakespeare size
database.
So and then when it brings that in,
it will populate with tons,
but you're basically getting notification.
Here's what I'm adding time to so you'll
know.
To change it. So.
So these are Tekla times, right?
Tekla said. Power back said.
These are the times are defaults.
I would imagine that Lone row has their
own table for their times for every
operation. You may have changed these.
Sure, but yeah, we could.
You're you're the master of that domain.
I always see the portion of that.
So you say, hey,
you gotta C6 is 2 minutes. Yeah,
so this has the original database the
tech will put in and then upon our review,
if there's anything that uh may be out of
the north and I need more processing time,
that's when we'll go ahead and change it.
So when there's updates and one of the
first things that I was seeing when I
came in is we were hitting pretty much
all of the all the other areas etcetera
and and it depends on memory you're doing.
The cycle time from where you're coming
to to where you're going.
So there's a big barrier.
But we we could see that the handling was
it was we were we were constantly losing
or not getting our hours, right.
So that's when we went back in and we
asked.
Application are estimating recon to
change the values on the estimates.
They they manage it in Gilbert.
It's not managed here. Well,
it should be managed here.
It's managed here,
but that we they have to be updated and
informed that we've made that.
That change. OK,
so you guys are telling them, hey,
this number's wrong. Yeah,
we're giving them constant feedback on on
their not that strong, but that we can.
Yeah, we are.
But we have basically we we do a on on
like we have when we go over on over $500
we have our we put a self-imposed what
car.
That's yeah, you can see I must do it.
It'll be able to restore it.
So it's gonna have a internal way to may
have what's measured instead of you get
it stating when you update that it does
not go to the estimated so.
Yeah. If we update the these numbers here,
they're using tech with the estimate,
then yes, it's. Oh, OK, yeah, yeah, yeah.
All your tech is all linked between here
and and, right? Yes. OK, yeah,
we're all on the same thing. Yeah,
definitely at a base. Hey,
when we talk about estimator,
that's kind of.
Talk, right. OK,
I see the low part Isaac and Isaac,
Isaac as well.
So it's good estimators over there.
Goal is going to be a lot of spot checks
and time studies on certain projects.
We we need to get a certain data set for
each set up and then make adjustments.
But there's a lot, yeah, to do. I mean,
it's it's intense, yeah.
I mean you can have all the different
shapes up there and then every one of
those can have you know 20 different
dimensions if not you know hundreds more
if we did the first one and then the
fifth one and then like the 15th one and
we can see some correlation.
So we can just run scale on it and just
scale along. So yeah,
you can use that global edit to do it
based off the cross-sectional. Yeah,
theoretically based off the
cross-sectional area,
you do one and it should be good for
everything.
But I found that I had to do it in like.
Like the shop where I was at,
I I measured like a how long would it
take to do a 14 or 22, right?
And then when I passed that to every room,
it seemed like it was good for maybe 12
and 14 inch,
but then 1618 inch I needed to do another
one.
So it was like I had to do it in two inch
eager.
Permits in in order to make it somewhat
easier.
So we should probably do you get brought
up and pick some every so a while and
update those and then hopefully it will
be.
So it's like,
but it's like add the comments, sure,
because I would find the reason to spot
check those numbers. Yeah,
on those shapes.
Have you guys done any time studies at
this point or yeah, but so I.
I have a border here,
but we we obviously we we touch stains
every once in a while,
but not as much as we touch carbon, right?
We have the the shades,
grays obviously for for the metric in
there for stains,
stainless materials as well, yeah.
Standards is all gonna be s s to signify
stainless and then whatever the shape is,
so like this one would be played. OK,
so if we were just gonna cut,
let's just say 1/2 inch.
316 settings play and we were gonna cut
strips of the app for some reason and say
two by two squares. How? How would that?
How would that look here?
Play tap games.
316 you talking about for the time? Yes,
yes.
So we'd have to go back to estimating the
maintenance, estimating labor,
maintenance and labor standards. Oh,
this might be some.
There might be some you might need to add
me and see the yes it's not in there.
So any shape that you're going to use in
estimating will need to be added in here
in order to get times for it.
So so with that being said,
if I'm adding it.
From a higher databases,
they're already pointing.
If I tell it to add the stainless steel
like for example,
it will pull all of the information for
all the dimensions and everything like
that. Yes. OK,
so you wanna do one real quick? Yeah,
just to add.
Yeah, and choose it.
Cool.
Then you can pull over whichever ones you
want. So cool.
So this is where we could potentially do
one size. But yeah, yeah,
I don't know why why you would,
unless there's just sizes that truly
aren't legitimate.
But then that's something you need to
clean up anyway, right?
So shape,
right size and differentiate between type
304 and type 316 stands.
You know it's when you have your database
of all your materials that are possible
and for steel you know you got this,
this and this.
But for stainless you got like type 304
and type 316 or different types of
stainless. But the question is does your.
Database currently have differentiation
in there.
When you go to look it up and you choose,
that's the type 3 or type 316. Yeah,
you can select the grade. OK,
but does the grade change the like the
weight at all? Doesn't change the weight,
no. Hold on a second. I got three.
It's changed. Yeah, so you put it.
It's probably a little easier to to cut
through the portal so that then that
would be the time to be right here.
But it's not. I'm not talking about. Yeah,
those are all they 316 doesn't process,
for example. Yeah, so.
OK, but hold on a second. Why do you care?
I can see in the material grades you want
316, three or four,
but in the labor grades,
labor grades should make any different
scenario because you're going to pay more
money.
I get, I get the general side of it,
but I think I say it seems the material
grade, but this is the labor thing. Yeah,
you say the labor is not looking at a
grade. So yeah, we're not expected to.
Yeah, it's it's not right. Yeah.
But now the way you had it before where
stainless was a grade of the basically
the carbon basically Pl.
and then you you're picking whether it's.
836 or whether it's three or four that
made a big difference for estimating
purposes.
So switching to stateless having its own
shape is big because labor is vastly
different.
Now, now that we brought that in though,
you can see that the times are not
populated. So what what you got to do,
then you got to populate the time we can
pull that over from like.
Just regular Pl.
So you got something in there and then
you can adjust appropriately from there
if you want to.
That's probably the the best way to do it.
So like we can get a plate there and then
choose to pass it over so.
And we just pick whatever size.
Cool.
Then go up to the drop down and global
edit.
Global edit operations.
And then choose to send it.
You're going to send it to the SSPL.
We'll we'll make Pl.
because I'm assuming Pl.
is already populated.
So we're we're saying we're going to send
it to stainless plate all those sizes.
So hit OK.
And then this is all the labor.
So push all of it over or it'll say send
everything over there,
hit OK and now it's updating it.
Now it's using what's called an
extrapolation factor in order to do that.
What that means is.
That extrapolation factor is what makes
the time grow or shrink.
The extrapolation factor could be a
cross-sectional area,
it could be the length,
it could be the weight.
It's whatever you've chosen to do in the
system.
And so say at well and cuts going to be
different here,
but if something's done by the length
then pull.
It's using whatever the standard length
is in order to make that grow or shrink.
So it's in other words,
you're not going to be at the same time
on one inch piece of stainless plate as
you are on 1/8 stainless plate because
the extrapolation factor looks at the
properties of it to make a grow or shrink
so.
So now we should have times in the
statements plate now.
So is it is it run statements at .
31 where car will be .
28 density or is it not even is it not
even understand that it it it can,
it does, it can.
But it,
but that's pretty much just for the the
weight of that, right?
So you're putting in the weight of the
piece when you put the size in.
So in other words,
it's not doing the conversion unless you
want it to.
So like a piece of quarter inch plate is
10.
2 lbs per square foot for stainless is 11.
16 lbs per square foot.
We enter that or it knows that when you
put in that that quarter inch plate,
then you you're putting in that.
Yeah.
Now there is a way to take it in the
initial setup.
There is a way to take the whole database
of the of the card and say convert this
and it will convert it for you.
That won't do that one. Yeah, I.
Yeah.
So,
so now we have time for stainless plate.
Now what should happen going forward?
Let let's say if you added like three
quarter inch stainless plate and you you
would still have to come back into here
to get add to add that three quarter inch
so.
So just because we add a a shape,
random size to production,
it doesn't be just added to correct,
correct.
So that is that is something you got to
keep an eye on and a lot of times I'll be
honest with you.
Estimators don't catch that.
Like if if an estimator went in and they
had put in the stainless plate in an
estimate,
they could put it in the estimate.
But because it wasn't here,
there would be no time.
And a lot of times the estimators just
crank it out. They're just.
Entering the pieces,
not really paying attention and don't
notice that it's not adding all the
layers.
So this is something like 12 like I said
displays out of 12 meetings.
So that's for the that's for the standard
size.
So you see up at the top we've got one of
the corners selected at the top.
Quarter by 12 standard length of two foot
so that it uses that for that
extrapolation. What's 1212 inches?
12 inches, yes.
There's stainless plate that's 12 inches.
It's it's it's not.
You can't.
It's not saying that's a that's a flat
mark. It is not saying that, OK.
It's just saying that plate when I'm
looking at it to to make my.
Yes,
to make my make that extrapolation factor
work.
So say if we said that it was a it was
based off of the square footage,
it has to have a starting point.
So the starting point for this is 1 foot
by two foot and then when you say I'm
ordering a four foot by 8 foot.
Yeah, it's just the starting point.
It's all it is. So like you had zero,
right? Yep,
right side and all the the time it takes
to work on stainless.
Each one of those is a little bit longer
for stainless than it is for steals.
So those will all have to be updated. Yes,
for sure, yeah.
Yeah,
so I would expect to then come in here
and say, cool,
I got some times in here that might be
proportionately right to each other,
but I want all of those to go up about
25% or something.
You go change that and then pass up all
those stable sizes.
Now I understand how the bad control guys
think this is all the bad control.
Yeah, yeah, it is. You said the bad word.
You said the F word. Yeah. Fortunately,
I didn't have all of them. Yeah.
I've converted a lot of fat troll people.
One of my guys that works with me said,
yeah, well, then Jason, I think came out.
Jason was like, Jason was like, yeah,
I'm a recovering fat troll guy.
Some little different,
but it was doing this morning was rather
than this, uh, left hand corner.
It's just saying I like you said you have
to. Yeah.
Keith said they're just keep a touch in
their crap.
They're not even looking at the timeline.
So it really needs to be picked.
So it does, yeah.
That part of my job,
I've been told it's gonna be precon.
I'll be working with your clients.
Oh I have, yeah.
And the people and the issues like they
think about this, but not 100%, right?
Yeah,
since the update it's been that's
typically the network disconnection or so.
Like that is what that technically is.
Yeah, it keeps working.
There's two people that own this,
this building.
Garbage is more of the order.
Mark is more of the director.
Oh, all right.
Not doing anything.
Usually after that other air it you're
you're sunk anyway.
Yeah.
I don't know if I mentioned it or not,
so tell me shut up if I have the.
The permissions for this,
I know you said you adjusted permissions.
The the cleanest I've ever seen shapes
great sizes.
It was at a shop where nobody had
permission to update shapes great sizes
except for admin and even the admin had
an alternate log.
So that he when he was importing,
it wouldn't allow him to change anything,
shapes, grade, sizes, yeah,
it's very locked and I think yeah,
I almost wonder if that's the case,
if I need to not have the function so
that way.
It's just can,
so that way it might be the important.
Once we once we get it cleaned up better,
then the goal was to have it go down with
one person.
But everything was quieter than the floor.
Yeah, and that was part of the problem.
Yeah, too many people in there.
Great idea.
I've been to companies where they had
that.
And.
We're doing it.
Purchasing people were doing it.
Other people were doing it. Like, yeah,
15 different people had access.
We started cleaning everything up.
Then we got about two to three weeks in
and we realized that they were clean.
That's it.
We've got to go in and clean it up.
**** just comes. They were.
So is that right? That's it.
Let's do the permissions first.
And then start making better products.
Waste a lot of time.
You can go to one or two weeks and say
you can actually fix this.
We don't really.
We don't estimate utilizing software.
We don't want them. Yeah, makes sense.
So I'm used to also places that have a
library,
a dictionary that tells you how to name
stuff. I mean,
I think that Tecla does it in the Tecla
way.
I assume everybody follows the Tecla way,
even though I'm against.
I'm used to plating 36.
I'm not used to a 36 plate and so the
technical way is a material range first,
right? No, no, that's plating.
It's always shade. Always plating. OK,
some companies do it the other way.
Well,
that may be that may be the case with
tech structures. And yeah,
you would think tech structures and tech
the power plant would be one in the same,
but they're not.
Everybody's wanted them to do that for
forever and they just never have.
So.
Is everybody going on water?
Does anybody do anything? All good.
Yeah.
You got money. Is that you? You got money.
I know money. Yeah. So money.
I'm trying to think of his last name.
But yeah, I know money. Yeah,
I hear he's the he's.
He he knows what he's doing. Yeah, yeah,
he's a good guy.
Yeah,
I think that with all the shapes that you
added, this is probably gonna need to be.
Fixed up as well.
If we are fixing grades or shapes or any
of those in like shapes and size of
maintenance,
is that updated in test 3 or do we have
to then go back and do the same task
essentially?
Update like if we remove a grade or we
remove a dimension like we realized like
that one was, yeah, not a a size, right?
So if we remove that,
but it was at some point added to.
The estimating do we need to then also
remove it from there or to say if it's
updated in just the shape and size,
is it updated? So if you add a a shape or?
Turn on a shade,
kind like you did with the stainless,
then it needs to be added here.
Grades will automatically get added
because it doesn't really affect the
labor side of it.
It's just you can utilize it within the
estimate and I understand that.
But we don't have all of it filled out
like the plan should or whatever, right.
And we if we update the way they are
going to update it in estimating, no.
So let's let's take it. Well,
it depends on what it is.
Let me let me rephrase that.
It depends on what it is. So like.
Say for instance,
the flange width that gets used whenever,
let's say some an estimator is putting in
a beam in an estimate and then there's
the coats field and he goes and puts 2
coats on it.
At that point in time it says cool,
let me go see what the flange width is.
And then it's going to figure how much
burden time it has.
So it will that gets updated.
But if let's say the cross-sectional area
is not in there and then you come in here
and you put in labor standards.
And add that size in the labor standards.
That cross-sectional area is at that
point in time used to populate the labor
standard.
So if you then go back later and put in
the cross-sectional area in Shakespeare
sizes.
It's not going to come back in and change
the time here.
So it it it depends on where it is,
which I know that can be frustrating
maybe, but but yeah, if you if you add.
The.
Say a plan you with,
don't worry about updating anything and
estimating. You do cross-sectional area.
Yeah, you need to go change.
You need to go at that time. OK,
so it updates some, but not yes,
and and it's just because of the way that
it functions in the background.
When it adds that time for like the the
coats,
it's happening at the point that I that I
that I do it in the estimate whereas with
when it adds the time for for cutting
based off a cross-sectional area it's.
It's a field in here and that field only
gets updated when I put it in here,
so it's not going to go update it later.
So does it warn?
You said it warns you for the lights.
There was that one report for for no
weight.
But what if there's no labor?
Is there a warning there's no labor? No.
I mean, you see it,
you can see it for sure,
but there's it's not going to jump up and
down and smack you in the face.
And in in actually what happens more
times than not is not that there's no
labor, but there's.
Some labor.
So standard labor in your shop. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. But you know,
it's not going to tell you if, hey,
you don't have cut time,
but but I do have handling time, right?
It's it's not going to show you so.
So it don't pick up a portion of it at
all. It really needs to be gone through.
Yeah, as well. Yeah.
So here is critical to get it all the
time. So yeah.
Because like that stainless plate,
if I had put a hole in that stainless,
let's say I put stainless plate in an
estimate, I would get no time for cutting,
handling, fed up, laying out.
But let's say I put a hole in it.
I would still have time for the whole
because it goes to a different part of
the database to pull that.
It's not necessarily dependent on the
shapes, pretty sizes.
So it's pretty mature here.
Yeah, the estimators come in today too.
They'll they'll build in. They'll have.
Yeah,
there's you have it laid out so that they,
like, the second-half of the day. Yeah,
I just wondered.
Just just to make sure everybody
understands to like click on the hit hit
add down at the bottom.
And then do FB is the one that let's do
flat bar.
It's the one that happens all the time.
With what I'm about to show you now hit
OK, OK,
so right there it's saying there's no
flat bar sizes that exist in the system
that are not in the estimate,
but you'll you'll find that from time to
time as sizes get added and whatnot.
So like try try it on Pl.
Let's let's add Pl. again.
So those right there are sizes that are
in shapes,
grade sizes that are not in the estimate.
Now I doubt very seriously you're gonna
add 25 inch plate to the estimate, right?
But like.
One and three sixteens. I mean,
you're not really buying that nice,
but 10 gauge, 11 gauge, 10 gauge,
16 gauge, 18 gauge. Yeah,
it's not considered playing, but yeah,
I'm cheap.
So that's the kind of thing you got to
kind of watch for.
I'm saying it doesn't mean sheet.
I'm used to seeing. Yeah, I have to.
And you'll notice that it did add times
in for those that we just added sometimes.
But yeah, cut time,
you'll get piece times you're handling
with plate. With plate,
the cutting comes from a burn function,
so it's it's not gonna come on that line
item breakable.
So yeah.
So yeah, any anytime a size gets added,
make sure all the properties are there
and then it's so why is that operation
not in there?
What the burn?
It's a it's a separate area.
So there's a in in what's called labor
code.
The labor code tells it says look at the
width of the length of it,
then go to a burn table that's separate
from this right here to go get your burn
rate and then it figures the.
It is in the system already, the permit,
just like the whole was for a thing,
correct? Yeah. Is that how roll will work?
Go look at a table for rolling.
Rolling doesn't look at a table,
but there's other ways to put it in there.
The background of the estimate you can
get a lot of your time will come from
these.
Standards here,
but then some of your time will come from
a Weld table, a burn table, a drill table,
and then there's also what's called like
estimate extras,
where you can create a formula to add
time into into.
Yeah.
So it's it's not like there's one set
place that all the labor comes from.
It could be multiple places.
So it's it's very dynamic,
which is it's difficult when you're first
learning the system.
But what's great about it is it's very,
very customizable, so.
Everything.
Yep.
So.
Any good on that? What's TSP guys?
I assume seal.
But why do you guys use tube steel and
HSSS? Yeah, good question.
I don't think you are, are you?
Yeah. Another place I work,
they got me to see. Yes,
they just called the HSS. Me too. Yeah.
Yeah. So it's not activated. OK.
So we quit the HSS, right? Yeah.
So we have to use, OK.
But eventually you're going to vaporize
those or not like you're regular or you
don't care with it not being activated.
They're not accurate. It's that matter.
Yeah, it won't pull up to right.
I don't want to say any don't care,
but let's say I'm going to just be silly
here.
You get something from Shuff and Shuff
decides they want to use TS. They use TS.
I'm not saying they do because they don't,
but they use TS and you don't have it
activated and all of a sudden.
You're going to get.
I don't know what would happen actually,
because you're probably estimating
straight from their tables. From that one,
since it's a labor take off only,
it would we're just putting in well
parameters or cut parameters at that
point.
It would stop and ask if if it if TS were
coming in,
it's it's gonna say what do you want this
to be? Yeah.
Now you could actually set it up to where
if it saw TS,
it would actually just change it to HSS.
Yeah, that'd be a good idea.
It's not the import questions.
If it recognizes a that's or doesn't
recognize a that we use or it doesn't
recognize when the shape nor the
dimension it called and all.
For for us to update it and then once we
update it to whatever we do use, um,
then it asks if we wanna make this like a
permanent change so that it it recognizes
it for everyone. Um.
Do you guys report it like once a day,
once a week, once a month?
It's for every hour.
So it depends how much workflow we get
from the Gilbert office.
It could be several times a day or.
So you want this to be really efficient,
right? Yes, yes.
I hope so. Uh, I can see that.
I'd like to see you doing this constantly.
Every job is important. So yeah, anytime.
Well,
I see it's easy with Gilbert 'cause
you're on the same database,
but it seems harder if you're getting it
from all these other.
Customers, yeah,
we we typically tend to have our,
you know,
if we get a package and we we send it to
our detailer, correct.
That's a mix bag like for the shop
contact,
the TSMC that we just got last week,
we asked them if they could do a a IFC
model export that would.
We can correlate tests with the models,
so if we can request them to change it
before, then we're looking good,
but if not,
then we're going with their criterias and
we're either battling it or reporting it,
yeah.
You want to look at.
Uh, seriously.
What do we have to get through before,
Ron, before Estimating joins? What? When?
When they join?
Sorry, what was that?
Somebody said that the meeting's gonna
join at sometime.
I know we're gonna get feedback from
Jared. Do you know that one?
But you don't know if there's anybody,
so like not running this for the estimate.
I'm just wondering what we have to cover
for. I'll ask 1000 questions. Yes,
because I I think you're good on shakes,
great sizes really, right.
It's a really we're kind of down into the
estimating part of today's agenda.
Which we kind of started touching on a
little bit with bringing in the stainless
and everything over there.
Do we need to I think we can get get into
it.
I know they have a lot of critical
estimates to do today,
but there's a few things that we already
know we got to have the cross section
dimensions.
Some of the integrators are added,
but I don't want to jump into that now
unless anyone has the new kickback. Do it.
Are are you? Are you wanting? Oh,
you're talking about jumping into
estimates? Is that what you're saying? OK,
there's something.
It's.
Yes, as far as like that first point,
estimating aluminum stainless shapes and
sizes set up,
that's kind of what we did a minute and
never in that stainless plate and that's
going to have to be done for all of those
shapes.
I don't know if we want to go ahead and
do it.
I mean,
is this a we need we wanna do session or
is this a we'll talk about it and and
that's your homework thing.
OK.
That's the way we can hear.
So far on some of this stuff. Yeah,
we've got a personnel change and we're
actually not doing anything. Yeah.
So as much as we can get done while
you're president, yeah,
it makes me feel very good.
Then let's do it. I like. I like to do.
It needs to be done.
And correct me if I'm wrong,
but I want to see where the keeper is
over this location of tech web and then
you hear you know Mark and Gavin and and
Alan will update estimating.
Teach them and train them when they need
it. Yeah.
And they're like utilizing our software
that we own. Yeah. And that's, that's,
you've had a couple of conversations with
that over the ones they're estimating our
shop, not the other way around.
Yes. So and they are not. They're so busy.
Yeah, that they just can't.
They can't all join and participate in.
But sometimes it seems like we just don't
care. Well, yeah, I'm,
I'm glad you have the, the, the,
the thought process. This is our time.
In other words,
what I'm hearing is it needs to be the
actual time.
So many estimators are like they don't.
They could care less about actual time.
They're more like I want the hours to be
here because I know I can sell it.
They're looking for selling hours rather
than they're looking for actual hours,
which is to me.
Incredibly wrong.
So that's the way 90% of the escalators
have to do with the ability to believe it
or not.
So especially our thought is if we own it
and then they're utilizing it to do their
estimates,
we feel comfortable with their estimates
where now Mark is looking over.
Everything,
every line is going through and it's just
not efficient. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
I agree. So you do a Tecla review, Mark,
where you do a heavy bid review. No,
I do Tecla review.
I request to be brought in with heavy,
heavy bid,
but they dump Tecla in the heavy bid.
Uh,
we're porting for the guess at that point.
Oh, so let's add some then.
I I guess I got a question too like on
this right here.
Do we need to get more sizes in for
stainless angle before updating
estimating? You know what I'm saying?
So like.
So.
Let's start with.
I need to get some in.
There's not a way to import like
Ryerson's book. You you can import. Yeah,
I mean with the Chris, they I would be.
So that's what I'm looking at right now.
There's a way to the difference will be
the weight, right? So that's.
It's it's been a while since I've had it
converted.
What's stupid is the stainless angle will
run the same pounds per foot that has
parts,
but stainless plate has a different count
per square foot than the carbon footing.
Sorry, I don't actually take it. So .
19 lbs per foot for both departments.
It's the dumbest thing ever.
That's the way Ryerson sell it.
I did not realize that. Huh.
I knew there was a slight difference in
the in the way.
Yeah.
Well, I.
So what we can do,
we can't export the angle from here from
the L and then reimported this SSA
because the.
For samples,
like we can't do that with the shape.
So we're saying Alan was if we export the
angle for target then you can just change
the grade and if we import that.
So go to the I if you go to the drop down
and go to export export to ASCII the
other top one.
And then get rid of everything.
Just pull angle over.
And save it wherever you want.
Cool. Go open that up.
What we're going to do,
we're going to find and replace.
We're going to say find L and replace it
with SSL is what we're going to do in
that text file that it exported.
But you're telling me once I have it in
text,
I can manipulate it any which way I want?
Yep. Oh, I can even do a lot with that,
yeah.
OK,
so now obviously we don't want to take
all the LS and change it to SSL, but um,
so go to edit and.
Then replace.
And find L replace SSL.
And what I would do is just hit the down
arrow cause.
We don't want to do that.
We don't want to do the next one, right?
You're just going to get down to where
shapes included is the next one.
Keep on going.
There now hit replace.
And I'd probably replace the rest of them.
Yeah, say that again.
I'm trying to think if there's going to
be an L anywhere else. Yeah,
you can probably do replace all after
that.
Shoot, it did it even up top,
but it's not gonna matter.
Those are just comments. Yeah,
they're just comments.
They're not gonna really matter.
But see where it says shapes included.
Do fix that and and change the shape
there.
Yeah, there we go.
I think we should be good. Otherwise,
can you scroll down this?
All the way down. Yeah,
I don't think you'll be able to get those
angles. They don't exist.
Yeah, 1212138,
that'd be interesting to try to find.
I don't think that exists that would be
my 70.
I'm not staying the same one,
but it's been so long that I.
OK, cool.
Just save that and close it and then
we'll import that back in.
Are you used to operating at this level
of what he just showed you?
Just normal for you?
Just go to the drop down at the top of
the end shapes, great size and then go.
Oh no, you do need to get a file,
file and import.
And Scroll down in that list.
Shapes great sizes, yeah.
In this case, we want to choose the SSL.
Is it a pending or overriding? It is.
I think it's going to ask us on a few
that are in there.
They don't want to ask us on those.
It would kick some out.
Everything.
It's not a floating point value, is that?
Huh. Like, yeah, I didn't like that.
2-3, but all of.
What are being point bag? No, go up to.
Let's get a shape maintenance and make
sure that the stainless and the and the
angle are set up.
Identically.
Yeah,
and then the number of variables I didn't
want is different than the number of
variables we sent it. Yeah,
something's different about it.
So go to the drop down at the top and go
to shape maintenance.
You can probably export both of them
apparently.
With inches.
See if, uh, see the stainless angle.
Let's see if that's the same.
OK, the property is different.
Hit dimension format properties about the
middle of the page here.
Go on down and yeah, there you go.
So three and six, OK.
So angle was just 6 unit weight,
cross-sectional area and K distance.
So I think that might be the problem.
Um, so how do we fix it?
So which one has the K distance?
The angle? The carbon? Yep.
But do you want the K in sandals?
Are you using SSL somewhere in the system
right now or has it just been set up?
You know if it's being used in production
or anything?
Go up to the drop down at the top Shape
Maintenance drop down.
Uh, well, close this then.
And go down to SSL here.
You're gonna try to make it a sense. Well,
what I'm gonna look at,
there's no way to change it after it's
been set up.
So what I'm gonna look at is if it's
being used anywhere.
If it's not being used anywhere,
it's gonna be an easy thing just to leave
it.
And do it over again.
So go to the drop down at the top.
Now shape grade size maintenance show
where the selected dimension grade is
used.
Yep, it's in inventory,
inventory history too, so it's being used.
Um.
Yeah, not a lot of times.
You buy all of this.
Yeah, so.
Um.
We could.
Is that a real job? The AZR?
Is it closed? Yeah. What is?
We think how we could do this.
Yeah, boy, boy. Yeah,
cuz we can't change those properties
after the fact on the piece. Um.
See.
Probably doesn't make any difference,
probably on white.
I want to say what we're currently
working on in this job would be outside
of tech planning is because we're being
and now we're adding all of the
mechanical sewage on tracking.
So I mean we might be OK,
we'll just do it again.
If this is not only showing, yeah,
that's uh.
That would be a deleting of it, though,
in order to get back in there.
That was sure.
So here here would be the option. Um.
The.
We don't change it and you have to get
all the sizes in there manually or we try
to manipulate the text file somehow.
To get that property out of there,
what's the repercussion? Well,
if it wouldn't be in the job,
you wouldn't have record of what you did,
you know it wouldn't cost.
The cost wouldn't show you if I purchased
it, it'd be completely gone to you. Yeah.
So I was here.
So after that it was no purchase,
it just wouldn't show you cost.
Your vendor might not get paid.
And we add the correct one and then this
one.
So then we're not do you change the name
of the one that you have currently exact
to a bogus name and then create a new one?
You could, yeah, yeah,
like changing SSA or something like that
and then we set up SSAL and then.
All stuff would still be in there for the
job and already purchased it for it and
then you got going forward and everybody
would use SSL and put SSA as not. Yeah,
yeah, we could do it that way. Yeah.
Now you know, I'm,
I'm guessing that that's the the issue
too.
I think it probably is,
but I'm guessing that's it.
We could walk through this and then try
important and not work. Yeah,
but I believe that's probably the issue.
We wanted to pull the case and stuff.
Start.
How many do you guys watch?
They do.
I'm trying to think where the system
actually uses it. Really,
if we want to close now,
we're paying it off through our.
ACPC. So it's all current.
I'm I'm thinking that the.
I don't think it actually uses the pay
distance anywhere other than a reference.
I think you might be able to use it if
you wanted to in a formula,
maybe in estimating,
but that would be a custom thing,
so it may not actually be using it at all
either right now.
Oh.
You.
Site. Yeah, that's the problem. Yep, Yep.
And then is there any?
Manipulate the file so it's not looking
at that.
We'd have to figure out what it's not,
what it's looking at that it's tripping
out on,
and we'd have to manipulate the file to
do that.
What's your thought we might create?
Why don't we create SSA and then try to
do the import to see if it OK, yeah.
And then if it doesn't import,
then we know the importer isn't gonna
work anyways. Yeah,
versus trying to go in there because if
we're gonna have to manually add them
anyways, then yeah,
we might as well leave SSL along. It is,
yeah.
Yeah, let's try then.
It.
You want to get a shape, right? Yeah,
the shape maintenance.
What I would do is go to angle,
just go to L and then when you hit new
shape it just copies it.
Yep.
And so it just basically copied what
angle heads. Look what it is here.
Angle we're going 1363136.
Yeah,
but the one that's highlighted is what
it's going to choose,
which has that property of shoot.
We want to like,
we do want to change it to the.
This is what we want. Yeah. Yeah. So yeah,
this is what we want.
Because this is exactly what the angle is.
So when we import it back in properties
are all be the same that just the just
the one you got selected.
So like the the stainless angle was the
one.
I think just above this one,
which is the the line that says no, yes,
38, the second line down,
I think that's what the stainless angle
was set up as. Yeah,
three for the property, yeah.
So yeah, so that's what we want.
Just hit add shape now down at the bottom.
Well,
you got to get a description up there as
well.
Yeah, and then just ask you. Yep.
So now let's go to change your um.
Change your, uh, this is the next file,
yeah.
Go,
go to your text file and change it from
SSL to SSA and then we import. Yeah,
so will take the structure.
Interact with us.
If your detailer gets on Tecla Structures
2025, then yeah,
those this can be passed over to the to
their database.
So would he if he uses K in his detail?
No,
because what's going to come across in
the import will not be the K value,
but it will be the it'll be the just the
size and the shape and the length,
not the K value.
If you get a,
if you go to edit and replace up there,
then you can do it that way.
So let's do SSL and then change it to SSA.
Right now.
And you could probably replace all here.
Yep.
This will not work for the meeting.
This will not work for the channel.
The white, is that what you're saying?
Dimensionally different, yeah.
Yeah,
it's it's almost like a like a beam is
just, yeah,
the the totally different sizes. Yeah,
I get what you're saying.
Yeah, it does. It was that setting.
I think what it was that had the K value
in there and then when the when it didn't
have the K value in that shape set up,
it was freaking out.
I haven't received it.
It's not a slot to receive it exactly.
Well, now you let it go in.
I guess we then decide,
do you want to go through changing that
job and everything from SSL to SSA? Well,
excuse me, yeah, we can change it to SSA,
then delete SSL out, then.
Change SSA to SSL if we decide if we want
to do that.
Or do you just want to add the sizes as
you get them and you have to add them in
the stainless as well?
Cutless and purchasing and everything
done here.
Yeah, yeah, that's going to be difficult.
No, not yet. We'd have to.
We'd have to tell it to.
Well, I.
Once we figure out if we're going to use
the SSA or not.
It's gonna be difficult for you because
it's already been purchased and
everything if we go changing it.
She's leaving,
gets it say and then going forward,
just use that as I said all along.
How are you doing? We haven't set a table.
I bet you don't want to do that. No,
I think you got it.
You need to go back to the type of
standard, yeah.
I don't think of an easy way of changing
that one.
Look at some.
I mean,
you guys are spending this hour and hours
with all these factors. Yeah,
I can see that it's a bunch of better.
Yes, it's tossing.
What you're doing all the time, right?
Important videos.
I think that they had a secret.
There's no way to change that property.
Um, that is very.
That's what we were talking about.
We have that separate database, right?
This is our old database.
There is the reason why we do.
It's the.
So we tried to add the sizes for SSL,
which is the same as single.
We'll be able to use that for me because
the values are the same.
They're looking to.
So now I'm trying to figure out.
OK.
I'll be honest with you, I think.
So the easiest fix is gonna be to take
that value out of the text file and
import it back into the SSL.
Because it's technically not used
anywhere. It's informational purposes.
Let me see if I can reference that in
estimating real quick.
But they're not perfect speeds as I mean
data.
Say it again.
RSV's which is like construction
construction cost data as a database for
labor or inspect.
It's updated annually.
When I got into this program this year
and a half ago at ASB and prior to that
too.
Right back in California,
they were starting this, but.
It was all set up for when I got there
and but they were well,
they had to use the party at all when I
was there.
So they went through the whole community
with another gentleman Ricky Soft.
They sat around the entire week and but
yeah, they already had.
Something in the database they were just
using.
So um.
I don't see that the K I I can't even
reference the K just that's an estimated
in for a formula,
so I don't think it's really used.
I'd almost pull it out of that text file
and import it in. Yeah,
so we'd have to figure out the where it
is in that text file.
I think that's going to be your easiest
solution.
So let me see if I can see what the what
we're looking for here.
Uh,
I'll look at 1 by 1 by 3 sixteenths maybe.
Well, I'll look at.
I'll look at 1 by 1 by 1/8.
Gate distance is .25.
There it is right there.
So I'm thinking here's here's gonna be
the fun part is.
I'm thinking if we took that out.
To where it's blank,
then it's probably going to.
Importing and we can probably try it is 1
by 1 by 1/8 in in stainless angle right
now.
Well,
the only problem would be is that there's
.25 anywhere else in the in the document,
because it's going to be different for
each one, you know.
Mm.
How many line items are there?
Wonderful.
Hey, what's the easy way to edit that?
I'm wondering if we could do it in like a
sequence on the line.
So it's number whatever, right? Yeah,
you need to hit that location on all
lines to make sure they're all.
The .25 is gone, right?
So you export it to Excel. Yeah,
you export it into Excel using the
columns as the separators.
It'll throw it into Incel and you have a
position here. Then we zero that out,
then back into Excel, right? Yeah,
probably be the easiest way.
Let's try it.
And once again, on December day,
if we take that out, it's going to work.
We'll we'll find out.
Good. Good.
That's the limited file into Excel.
So I'll put it in the comments.
It may work. I'll grab your comment.
That should it should work.
So it will work.
I didn't realize we're going to be this
far in the meets of this last week.
Definitely in there.
We are in the meetings. Yeah, we are. Oh,
man. Yeah, but it's cool.
It's like these little guys out there.
It's good, I think. Good for them.
Yeah, yeah.
Good. Yeah, finished. Yeah, next.
Delivers.com.
Thank you. Yeah, that's what she.
Yes. Oh, OK. What are you gonna do?
You can make all zero.
We want to delete it.
You can just click on the one corner and
go. It's gone. You don't have to do. Yeah,
click on McKenny.
At the top, the whole log.
So now the delete button. Don't do that.
Yeah, go on the top.
It's if you delete it,
it moves everything over.
So when we go back to text,
we need the comments back. That's.
That's beyond muted. Go ahead and exit.
Save that so you keep it. You'll save.
Now go to export and see if you can
export it as an asking.
Can you smile?
That's, uh, the tap that we would do.
It's it's a value format.
That's the level right there. CSV.
It's yeah.
Change the name so you don't provide the
other one.
OK, that's the CSV,
but we'll be able to import CSV.
I think so. What was it called before?
Text angle dot CSV.
So just rename the file.
Just do it. Yes,
rename is denangled dot CMC.
That doesn't work.
I think I I think I got Chat EBT to just
remove it too.
We'll find out.
Yeah.
So I think you need to change it.
You have a CSV file in there that you
need to make the text file.
And then don't override it.
Call it S angle wherever you want to keep
the old one just in case you want if you
want it.
And we'll try and develop.
It's now it's CSB angle,
call it angle pass or whatever.
Change the name this extension or like
you you got to change, add something,
something in there. There you go.
That will now you can go to CSP.
It's changed CST, right?
Is it that simple?
It's gonna warn you.
I actually can do the follow up.
OK.
You can see where it.
Yeah.
We're not there in London.
I don't care anything you don't care.
No program right here. Well,
that's why you say with spaces,
sometimes it does care to how it should
be the deliberative.
That's what I said.
What are you doing? We want to do SSL,
right? Yes.
OK, didn't like it.
I got one that I I cleaned it up in in
ChatGPT and just imported it back in to
stainless angle and it seemed to work.
Let me make sure I've got weight and K
value or cross-sectional area.
Um.
I think I.
I'm good right now.
But but go ahead if you.
It looks like what I did here worked.
Let's confirm. Wait, go to. Well,
I can do it here. Go to the quarter.
4.1.
Are you only in the same class?
What's that? You're not working. Yeah,
he gave the code. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, what's that? This.
This seem to work.
You want me to e-mail it to you?
I I took it and cleaned it up. Well,
I had it take that out of there and I
didn't think it liked ours because it.
I imported back in. I mean,
look at this real quick,
just make sure there's nothing that you
see that jumps out at you,
but I think everything's good.
It brought all these shapes in as the
weight cross-sectional area.
Now I just took the default
out-of-the-box. I'm I I don't have yours,
but I could probably take yours and I'm
gonna export your e-mail.
I could have ChatGPT clean it up and then
send it to you. Yeah,
you want me to send it over to you? Yeah,
I mean, I don't know if if you've got.
Different sizes that we need.
Than what I had.
So you need a job.
That and.
Last week, about five or six weeks,
I forget the name of the project,
but I I remember,
I'm pretty sure it was you I talked to
several times that we we were struggling.
You guys were struggling to meet schedule
or something and I had to keep coming out.
Here we worked it out. It's it's RHSCOM.
Yeah, you at fabricationis.com. Yeah,
that's great. Yeah, we'll see.
There is that.
Yeah, I learned a lot about the engine.
Oh, OK.
And then I didn't understand seven months
of everything, just fantastic with other.
All that stuff. So yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's the Sheffield management.
It's quite a different it chefs the about
a big chef and because just the
management is dependent on the fact that
you need. Yeah, they can get products.
Every single one.
Hello. How are you? I'm here. Oh, OK.
Yeah. We used to work quite,
quite a good part. We used to. Oh, yeah,
here. Yeah. Oh, OK. And we're together.
We're solving the entire.
Yeah, he's only a couple guys.
I saw on the screen a few minutes ago
again named Christopher Galski.
He's still a deputy of his and his wife.
I saw Stray Con on the screen. Yeah,
I believe it.
They should have. But yeah,
first the guys, he still works.
He's one of the guys sitting there at
5:00 PM.
Most of the people are from all quiet.
They're not really. Yeah,
I thought that was a a few Q&
A with them.
I used to work with you that more maybe
like 12 years ago.
OK.
Yeah.
And that was one of my maybe two years
ago. I had a interview with them just,
you know,
to see what the weather was like.
And that was one of the things that I see
in their retention reviews. Basically,
the people did that morning talk.
They they didn't. They wanted.
Well, yeah,
when they go out and do like all day and
you want everybody to do that all the way
down. Yeah, I see. We parted with this.
I'm like, yeah, so.
So this is the one we were talking about
messaging back and forth. Is that the one?
Oh,
that's really what do you have to do on
this? Honestly,
we're just filling out a AQ and A just to
see if we qualify to see it. OK,
that's great.
So it'll just a bunch of questions on
clients.
See, you shouldn't be involved.
We're not doing. No,
I didn't pay my salesman pitch.
That one wasn't. It didn't.
It's not comma delimited.
It's not commonly limited.
Maybe export it out again and send it to
me and then it'll clean it.
It didn't know what to.
Dix 'cause I didn't see nothing.
I can't cut anything over 2030,
so anything over 2030 though process. Oh,
it's it's massive, yes.
It's something we have to do this maybe
three, maybe four other.
But I mean,
a company like that is going to be
shopping. I can imagine that.
So who owns this? Who? Like,
who gives this to you in setting chase
this? This one specifically. Oh,
you have to get out. Yeah, that's right.
There you go.
I think I think it came from. Yeah,
they'll tell us to do stuff like this
sometimes if they don't.
We understand.
I'm just having this chase on these
things.
So we're just doing the footwork right
now.
I'm just busy working and then then
they'll get into the estimate part.
That's going to be shifting.
That's what I think.
That's where I think my recommendation
would be.
That's good. See, I wouldn't even be,
you know, yeah,
you're not still still anything I would
do, but I can live with this thing. OK,
I mean.
From here sometimes,
you know through background there's whole
more,
more weight problems getting this meeting.
You're dreaming, you know, we're,
you know we're waiting to find. So that's.
Because we kind of looked at the same,
you know,
we're going to have to follow along to
stop. Well, that's right. Makes no sense,
you know.
I mean,
this is taking anybody with experience,
even at all to see that,
but coming from somebody with experience.
But here's my experience.
I did that in my last hour,
which is why they told me to found what
they said, yeah.
That's why I told Mark,
I'm staying in my lane here.
Yeah, you when you said that,
that's above my name as well.
I like chasing those kids, remember? Yeah,
but we're going to do it all in different
shops and I'll be like,
bring us some money.
I will tell you the sunscreen is the sun
did 100 scales with they only had a thing
I could prove.
And it's $40 million worth of work and
they're they're going to do it with 18,
but they figured it out.
So I think you'd be surprised what you
can and can do.
Because skids,
the pipes are not big if you integrate
them.
Whereas if you were asked to handle it
before, you couldn't even handle it,
but you like physically couldn't do it
with a skin.
You could do it because the parts are are
manageable. Yeah,
I think the hard part about the skin was,
you know,
we're not a tight shot and then you come
to fight.
And then the sample assembly offers.
So it was gonna like you do a portion and
then yeah, focused, you know,
the guys in the float field are webcast,
right? Correct. Yes,
they're totally like fabrication.
Question of the stainless type guys, yeah,
which I think they're not.
All right, just send it back to you.
That's what I'm trying to figure out the
other shops and.
Hey Richard,
have you worked with Metro before? Metro?
No, they're leading in fact live.
One of our thinking was our annual
training that we put in this preliminary
intro to to them.
So I'm just curious if they have reached
out to you. I haven't worked with them.
Are you guys import? Yeah,
I I wanted to check GPT and told it to in
this position zero all those out and then
I imported it back in and it works.
I had theirs.
Chase, you guys have,
you guys have a license here or got it's
all free free free.
But we're you know we're gonna bring to
the question because Chase at the top,
Chase or Daniel said that's about saying
you guys use AI as much as you can.
So now we're in the case.
I've been experimenting with Chad and
Todd and Gemini,
and Gemini just stepped up their game.
No.
For free we use file,
but I actually get my funny questions.
Yeah, so you got to be real careful.
I got the paid version of ChatGPT and.
Works pretty well. I'm working on a.
I'm actually recording this.
I'm working on a.
A that will take all of my sessions that
I can just upload them to and like in the
background.
Tech was got a tech assistant where you
can ask a question. Yeah,
but it gives you pretty much the textbook
answers.
It's like OK, how do I do?
If you ask me what file to use for
control,
it said here's all the files I can use.
Whereas like I want my trainings in there
to be a what file should I use and my and
I want mine to come up and say never use
a kiss file, always use.
EFXC file.
I think there's the reasons why.
So that type stuff I'm I'm building into
an AI tool in order to get that.
Plus I wanted to do my reports for me as
well as at least get the base so I can.
Have the majority of the work done,
maybe if we're touching up so.
My son went,
he has a master's in data science and a
lot of that had to do with building AI
agents and so he's doing that for me.
So that's kind of cool.
But yeah, looks like this will work, yeah.
Hm.
I can tell you the name of a really,
really,
really large fabricator in the country
now.
In their city last, but um.
They have banned AI from their whole
organization. It's like, what? Really.
Yeah, they have banned it.
So it's like they're afraid people are
going to get their secrets and there's
their secrets.
And there's there might be good ways of
using stuff, but.
So they have paid in a I'm like holy cow.
They use all the free stuff all the time.
It's very Yeah, it's a problem.
But I had to use all three because I kept
running my questions.
I never use any other than.
How many questions do you get? Handful,
right? Then you got to wait six hours,
yeah.
They were good.
Oh.
By the way,
that that set up on that is not your
issue.
That was that's the way Tecla had to have
a box. It wasn't to be set up.
Sorry I checked.
I just checked to see that and it's it's
true that.
They don't have the K value in the
state's angle, but they do the regular so.
Do you think though they even if it was
falling over about you? Yeah, yeah.
Well, that one was the easy one.
I think the rest of them, if you ever do,
it's they're not as easy. Well,
if you get hit that drop right there.
See global edit.
I need to brush up on this.
It's been several years since I've used
this.
This is a way to convert weight in a
particular shape,
so I'm thinking we can use this by
bringing in the the.
Feel the carbon light and then have it
converted.
But I I've got to brush up on this.
It's been a while since I've used this,
so.
Might need to figure out,
figure out how to use this.
So what I'm thinking is I think we can
need more to then we come in here and say
change all these weights and it do that
math for us so.
As you can see, it's going from 1.9 to 5.
1 right there because of the 490 lbs per
cubic foot.
Maybe we try on one that we're not using.
We're not using, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we try to go to the density for
certain applications and design and I
just say all Harmony has a .
28 and all stainless is .31.
It doesn't globally do it in adventure
and in SolidWorks that way,
so you don't have to worry about house
per foot, house per square foot,
blah blah blah blah blah, yeah.
So like that right there.
What converted? How is it converted yet?
So if we got the right, yeah,
per cubic foot.
So put just since we're not using SSA,
just put in 400 or something.
Yeah.
And then push over all of it and then
we'll hit update.
Let's see if it changes to that.
So 1 by 1 by 1/8 should be .
651 then I'm guessing.
Getting the Snipping Tool like the
greatest in the world.
Thank.
If you're using tech now for the majority
of time,
or at least it's a different program.
Have you done something?
What is it that you did? Oh, OK, right.
So they're using that. Yeah,
to be like for the Miss Metals.
They'll do that portion here, export it,
and then add that to the heavy. Yeah,
they were all in Colorado.
I heard when I was here.
We're going to be here supposedly today,
yeah.
Yeah, it's not responsive.
Oh, that might have been mine.
It's I'm just saying.
I don't think you should have the right
people.
I spoke a little bit training last week
and it might be so, especially today,
just getting bad.
It's a thing.
I know they're pretty intense work around
the job for back down and now we have to
get involved. I was only a very.
Is that the same one that you're talking
about? What?
What do you think you guys are doing?
They're gonna give them.
My assumption is they're gonna give them
material price per section and the labor
table per section.
But for Ron was leading up with the
material, right?
And I haven't even met the guy yet,
but did they have to?
Model the whole thing. Yeah,
I'm not sure what they're doing.
I've been driving for three days.
But there's no build material there.
It's all take home. Take home. Yeah,
the interesting thing is that somebody
put back else in us based on the same
thing.
There's this many times on this side,
on this side. Yeah, yeah, there you go.
Yeah, it's like,
but there's no take off per se. No,
no stick take off. So in my mind,
I was asking Jeff to make somebody here
gonna model this thing and try to figure
it out.
So who you've been around?
Who would do this job? Who would?
What do you mean? Yeah, who would?
Who would do a job like this?
Who are the competitors going to be? Oh,
competitors. Yeah,
could do a job like that. Yeah,
still could do a job like that.
It's like a lot of people.
You're not even having these small shops
to do that, that's for sure.
So what's small? Is it small? No,
this is not small.
I think they have the ability here.
Small would be like T&
L or something like that,
a little tiny shops would be.
They'll be 44, I think so.
They have a lot of the latest,
greatest equipment.
They have the ability to, you know,
they're actually because they're so
automated,
they're actually extremely compatible
than anything in Arizona.
They they're talking to people.
But I want to get it done because they
really get set up.
We'll get an update.
I think it's still about how to be
another one.
We have to have an audit 'cause they're
doing some processing for us. They got,
they spot free paying out the fund. Yeah,
it's like they're doing 7 hour time work.
It won't will be a month.
Yeah.
But I can see you're being preserved
saying we should be touched.
It's gonna be all telling that people
have the equipment to just need this job.
It's true. They won't go ahead 15 minutes.
Go back to the global editing.
Hit the drop down for shadow. When you do,
I'll hear the same story. Yeah,
I don't even know what the capabilities
are. They want to be there.
Here's what I don't understand is why all
shapes don't show up there.
I'm not positive.
I never have figured that out,
but they're not all shapes are there.
Is SSL there?
Or SSPL's there.
See, I mean,
I don't know why they're not showing up
there, right?
Table somewhere, yeah, I mean.
I know certain shapes that have what's
called a dynamic dimension or dynamic
field in here.
It won't allow you to do it on those,
but if it has a property,
I think it would but.
Inhale.
So yeah, we'd have to see you.
So we could bring over some of the other
size and see if we could change it.
Jorge,
I'll get you to do it without if if it
doesn't show up here.
I'm sure.
Yeah.
Oh.
You want to keep doing that?
Keep working now.
Yeah, I might as well. Yeah,
I don't think so. That's the standard.
So we can involve all that over for SNP,
right? Yes, we do.
We make sure all of the sizes are read,
everything we want to move over 1st and
then jump into moving over that into. Um,
that way we're jumping back and forth.
Yeah, probably. Yeah,
you're saying update all this first thing
to overdestimate. Yeah,
you probably want to turn off SSA now too,
right? Because it's activated.
I guess we could actually delete it. Yeah.
Well,
is it still not in that other job though?
As I say it's not.
It was the whole placeholder. Oh,
that's right.
You'd have to get it to drop down top of
shape maintenance or you don't need it.
How scary. Hitting the lead in.
That is scary.
Anyone want to screw it up now? Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
Channel, but we can't.
Is channel the same in stainless as it is
in?
I I want to say it's different in in
stainless channel different than regular
channel. Yeah. So yeah,
I don't think we can even move it.
What can we move? What do we need to move?
I think the angle is an easy one.
I think the angle.
Yeah,
I think I might pipe should be the same
thing.
Like the weights are the weights are
based on weights. Yeah, that's true.
And I think if he's got a,
it looks like there's a tool to
manipulate the wave.
There's probably a way to do it.
I just don't know this program.
Let's so let's get the let's get an
import into there to get the sizes.
Yeah,
the size of the tubing pipe is the same,
just the weight would be slightly
different.
Yes,
you can then go export out the sizes we
want to bring over. So it's like,
if I are in there then first things.
Is labor driven by weight?
Could be, yeah, it's possible.
That's all I got to worry about.
If it is labor, you know a wage,
you got the wrong wage, not wrong labor.
It could be.
The one extrapolation factors in here is
by weight, weight or unit weight actually,
so.
It could be if you wanted it to be.
Now some of it may be.
I don't know what all has been changed in
your.
So yeah,
you want to bring overall plate to
stainless plate.
Always sure the way.
It's current.
Is the current SSPL being used?
I'm assuming it's being used in projects
similar, right?
Is the weight in the in the SSPL
currently the actual stainless weight or
the carbon weight?
Should.
Because I think what's going to happen is
what if we bring the other back in the
the sizes that are currently in there
will get changed to the carbon like.
Well,
I what I'm thinking of is in production
control and POS and the whole production
side of production and purchasing side of
things and payable,
so very similar to use for that.
Yep. But yeah, I mean,
they're they're saying that's used over
there. So yeah, so if we bring it in,
it's going to change it to the carbon
weight with those sizes,
which will change PAS and stuff.
Now we'll change it back.
But I just want us to know that we're
gonna affect stuff over there, so.
We good with doing that?
So if we reimport that,
so we exported plate,
we import that in the SSPL,
it'll bring in the carbon way which will
change.
Everywhere in production, inventory,
everything, yes.
So it'll change all of that.
But then if we change the weight back,
it'll change it again on all of that as
well. So I just want to know,
make sure everybody understands we're
affecting that there might be some
variations.
Mobile change here.
Are you just showing us, right? Yeah, but.
We have to figure out the version rate.
Yes, we have to figure out the version,
right? Is that the best path over? I mean,
it's still something more simple than
going into in creating every single one
by one. Yeah,
it's basically the same thing we did with
the angle. Yep, Yep.
So it'll just temporarily change some
stuff on the PO and I can see some slight
variations too, by the way,
like if our conversion is just slightly
different,
like rounding differences or something,
what's currently in there, so.
But it's gotta be.
It is a support, yeah, yeah.
You.
Yeah,
so steel is 490 stainless steel lens.
500 fast, but you could use that factor,
yeah.
Actually do this,
go up to the top and make sure what was
SSPL one of the options of going with a
unit weight.
Yeah,
I hit Global Editor right up there a
second.
Make sure SSPL is in here.
You're talking? Yeah, OK, it is.
Cool.
I just want to make sure once we bring it
in, we're gonna be able to do that.
You'll have to go to the text file and
change Pl. to SSPL.
And hopefully we don't have any type of
conversion.
I think that was just an anomaly that
with the angle where we had to get change
it so.
Yeah,
we can probably just replace all here.
Should work.
Cool.
Yeah.
They didn't slow though, didn't it?
That's brutal.
What's this computer set? It's serving.
Oh, it's on campus here. Yeah,
it's next to the restroom building.
I haven't even got my computer yet.
I hit him up for you.
He's in line and then solved.
Just so you know,
there's database problems trying to
figure it out. OK,
I was driving in line this morning.
I I don't even know how to use this thing.
I I.
Project man.
Sat through a week of training and just
use it for project manager a few months.
Then I left Steve.
Almost a year.
I can't believe how many fabricators are
here in Phoenix. Yeah,
it's unbelievable having to get here.
I think there were 87 that found about
from Arizona to Canada,
kind of the slice of the country.
And now that those are the ones that were
easy to find.
I didn't even bother looking. Yeah,
got me there.
I I saw it was missing some of them,
but I started looking at the website
something.
Like I'm working on such structural steel
business because there's just so many
tires here.
I think I've got close to 10 clients here
in Phoenix. It's or in Phoenix area,
you know, it's it's unbelievable.
All right, cool.
We got 22 and a quarter and 25 inch
stainless plate.
Let me know when you're doing that.
I'm gonna come back out here and watch
watch you fabricate.
Thank you, Brog. Everything past two inch,
yeah.
Can you touch the light?
Just to touch like a branch?
Yeah, so do a do a use 500 up there.
Yeah, I think it works.
It's not right though. 4 inches is 11.
16 and 3/8 is 16.5.
So we can manipulate that till we get
there. I think you should,
but I bet it's not as linear as you think
it is, may not be.
11.169 but look at 3 eights it's 16.
75 so it's not linear precise.
It's not a is it because of what it's
gonna are or to be off in?
10.2 is money, 15.3 is money, half inch,
24. Those are absolutely right. I mean,
I'm used to distributing to the first
decimal place, but half inch is 266.
All right,
I think you're going to end up having.
What I'm going to do is everything past
two inch paperwork and then go in here
and just man these in.
Because I don't think mathematically it's
a it's not just a straight not gonna be
able to calculate it. In other words,
is what you're saying. OK,
and I think that you could probably
create a little formula,
do it in your text file, but I think it's.
For this class, we'd be here first. Yeah.
Now, yeah.
So do we want to at least try to update
it to this? Just go for it.
Then you just know that you need to
actually go in and fix it because they're
wrong.
I think we need somebody who's how how
good is Gavin and or any anybody here at
manipulating SP text files and doing
calculations and stuff like that.
The basic program.
Sure, you can write or achieve to do it.
Did you say you found a a table somewhere
there?
For what? For labor? No.
For the the sizes and weights and
everything.
What tables did you find earlier that you
said? Oh, that was labor.
That was labor's labor standards. Oh, OK,
so Rs means produces.
Labor of AISC or anything you want.
I got a lot to take a bit of a piece of
plate. Yeah,
they have that database and it's built to
be imported into.
I'd like to see that cause I I would see.
I've never seen it.
I go to the store chat ABT 70. Yeah,
I'm sitting here looking,
but it's all behind the table.
I can't be mad.
But it's probably the industry standards.
I've never heard of anybody having
anything that would import directly in
here, so I'd be curious to see it. Yeah,
I'd love to go to the table and I'll just
e-mail our speaks to see if they have it.
Yeah.
Where did you get that 500 or whatever
per per cubic foot you just gave over
there? I just took 10.211.
16 and figured out ratio against 490.
I look it up on mine since it's about 495
lbs a cubic foot or is that stainless
right? So that's what mine said too.
In the bath and it doesn't actually work.
Yeah, OK,
because they did the math right there for
us. It's like, Nope, didn't work.
It's just type 304 is typically about 495.
They got all the the carbon stuff in
there, not the stainless.
Yep.
Oh, he really likes people do it.
Department time.
I don't really know better than people
that use tech love or valid others in
department, yeah.
So I can leave anything farther than too
much. First,
I think you ever have to pay stables here,
yeah.
Nothing much. Nothing much. OK,
four to three. Oh, it's more. I leave,
you know, possibly even 4 hours.
Like the building. I don't know.
I don't know what I see. I don't see any.
They don't see anything after the show.
Oh no,
I'm saying I don't know what they're
estimating. So we take everything.
It's just a BD.
They don't share the state. They don't.
They don't have what you're going to find.
Well, too inch. It's not serious. Yeah,
it's almost. It's all the work.
I should believe that it's.
I think I think that I need to see. Oh,
there's no mobile. I don't think so.
I don't see.
Try and see.
I think a lot of that from the shift to
the management. Yeah,
that's shift to the management.
That's all the other. They. Yeah,
I thought it would be OK. Who's best to?
I mean, it's.
Yes, Sir. Yeah, it's. Yeah,
it's thinking about.
I think I think it says selected
dimensions.
You working wirelessly? Yeah,
I'm not usually that's what we're doing.
So I can see,
I'll see you all the weeks of segments
and stuff for your back.
If everybody's on tech lab and you're all
and then based on what you guys do here,
then they go away.
True. That's that. For estimating. Yeah,
numbers.
So that's why I that's a really that you
all are that's right now. Well, I know.
And one of these are going to make
something else.
Most companies are using spreadsheet.
That's all they use up more. Really.
A lot of companies have done that,
you know, but it's a.
But you can get right on the same page
that one program would be ideal.
They're working on this Wi-Fi.
like this.
There's something you can ask right now.
Yeah, the right extension.
If you need that, that'll help you.
That's what I'm saying.
I think at the end of today, no,
I'm just saying for for the rest of the
week though, it might be beneficial.
Tell me how long do you have?
How long do you know it's better?
I was getting some butter,
but we're not testing positive anymore.
Oh, he's got those fake ones already up.
He's ready for it.
My God, it's done. So cool, cool.
We did angle play.
So.
We don't use tube steel, but yeah,
stainless uses stainless steel.
You you could change that to SSHSS if you
wanted it to.
Changing the shape and it'll allow you up
in shape maintenance.
OK.
Yeah, it just changes it everywhere.
You just change it at the top up there.
Good.
How nice it lets you do that, huh?
One of these times we're going to run
across, you know,
one of these that it does not show up
here and I don't know how to find out why
they say SSHSS is not there.
And I don't know why.
Maybe you have a patient. So I was.
Why are you talking here?
It doesn't need that talking to me
because.
I don't say anything. I wouldn't think so,
but I I don't. You know,
if you look at the help in here,
it says it talks about if it's a dynamic
like you know, like CEO in here,
you can type whatever you want for the
dimension. It's completely dynamic.
It doesn't say anything. Well,
this isn't dynamic.
But so you know what?
I'm going to text one of my guys and see
if he knows. I'm Jason.
It used to be at Tecla.
He he might know or not Jason, but Chris.
But.
So what what we might have to do on that?
We probably have to change it before we
move it back.
Unless we can make it show up there.
Um.
Let me see if either of my guys responds,
see if they know.
OK.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, of course. Yeah. That's why.
I think what we'll have to do on those.
I'll think there's a way to force it to
show up in the converter thing over there.
I think we're going to have to manipulate
it before we.
Yep, in the text.
To go change it,
is that what you're saying? Well,
if we can get it into Excel.
Yeah, do a formula to change it,
put it back in that cell,
save it back as a text file,
then that that could be quicker.
Um.
I'm seeing if I can figure that out, but.
Because when we saved it back as a text
file before, it didn't play well, did it?
Let me see if I can do something with
that.
We exported to the tech file and then
added to chat GVC to update all of the
sizes. Yeah, yeah.
But.
So when you when I see this on the agenda
estimating stainless and a little bit of
progress, stainless was barely touched.
What's the real need this year for a
little stainless?
You guys in meetings?
Are you even doing it?
Is anybody doing it?
We do a little bit of experience,
so you do a meeting, yes.
But I mean, if it's Eric,
I mean focus is hardly.
We want,
we want to find that and we want to work
on this, work on this will be bad.
So we want to do it in here in this class
for each because it's going to take a
while.
Next.
But David, I believe so.
OK.
There are only two people that we have to
do this is gathering the day-to-day job.
So when you look at their daily capacity,
there's my new,
I said get out of home for a week,
four hours and all of a week, nail camera,
a bunch of it, all of it. So.
Because most schools today,
the best thing was great to be in here.
I feel very confident about that.
Much easier. It seems like that, you know,
transfer over.
It's good. So what do we need to change?
What's the conversion then?
So like as an example,
I'm looking at 2 by 1 by 1/8 tube.
It's got 2.
2 lbs per square per not square foot, 2.
2 lbs per foot.
For the weight of carbon,
what's the conversion factor we need to
get that to stainless? No.
OK.
I.
Here we go.
They don't offer much from posting.
2 by 1 by 1/8,
but I can look at a different one if it's
easier.
Do you something like call it like 2 two
2 by 2 by 1/8, 2 by 2 by 3/16?
Tube. Tube. Yeah,
three to three and a quarter. I got some.
OK, two, three and three quarter, I think.
Quarter. OK.
Should I use to memorize the car?
Tuba tuba quarter is going to be 6.1,
is that correct? That's what I got. OK,
hang on. Roll it out of here. Stay this.
Did you just pick one of those two? Yeah,
that works.
Again,
I think you're gonna create a factor,
but it's not going to be a linear factor.
And we can check a couple of them to see.
So we can get you in the ballpark.
Let's see. So hang on,
let's see here to the to the quarter.
Just got to get it converted to a way for
a.
That's the way I would do it because
that's we did .28 and .3 once. Yeah,
just did block conversions.
Yeah to the stainless way to what?
What was the tuba tuba quarter?
The quarter was 6.16.4.
ChatGPT. They're stainless steel.
I'll see if you'll do it.
You said you paid for a little ChatGPT.
Yeah, yeah, it's like 20 bucks a month,
but it does.
Pretty much, yeah.
It's unlimited what the things I the
number of responses I can get and it does
a little bit better job.
So let's see what this looks like.
So.
What's another size?
You got 3 by three by quarter.
Yeah, what you got 8.953 and it did 9.
9336. What if that's linear though?
I think that I think we probably got
going on what?
What we were saying was it's not gonna be
linear.
Um.
See here.
Try another one. What else you got? Well,
I'll tell you what the thing is.
So we went from.
5.41 to 6.1.
6.
OK.
So that's a factor of 1.
123 by three by quarter was.
8.81.
9.93 Yeah,
it's so it it it did it what what I told
it to do,
but it's just not going to be the same
factor. So yeah, what do we?
So you want to try this one to see like
the three,
what the factor would be for the threes?
Yeah, so it says it should be 8.
953 for for what now?
Yeah so well what I'm saying is if you
because it it should have been that or it
was 8.81, right?
Let's say.
Yeah, 8.81.
So if we figure out the factor 4,
So what do you got there? 8.1953?
8.81, so that's 1.81.
I don't know about 1.12.
So it's completely different. Yeah,
completely different. Yeah,
I've seen numbers.
It's it's not somewhat,
it's not a it's wonderful. Yeah,
I wonder if we just bring in the carbon
then and then you're just going to change
it.
I don't think converting it at all is
going to help.
It doesn't look like at at minimum at
least it gives them a a good base to
start with.
It's they have nothing in there. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, I agree. It will be something.
But this is where we spend. I mean,
be busy doing the average that we come up
with per cubic foot weight of stainless
in there. You know it's not correct.
It's supposed to be closer to the steel.
So you could start that.
Right. We could start with one.
Basically what he's saying is start with
the one that you have.
In the, uh,
charging team where we did change it
where I converted it. Yeah, yeah,
at least we can hear the ballpark.
And then as you go along, you change it.
Whoa, like we just looked at it. Uh,
we write the right quarters.
It was only off by.
That 100 foot, yeah, but it was,
it was that way without changing it. Yeah,
yeah,
but so we know it's almost one of those.
If we don't change it,
don't mess with the ChatGPT one that's
already changed because ChatGPT changed
it to like 9.3 versus the 8 point.
Yeah, the two per two per quarter was a 1.
12 factor,
whereas three to three per quarter was a
1.03 factor. So it's vastly different.
There's just no it's not on the near
factor.
I'm trying to figure out why it's not
leading. Yeah,
I don't understand why it's not.
So I've argued this.
It's the stainless bill is a big ball a
lot.
So they have a tolerance that they're
they want to sell you.
What they shipped you. Yeah,
they're trying to get their tolerance and
they do pay for the maximum the maximum
they could give you,
but they may sell you the minimum.
There you go.
I think you got some of that going,
but I never understood.
Is wide angle. They didn't do that. Yeah.
And the books are all published that way,
even though the numbers are wrong. Yeah.
So what we ended up doing because we
fought this problem everywhere.
In the design softwares we would use .31.
Pounds per cubic inch for all stainless
and .
289 pounds per cubic inch for carbon and
then that made a conversion,
even though we knew from a procurement
weight perspective, it wouldn't work out,
but for the things that we were using it
for center.
It was fine. It was, yeah, it was there.
I suppose if we pick something on the
higher side,
it would be OK to get us to the ballpark
and we picked something on the higher
side. I would, I would do,
I would do that. I think a little routine.
What I don't know is the ripple effects
on labor here, but I'm not so worried.
Just for when you're trying to do the
labor estimating, that's a good point.
I think it's interesting. Yeah.
Which one do you want in there for the
labor side? The heavier one? Well,
the heavier one would cover your worst
case scenario, but again.
Somebody would have to make that call
understanding the the weaknesses of it,
but a lot, you know,
it's not all the labor is done by way
either, so.
It's there's in fact it's probably
there's actually not that much labor.
I wouldn't think that would be affected
by weight.
It's more it takes this much time to do a
cut, this much time to do a whole,
you know, things like that, right? Yeah.
So I'm.
I'm curious about.
Oh, like handling. Yeah,
that makes sense to me.
But they just figured on the heavier side,
the pounds per cubic inch,
cubic foot and use that the only ballpark
are the only ones that are.
Ball and estimators because all over
there.
So, you know,
they're not involved in this part of the
project, right?
I think what you're going to do
eventually is you're going to start with
a baseline.
Baseline could be whatever it is that's
close.
Eventually you're going to start saying,
oh, these numbers are ridiculous.
But I don't even think it will be related.
So it'll it'll be addressed in the bid
review prior to submission.
So if they feel that your money will
arrive in a bunch of whichever it's made,
then we'll go up or down depending on.
When you actually purchase something,
doesn't doesn't that information get
adjusted in here somewhere?
The the weight doesn't get adjusted
unless you purposely decide to get into
it. So maybe knowing this though,
we go and purchase something.
It should be a standard habit,
like every single time you purchase
something. OK,
we need to update the weight.
One thing that I that I'm sorry,
that's that's one of those things where
that's what we've been doing for all of
the brands or all of the assignments that
have a 0 pay.
It's a it's a big reminder of us. OK,
I need to go in there and see what just
that.
But if there's a wait in there that
almost throws it off in a sense of like
that might be correct.
Maybe we have to remember just to
remember OK to be specific for everything
you get you've got to.
I I used to have a problem on the carbon
with various mills,
tube mills having different weight per
foot for the same size.
Now they're just slight differences,
but they were differences and.
It's not like I could change it for one
PO and another PO would be different.
The weight is what the weight is in the
system. If we change it to a zero, though,
our problem is that we're not putting in
there.
It's mine to update it if we are so.
Because they're saying from what I've
seen,
we we tend to use a lot of the same sizes
frequently and so everybody continually,
right,
continually using the same size and we're
constantly going back to check that one.
It's now we check it 2-3 versus
unnecessary.
So you recommend that when you leave it
at 0, so you know.
Or you recommend you can just pick one
and just go with it.
I say we either change it all to zero or
we move it to something like close for
him. I think so. No,
I think in my opinion,
I'm not the final decision maker,
but in my opinion I would just pick
something on the high side and say let's
make it all and if we do the high side.
I think at that point we could just take
what you've already done with Chad GT and
put it in there and then it just at least
that's probably probably your best bet.
Just for my opinion like that,
we'll have to finally make all the
decision and all this stuff,
but I would just only want to know what
the ripple is through procurement as well.
Like I assume let's say you buy explained
soon.
Do you receive 6 plates or do you receive
2 sons? It'll be per piece, right?
So I don't think the way it matters
because you're receiving bases, right?
But there's some systems that.
Want that weight that that other thing
can be given there is when you get your
invoice.
If people actually look at the invoice
when they're when they go to payability
of this test,
same place and waive X amount of balance.
If you look at what you have in your
system here.
The kind of, yeah,
it's like and so it was appreciate for
example creating loads in tech load and
now we're trying to get that, you know,
I think you're looking at fairly,
I think you're looking at fairly minute
changes unless you're talking about
setting up one or.
Truck loads of the same item, right?
It'd be still relatively close. Yeah,
you know,
do various stainless mills have different
weights per foot for the same size?
I'm gonna say, I mean.
I'm just saying for the cost of medic
grades stainless, no.
I think you know Kenmac will give me what
mass gives me, gives me.
It's the same for what I want to do for
what I miss is when you get into
different grades,
the weights again change duplex.
Just comes up with either three or three,
probably going to use three or four more
than anything in the case where it's the
316.
So if you base both everything on three
or four,
you're probably going to be your fault.
I mean,
the Ryerson book has really worked for my
entire career.
Right.
There might be a little arguments here or
there, but those numbers are.
It's funny how that book has become the
the standard.
Ryerson has such a good book on that.
So well,
that book used to be really the new book
is shipped.
I had one that was just tattered. Yeah,
I could. Yeah.
Any of you who speak to the number that
you had to chat to BT,
that's going to be kind of the worst case
scenario. And then, you know,
it's going to be everything ballpark.
Yeah, you know,
at least everybody's getting that.
Somewhere down the road a year or two
from now, oh,
we got this size that we haven't really
bought much of. Oh,
let's take a quick peek and I'll maybe
it's the same, maybe it's not.
And it's gonna get you at the ballpark.
It's probably better than having a 01
happen to actually enter every single one
every time.
I'll send it back to you if that's what
you want to use.
We might have to check two or three other
ones just to make sure it's not out of
left field or something,
but I understand what Gavin's spending on
this,
trying to get this stuff fixed just hours
and hours.
Yeah, he has time. Any,
any between with Bailey or Peter,
anytime he has something.
He's our he's our major Tesla.
OK,
we requested from the leader Gilbert to
get us person here.
We don't care if it's we would prefer
someone.
It's the technical experience, but if not,
we can just get somebody here that's
highly trained work. They can be in house,
they can get out, you know,
outsource to do this work and and we have
not the set up work is what you're saying.
Jeff and I I talked to Jerry and Jeff
went doctor in public.
I mean,
right now we're just trying to get a list
together of all the IT issues everyone's
having and get somebody stationed here
for this camera and all that stuff like
this thing.
Do you like printing? Yeah, I think,
I think. All right, 477 is, you know,
these things here are knockout drag out.
She's brawl. She would have just.
That thing is so quick.
And then the angle,
which was not even close to that,
was the problem. Yeah, it was a bit crazy.
What? Wait a second. I thought we had 400.
Did you say you brought it all in?
Bing, oh, serial.
Hang on a second here.
The um.
Go to HSS.
Make sure we didn't just change HSS.
What's the weight on like Tuba Tuba
quarter?
5.41 So can that's SQ. Yeah, the.
That text file.
Has HSS in it? Go change the SSHSS.
I know that's what I found awful weird
too.
That's why I was scared that we just
changed the way to the HSS.
This, this, this one looks like the board.
If.
Yeah.
So there's Jason and she Jason with what
she went to.
So Jason and then I got another guy Chris
Randolph. Chris was.
So both of those guys work with me so.
Jason, you should be. Yeah,
I basically I didn't entirely because I
was in charge of all the project manager
getting involved with the estimators.
So I just sat there the full week with
him, you know, it was kind of fun.
Not that I remember much.
It was like a lot of information.
I'll tell you what, this week, Sir,
you're you're drinking through the fire.
I was spinning. Jason is so good.
He he knows the system really well and
he's a true teacher.
But she was very good.
It was a year and a half ago.
I had to use it for the last 10 months,
probably. Yep.
I don't remember everything. Yep,
I really haven't focused on, yeah.
So we were doing some of the same type of
thing we're doing now. Yep,
I remember going through that. Yeah,
it's OK.
Maybe doing this even though I sat
through and still have never estimated,
but estimating day-to-day usage of
estimating is it just to set up?
I had my own structures,
so I had that control and I switched over
to that suite. Yeah,
this is now that suite that they've
converted. Yeah, yeah, this is.
So I had some experience with that
estimating, but I never asked.
Yeah,
the estimating from Fab suite till now,
I mean there's been some structural
changes and some things that they've done,
but the basics of it is the same as what
I was saying Fab suite.
So you used it then and you wouldn't have
trouble with here, but I like.
I did sit down with the estimators quite
a bit.
I like the fact that they could make them
set up like a like they'll take 10 items
to make a call and combine them all and
say OK, this is a memorized thing,
you know,
and that was pretty cool because you can
do the same thing over and over and you
can set it up.
It up. I said ladders.
They got three dozen size ladders. OK,
I got a set up for that, you know,
you're talking about parametric
assemblage. Yeah, assemblage. Yeah,
that was really cool. I believe it is.
It is the speedy way of doing, I think,
especially when it comes to miscellaneous,
miscellaneous.
So good, yeah.
I'm hoping that the estimators here
already know I do. Maybe they do,
but you know we've gone through,
we've gone through the website.
I would love to just be nothing.
I'll be on a pair of records soon for the
rest of my life. I'm something.
I'll be on a pair of records soon.
They're fun.
That's what my ChatGPD was really.
That's cool,
but you kind of got to know how to build
in your retail chat to GPD out.
I would do it practically.
Now.
That's probably not an updated bunch of
tables, probably, yeah,
but I can't expect this to.
Really just drop right in.
Um.
Alright,
I'm I'm gonna drop this same file in.
I just started it.
It says successful. It wasn't that quick,
surely.
Oh, I know why.
Because I I did the same thing.
I didn't change the,
didn't change the file.
I I can't hear you. So Chris,
it's running 2223 or something.
It's running. I started it and I might.
I'm up to 100 right now.
Everybody.
So I just passed you,
but now granted I'm technically working
on server, you know I'm not, yeah,
not working on a client reading through
the server,
but I've seen guys switch offices.
And their speed like just it was vastly
different, but it's very,
very network independent for sure.
That's when you have a shared connection
to share versus versus the dedicated
board. Yeah,
cause all these routers have different
capabilities.
This is a Wi-Fi. Yeah,
I I think you're right.
I think Wi-Fi is exactly.
Yeah, the main line.
Mine,
mine just finished point of reference.
Small web file.
This.
Stay, stay. Yeah,
I was freaking when I asked her for a
while. I got it. I bought Smart Ring.
I don't know several months there.
And then I started to realize how little
level I actually moved. I'm like,
holy cow, I got that.
You got the ring. You got the ring.
This one even does. Yeah. Oh, oh, oh, oh,
I don't like that right in the middle of
that. Oh.
T.
But he actually ignored this crashes. Oh,
it's nice.
That's fine for nothing.
For example, you know,
for people to think it's, you know,
relevant to the location.
So sometimes it takes a little longer
than you certain things.
I can see that it's close to the server.
For what I got.
You couldn't modify the file,
so it only brings in the rest of it,
unless we just want to see how quick it
is that now compared to before.
Yeah, that's true. Oh, let's see.
Way faster.
I think it's looking at the ones that
already now we'll get now it's adding,
but that is faster than it is.
She was speaking to us on the laptop,
just to see if the attendance would be.
Yeah, 5G here. It's pretty slow.
What you guys are hearing you?
Facing safe? Yeah,
I think you can see it fine.
I had to switch carriers, right? A PP.
Military was not here. I switched back.
See.
OK.
Just remember,
this is your speed to your live speed,
not to your server.
So does the Gilbert have to hit the
server here?
They don't have it.
So we're down.
Yeah, we have still in Mexico,
but we ended up doing a very sort of.
Which would be the same data mirrors and
going to have to worry.
It.
But they didn't start.
Switch.
Switch is back at their own service.
I would think.
We're pretty impressive.
I mean 1616 about 2 1/2.
It.
For labor,
if unless you guys have changed something
drastically, I was looking a minute ago,
I don't see very much labor.
Well, I just looked at the state's angle.
I didn't see very much labor dependent on
weight.
It was more length or cross-sectional
area, surface area.
There was very little that was dependent
on the.
Just strict weight.
Yeah, big old tubes.
They are.
Any of this exists in the universe, yeah.
I think the biggest stainless tubes I've
seen is.
8 by 8.
And so you can probably save yourself a
bunch of time.
What's some of the sales?
It doesn't exist. That's not even for it.
It sales.
There's 177 entries of maybe half of them.
Wonder if that's when I noticed there was
a blank one in there after we went back
in after it crashed.
I'm wondering if that was a result of the
crash.
I mean,
I would want to know if somebody here is
messing around with really big stainless
too,
because it needs to flag somebody saying,
oh,
we don't really do this and by getting
rid of it,
they would have to ask somebody to add it.
Yeah,
and then you're gonna know that
somebody's playing around with something
weird. I think that's their mentality.
I'll try to find a way to do that.
That's fine,
but I used to get all the weird stuff
that sent to me and and.
Then we, you know,
I had the power in my past life to decide
who didn't or not to do it. There's,
you know, see,
but there's a lot more things.
That's right. Force it.
Yeah, and then somebody can just say,
let's not do that. Yeah, they just do it.
Well, you can't buy it.
You're gonna you physically will have to
make the tube with trust break.
The mill is not going to make that.
Depends on your quantity,
but you're right. Oh, right.
If you want a black 400, maybe.
Anything's possible, I suppose. Yeah,
right.
I'm straight to here,
but then jobs that I've never seen
stainless tube, I haven't seen any,
but stainless tube steel yet,
but stainless I haven't seen.
And even big beans,
we wouldn't if we if it was smaller,
we just make the bean. Yeah,
it cost too much money to see that,
which is cost too much money to buy it.
How would you make it?
You just buy it until you can figure out
a plate and weld it up. Yeah, that's it.
That's it. Well,
just like you're doing out here. I mean,
the box maybe. Yeah, same thing.
Same thing.
But the news level.
But you're not going to do thousands of
feet, like 2 or 20 footers, yeah.
And when you make it,
you got to worry about the warpage and
having to stop it from moving when you
weld it up.
And what do you do after it's made and
it's more how you going to fix it all the
time?
There we go.
So we have plate tube and we'll be need
to add to for savings that we need to add
to the estimate, correct? Yeah.
Are there any others you got to get round
pipe and and the round tubing?
Yeah, by you could use those, that's all.
Oh, you're talking about, uh,
agents and so on, yeah.
See that I don't see it,
but it's something people do.
I see hand rest without inch and a half
diameter spin still treatment rather than
pipes.
I've got lots of hand rail meets the code,
the tube meets the code and the pipe does
not.
That's only if you're going to have some
hand. It's just as.
Can we duplicate this for them? She's.
Yeah, different HSSR,
is that what you're saying? Yes,
just go to shape, maintenance, grab HSSR,
hit new and then we'll change.
We'll do SSHSSR.
We'll still have to do the export import
thing. It's only for round two.
It's not going to cover all the square
spots if you're not.
We're gonna take HSS on it.
We already have anything. Yeah,
so just do new now. Yeah, there you go.
That makes sense. And then just SSHSS.
Please.
Now I may stop at anything.
Nothing bigger than two inch.
I would like maybe three or four inches
that would stop that. Yep,
there is 3 inch.
You know you have a car grill,
it could have a three inch top.
So then you go export HSSR shapes will
change the.
We'll change it to SHSSR or that's hard
to say and then we'll put it back in.
Do we want to change,
try to change the weight as well or leave
it the the carbon weight or they're not
going to do it.
I grew up to 4 inch,
like 4 inch in the middle.
Get good at this import or export thing,
right? It's good practice. We should.
Yeah,
I would say to leave everything over four
years, right? Even the four and a half.
Yeah, I would say four is even.
Yeah,
I don't think I've ever done anything.
HSS.
What's weird is the the this exported out
with the shape of HSS.
That's really weird.
This is not tubing, right?
This is follow structure inspection.
It should be tubing, though.
That's what standard comes in.
You can call it change SSR,
but what I see here,
even in the bar side of it,
there's so much more tubing in this.
So it's not really built. This is not.
I mean, this is the structural business.
This is not the exchange or business.
I mean, why is there no 2 inch? Oh,
good question. Look at that.
So you see that 1.9,
that's an inch and a half.
I wonder if these are really five. Yeah,
that's what it looked like.
These are really five.
These aren't gravity.
Stop.
The the looks weird to me.
I don't know what happened.
Where did you grab from? HSSR, HSSR, HSSR.
It tells me the problem could be two of
these resizes that were happened.
I think that is the default.
A lot of the sizes I see there look like
they're pipe sizes. You know,
starting at the top,
the most common one pipe size is 1.9.
That's an inch and a half pipe.
1.9 inches is inch and a half.
You go down 3 lines more. It's at 1.9 by .
12.
That's an inch and a half scale to 40
pipe.
But that is it's not it's not too good.
And you're missing to me, to me, to me.
OK,
this that's coming from the AISC manual
in the AISC. In the AISC manual it's 1.9.
Do they not have any?
For tubing sizes, round tubing sizes.
Well, this is HSS round.
That's that's what that's coming from.
Yes.
Right. It's not a.
We just don't even put it on.
This isn't a.
This isn't like a DOM tube or something,
right? This is, yeah, this is different.
Yeah,
I would say we don't even have this
because this isn't gonna be helpful.
Now there is a.
There is a.
I think a tube round in here. Let me look.
Well, there is a there is a shape,
but there's no sizes with it,
it looks like. So yeah, it's all too big.
But what I'm seeing the way it's not in
the system, it's student, around student.
They've built it for just the structural
side and any other shapes can be done.
It's just they don't have to be built in
there. They do, they do stairs,
the rails all the time and.
Inch and a half pipe 1.
9 over D does not meet code inch and a
half OD like the ones they have up there
that does meet code inch and a half OD
you know .
188 or you know those people but I didn't
see it .125.
Yeah,
that's probably the most common handrail
size that is used,
but that's odd that they have all shapes
done.
But yeah, that's that's Alameda.
I think I wouldn't even put that in there.
I wouldn't put that in here,
but you can have it manually, right?
There's only going to be really three or
four different sizes they're going to get.
Yeah.
Jason was always bad about that too.
He's like, none of you don't use pipe. No,
you don't. You use stupid.
They changed that.
Unfortunately it was in my lifetime
because I started in 79 and we were still
using pipe sizes and then they changed
the handrail code.
Or if it had to be that you have to leave
for the river,
95% of the out there is not leaving.
Are we supposed to be looking for
something? I think it's all the same.
They're all the same. So just grab one.
Yes.
What's the driving standard for more
handrail?
What do you mean when you're saying a
handrail would be a week's code is inch
and 1/2 upside down.
That's a standard for the grip part and
the top rails they get 2 inch, 3 inch,
4 inch, 5 inch,
whatever they want the carb rail.
But the handrail portion is inch and a
half OD and you can get away with inch
and 1/4 of pipe which is inch and 5/8 OD.
I've seen that illegal also,
but nothing above that is illegial.
You can't use inch and a half pipe at one
point in time.
It has to do with the with the strength
of it as well.
Is that right?
It's not right next to here.
Whereas in fact, for pressure piping,
you get 850 degrees grade B.
But because these handrail guys stopped.
Blasted. Oh, free blasted.
It should be in here. Oh, it did. Got it.
Thank you.
Thanks. What is your? What is your?
What is your position here?
I think to to go beyond structural
foundation.
We were.
Changed and there was a gap,
but I think they're a great song.
I'm concerned with other people who are
trying to replicate.
My real practice is to go on to something
that includes a lot of electrical tools.
Yeah,
the experience with handling of metalwork.
What?
OK.
So the back of Wyoming on subcontractors
and departments.
I would say that would be,
that would be like me.
You ever leave?
And it's like, hey,
I'm talking to this fabrication work.
I might. If it's somebody I work with,
you need to come in the what,
100 party shops, something in the US.
I'm sorry, home is been lotted. Yeah,
definitely. It's like a 16,
000 tons that they want by a little bit
more.
Yeah, it's 26 and 27th for the March.
Yeah, March of 27th. Well,
it's 8000 this March, 8000? No,
it's not a good response.
Yeah, OK.
But the problem that you really have is
you've got,
they're going to give you drawings in
November. They want this deal in March.
You've got to have the capacity to push
all that through in two months.
If you need time to buy it,
it's time to drop the payment.
Yeah, it's silly. Yeah, but we'll better.
What's cool about that project is it's
more on batteries. It's more energy.
I think it's funded by Bill Gates.
Take care of.
Probably 10 something months ago.
If you're honest here.
That's nice to like driving complete on.
Now you can hit Phoenix.
Traffic starts sacking up right right
after Ridge.
I live in the northeast Mesa,
so my record was still here.
They said it could have been here,
but would have given it as possible.
The staff of the attorney is on Friday.
Well, that's very good.
But you Tucson to the Valley.
Super.
I mean, finally fixing that.
So if I can make it all the remains and
then you'll be telling me to report.
Nobody always says to do high speed
training.
20 years.
Well,
there's going to be building the the
island, Mexico up to wherever.
Maybe you drive at Kingdom.
I don't know if you got about two weeks
ago. I've been,
I've been working in Vegas, living here,
working in Vegas for the last seven
months. But yeah, I was driving.
I can see how they're improving all that
to make that interesting. They are.
Most of the time I flew,
I grow with a few times.
I don't know where I put that touch.
It goes to this area.
But it's on my.
That's where you live. I actually.
I'm with.
It's what happens when we do not.
OK.
Um.
Ducks. None. I don't know.
Thanks.
Like I was at shop week before
Thanksgiving that mid tanks,
so definitely not as common though.
Probably 8085% of the shops I go to are
pretty much strictly structural or
miscellaneous.
That's all I we used to hire.
I think the team from the environment and
they know this or after all.
Yep, that's the common part of it.
Does this work with HP?
You don't have to use tech of structures.
SDS is another common SDS too,
but really anything that I can output.
The best file type here is what's called
PFXT file or PFXF firefactor exchange SDS.
It's basically there's a zip file with
XML.
The drawings and the CNC files are in it,
but they can also import PS file, Excel.
I mean, so yeah,
if a program can output that I can get it
in. So that's it.
It's almost unlimited what it can import
from as long as you get in.
Excel for that.
It does work best then with technic
structures or SDS.
It's pretty much electrical up in here.
It just wouldn't work because you'd have
to have a home or electrical. Well,
that's the challenge in talking about the
electrical.
Yeah,
I know that's going to be part of the
agenda is creating the shapes you need
and then how you're going to get every
all the data in there, right? You know,
how you're going to get that important.
So that's going to be the challenge.
What the heck are they doing here?
No idea what electrical stuff in the
system. I mean whatever shape you want,
right?
And so it may not like bees in here.
It does have fields for what the fledge
width and the depth.
And all that is right.
You know the electrical stuff,
it's not gonna have a field for that type
stuff, right? You know, right.
But we can create a shape with just a
description at a length or whatever and
so and and can make it work. It's just.
How is it going to?
How do you get everything in there and
how is it all going to function? Yeah.
And I was like, stop.
So we ended up on a steal. Yeah,
just that. Yeah.
And then some of the baptrol guys would
have their own little boot like copies of
baptrol and just run the system.
Yeah, I think you need the right tool.
I'm not trying to force it because you're
just going to pull your hair.
It pains to do that. I mean,
there's another client of mine that
started doing deck.
And they wanted to put the deck in here,
the manufacturing.
So you're you're buying coils and then
outputting lengths of deck, right?
So system doesn't play real great with
that.
Yeah, we're building sheets, right? Yeah,
we basically did that. We did OK,
here's the sheet,
although the coil is this wide and then
the deck is this wide too.
So you you you about had to do a nesting
thing and and it functioned,
but it was a workaround that.
Wasn't spot on.
It's it would be a whole lot easier to
have the program that does it, but.
I think it's a very good idea,
but I don't think so.
Well, we got some out the last couple.
We had 29 different ERP systems.
And we got a level set.
Everybody moved to 1.
Everybody's pushed back. It's like, oh,
that's great,
but it's got one of the items, you know,
exactly.
So they tried migrating the biggest
business into the one. Yeah,
that was huge. And they just said OK.
So they went from 29 to 14,
got rid of some of the small ones and
they were trying to get 14 down to 4.
What they put us on,
they filled the business. Yeah.
So art was temporary parts in one year
with more than all the other companies
that were ever put in their history. Yeah,
yes.
Because every part we were junction. Yeah,
everything we did was unique, yeah.
And so they would have 6 inches of pine,
9 inches of pine. Well,
we have cobweats that are all over the
place.
They wanted that in the park to eat our
pieces.
Yeah, you'd never.
You'd never find it in the in the store.
And years and years ago,
probably in the mid 90s,
there wasn't a whole lot of good stuff
out there for structural and I kind of
had to do something similar and I forced
it into just full length stuff.
I wasn't doing any remnants.
And finally we then bought something that
was actually forced me off and.
When you got the right tool,
avoid it made it so much easier.
Maybe it switched to the second minutes.
Single next is good.
I think I will be coming for a while,
yeah.
What are the coding guys trying to do
with this?
The main thing is to use this to take off
of square footage,
so kind of puts Bob on boards instead of
having to take off and give you assembly
tracking cause right now it's all paper.
So if we can correlate their own
independent projects,
it's also coincide with ours.
Then we can have on fluid streaming
process because right now it's a e-mail
communication between the departments.
So unless you follow up, it should be.
So you're going to put all the you're
going to put all the assemblies into the
database, I suppose,
or one of them will be out specific,
right? Yeah,
it'll be a hit file and work and you can
come there to assembly and it's.
Yeah, don't say kiss. Yes, we did switch.
But for for Kody's introduction.
So they've been. Yeah, yes.
I got flamed on LinkedIn recently because
I was like,
I will kill kiss files if I can kill them.
And I got flamed by so many people.
It's like guys, you just don't look,
you don't get it.
So that's one of those things.
That's the old school drive, yeah.
Well,
it is still such a prevalent phylotype.
Just because people.
This is what I've always done, right?
And so people just don't know to know to
try something different.
But I'd like to turn it off just so
people have to find something different.
Scheduling.
Be fine.
OK, they they have to do.
And we track everything through the shop,
read the information back to the PM.
He has to do all the calculations on the
labor and update his his stuff.
Currently they're using Vista and we're
like 10 days behind. Yeah,
there's no course correction 10 days.
So will they find benefit out of the
production planner or the?
Other scheduled in here my.
Right now we have all these different
people asking us for different reports.
I don't need to know what they're doing
to talk to you, but you're 10 days behind.
I guess your forecasting that's fine.
We want to be able,
and we have a bunch of different
spreadsheets and whatnot.
We just want to get everything down into
one. Yeah, we can track everything.
We can look at it. Yeah,
just be much more efficient.
The the problem I have with tech on this.
Once again,
I can talk bad about what I don't, Alexis,
and I'll work for him.
I begged him to incorporate the planner
with the project schedule that's in here
and they would not do it.
And I think, I think it's because so,
so few are actually using that schedule
in there because it's a big,
it's a big thing and so but they they
didn't incorporate it and I wish they had
so the two don't talk.
So now work packages can show up on that
on the project schedule, but it doesn't.
It doesn't look at the work packages as
far as the new dates and everything.
So the dates on your work package don't.
Correlate necessarily to the dates on the
schedule, so that's annoying to me.
I don't get what I wish because my name
isn't tackled, so.
Yeah, we did. I mean scheduling,
scheduling,
scheduling how everybody wants this
critical path, Gantt chart,
blah blah blah.
But what I was.
We can never make it work until you until
the shop and the lines of the material
couldn't do anything right.
Typically they they get stuck in
engineering and customer rules.
I don't care.
They get stuck somewhere and you create
these.
Schedules,
but until you really have it in a ghost
state, yeah, it's meeting.
So you have to have something that could
really move it and update it easily.
And we were really bad on knowing how
long tasks took because.
Ten years ago,
the guys had lots of experience and the
new guys that got coming in had no
experience.
And so tasks were taken twice as long.
Yeah,
and so the labor just wasn't updated.
Hours. It's like, hey,
we knew you were running over on hours,
but the scheduling software had no real
hooks in it. Yeah,
to be able to make adjustments like that
and then ripple through the schedule.
Well,
and and one of the biggest issues
everywhere with scheduling is.
Capturing the time that it actually took
and then getting it into the schedule.
And so you know,
I don't know a lot of people that
actually capture their time,
but much past just the job level.
You know,
not even down to sequence or to lot or
now work package.
I don't know too many that that track
there.
Their labor back close. So,
but it's the only way a signal will work.
You know,
you've got to know how long does it take
to last 1000 square feet.
How long does it take to to set up?
I think the shops that I.
One of the things you want the chains,
everybody's have a client meeting.
Let's have a client meeting and what
we're going to do. I think so approach.
I think you need to do after the meeting.
This is what we're gonna do tomorrow.
Yeah, yeah,
because it changes the whole thinking
process of you have that meeting,
what you're gonna do tomorrow.
And then people start realizing that
they're not ready.
And they realize that at 2:00 in the
afternoon,
instead of at 6:00 in the morning or five
in the morning with the whole crew is
there, you've got a little time to react.
And it changes your way of thinking about
how it works.
I don't. I mean, some people do that.
It it is a hard mindset to shift that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The main,
the main purpose for the look at, look at,
oh,
look at spend or think they're called
underreleased work packages or something
like that is to reserve a spot in the
schedule. Yeah, so estimating can say, oh,
there's a.
We have something in house.
It's just not ready. Yep.
And it's we're taking,
they're taking up this much time.
These guys just start cramming **** down.
It's like we have to figure it out.
Coding is just an absolute. It's chaos.
Absolute chaos. There's no.
We plan daily.
That's where most of my time is helping
these guys plan the guard space and just.
Excuse me from logic in how things work.
And it's always said that there's no how
many coding jobs would you say go through
in a week or a month, 10 or 1000?
I don't know, probably 1010 to 15,
but it may vary per week.
Per month, 10 per month,
but they vary in size. I mean,
there's we're quoting on the border of
all. Oh, that's a shot.
We did a a WW infill job last year lasted
I think 8-9 months.
So you have that kind of work and then
you'll have.
Yes,
Arizona Water with the Gilbert water
treatment time. We, I mean,
there's stuff coming in and out every
week. Yeah.
So what we would do is we have things
very big jobs, right?
This got to the last place.
And these bays are going to be big jobs
and then.
On a daily basis, we get can we do this,
can we do this, can we do this, right?
That's just constant and.
You've got to keep the big hitters moving.
You just got them.
You cannot chop into this thing because
any money you make on a rush job,
you're going to lose it on the big job.
So we just had a quick hitting team.
They got a Bay or half a Bay,
whatever it was,
and then they would do it and we made
them sub out.
Probably to you guys all coding.
There's only scheduled work that goes in
coding facility. We didn't let.
Quick hitting jobs with coding. You know,
I don't know if it's the same year,
but you know you got sandblasting.
You can only do so many pieces of setup
before you got to clean that area out.
Same thing. Next code, next code.
So we did not.
I'm not saying any,
but we really try to avoid unplanned work
through the COVID facility because it fit
disruptors. We would,
we would love to do that,
but we got one a month ago.
It was.
I was here when I think you guys were
getting in.
I walked through the tour and you guys
were like,
but it sounds like you guys just
swallowed it. We smashed it. I mean,
we but that's good.
It was great because we we made so much
damn money in such a short period of time.
We really knocked that apart and then it
led to another like 6 truck loads.
But did you have to sacrifice anything?
And what was the sacrifice? We we had a.
We were ahead of schedule,
so we really didn't sacrifice anything.
We just,
we just kind of left that order that was
in house going to go back on schedule
instead of pulling it forward.
We just put it in there.
But if we didn't hit our numbers,
it would have,
it could have pushed that schedule.
That schedule was in jeopardy.
But the cool thing is we have field
people too.
So we we pulled in some field guys for
that job and have them work on that job
while the other guys were still working
on some of the other jobs so.
But they don't.
There's not a whole lot of time.
A lot of these,
a lot of the jobs we do our rush.
We keep getting like they move so quickly.
You know, like this back job,
we'll spend 6-7 months dealing with the
the, the set up and the, you know,
all the ******** waiting before we get
started.
Fabrication where coatings will be like
we'll be on the phone on Monday and like
Friday we're receiving steal.
So it's way faster moving what we get.
Yeah, you do a majority of their stuff.
Like there's very there's not a lot that
are like preplanned out.
How many places can you last?
Right now we should only be like stand
left in hand with financing.
And that's.
We're trying to utilize that as much as
possible, but it's such a.
Machine and then it's in this ****** spot.
So trying to move big stuff through there
and we do a lot of tape place.
That's the funny thing.
I don't know why they said it or they
said it, but.
Not sure.
The penguin is useless to be there,
the overhead,
the plate you could design it.
So if it was most plates, not bad,
it's not bad the right width.
It's kind of a real small window,
so but it works for the beeps.
Or when you want to play,
you want to play through a sideways
hanging off the conveyors,
that's a nightmare in the place to
involve.
I'm saying that we're seeing the Gods
support those beams there. Yeah, well,
which is what you're really saying is if
you don't have a wheel that shoots like
this,
you have a wheel that shoot like I got
both.
The one that's when it's off with what
we're getting there,
it's it's from the size that they would
do.
It would do pretty well on like on a
ascendance,
like these reflanges and base plates and
stuff like that.
But it's there's no way it's a continuous
moving conveyor,
so you have to pick it up in the.
It's too much.
And then you put money into that thing.
It's ancient, you know,
you have the blue machine, which is,
you know,
a horizontal machine and it's a plate
machine, so it's just got four wheels.
That's the one that we used to be noticed.
30 years old and it's the wheel operator
machine and it was designed as like an
economy machine.
It wasn't supposed to last 10 years,
so we are dumping much.
We've dumped a lot of money in that
machine.
It's all we're basically for solar power,
but we're using it for other stuff,
trying to put too much stuff through
there as possible and then take it out to
blast. If the if the numbers make sense,
we'll build that.
We got a bunch of small parts.
We can't hand glass.
We put them in a basket,
put it through that machine and it's a
good time safer.
So just each job has to be Coding's guys
are all real technical. They understand.
That means they can plan that they don't.
They don't think outside the box.
That's it's more of a a lot of processing
production lines.
They they like to lay everything out.
And do a big batch and then it's like and
I tell them these these things that you
started over there have been sitting
either for you know 10 hours you know and
then you're not going to touch anything
until tomorrow.
So that means sitting there for 19 hours,
no worse than being done on it.
So I'm trying to get them to focus on
smaller batches.
1.
But they they really need the schedule.
They need that the time they're talking
about.
Not that it's going to change anything,
but it can.
It gives everybody an idea that we might
have to bring more people in for this job
or or whatever.
Or maybe you can sum it out.
Is the importance more the long-term view
or the here's where we are over the next
2-3 weeks?
We wanna go as far as possible.
So for coding, what we're gonna do is.
The week ahead of whatever week here is
locked that not touched that week and
then it's the the following weeks can be
adjusted. Gotcha.
And what I wanted to do is schedule,
trying to get them in the mindset of
scheduling dead time and schedule things
so that.
It's short lead time or or emergency
guard to try not to impact the schedule
as much.
I think everybody wants to see it.
Jeff is big on this.
He he has everyone working on a master
schedule.
The current schedule, Yep.
And all these details.
And then we're looking at Tectonic,
the tech that can do most of the stuff
already. Yeah,
instead of having all these spreadsheets
with all these, you know,
the office personnel working on making
issues. Yeah, take a time. I mean,
we have a guy that was in Todi's
literally. That's all.
We did pretty much. Yeah. Spreadsheets.
Yeah. And he recently left,
so it's a great time to get started on
this.
It's the value of spreadsheets is
everybody knows how to operate
spreadsheet.
But the bad part is,
is disconnected from everything.
So there's a manual update for everything.
So I think it's so much better having it
in the system. I mean,
I would do everything I could to get it
in there. Yeah, I agree with you.
Who can streamline it all?
So there's reason.
So we're really trying to and we're just
be over the device because yeah,
we can't afford it. Yeah, yeah, yeah, um.
Then on top of that, it's I mean,
these guys are are busy all day and it's
like we start looking at what people are
actually doing. It's like there's.
I mean for some of these guys with actual
work and the rest of like paperwork or or
updating. Yeah,
all this **** that's it's like,
I couldn't believe my site was wonderful
and I was like, I don't know,
there's another company that needs to
have spreadsheets to run stuff.
We used to do what we call a hard same
thing. Wonder book, yeah.
Hour a week to keep it up later.
And then it's like I I'm trying to teach
everybody the question.
When people ask for a report asking,
give it to them because I'm not into.
I'm not into like, oh,
I just want to see what you. No, I don't.
I don't care if you want to see.
If you want to see, you figure out how to.
You wouldn't believe the number of
reports I kill at some at some shots.
Like if they're switching,
like if I go to the shop to switch it
from Fat Patrol to to this,
it's like I tell them I OK,
now's the time to review everything.
Why do we do this?
And so I'll, I'll simply be like, well,
I need this form, that form,
that form or this would report something.
And so there's been some objectors like,
OK, what do you use that for?
I don't know.
I just have to give it to the shop.
I'll go to the shop. I'm like,
what do you do with this report?
I don't know. They give it to me.
I'll throw it away. So you know, I I find.
I've done that stuff all the time because
somebody at some point asked for
something and then it became the standard,
but nobody actually used it.
Every once in a while I used to run a job
myself and it was all this paperwork.
I would just hold paperwork back just to
see if anybody came and asked me.
Don't use this. I don't know why you got.
Oh well,
you know the ISO manual paragraph 6.
3 says we got to do this like we don't
use it. Well, that's it.
I don't want to do that, right?
I know I find that too,
when some people are like, well,
our quality manual says we have to.
I'm like, well,
can't we just change the manual?
And they're like, well, no,
that takes 13 people to do that. So yeah,
so that's that's really what we want to
use it that portion.
Project managers.
Mark is up to date. What do you run?
Like 8 hours behind? 10 hours behind?
That's your. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Coding to 10 days behind. Yeah.
And then do a manual estimate to to kind
of fill in the gaps. Yeah.
So we want to get.
Want to get Mark up to speed within
minutes and then podiums come along to
let it up to the left.
When you say up to speed,
it means the guys that wanting their time.
That's the goal we've got.
We're geared up harder,
but I think we're gonna have a faith in
where we're gonna need to make sure that
it's.
The last thing I want to do is is keep
going to this and then screen all kind of
problems within there and someone's
having to.
So do you have a longer time every day to
a data mix?
So yeah,
so when Alex creates the work package,
he's creating the labour code that
pertains to each one.
So we do it very granularly,
having it will burn and then each of the
guys pick on their workstation,
you know how they worked.
8 hours on welding today,
then he'll talk to the job number and the
sequence code and then it all rolls up
into this database of QC signed off.
Is he ever linked himself or is he? Yes,
all the employees get their time manually
and then my phone number use it to make
sure there's any issues.
Some guy that forgets to take out the
notice break.
I mentioned our yeah, they started,
they took this area or so we make those
adjustments. So the system.
So what I'm used to do is guide the.
That's what starts at everybody if you
want it.
The new job 683 Work Center 25 on that
job at work center.
Halfway through the day,
there's a lunch break.
This is just docs to lunch for everybody.
And so there's no worrying about you're
going to get docked for lunch,
but nobody has to do anything.
It's just automatic.
You get 2 breaks and lunch is just docked.
No interacting with anything.
You go to a different job, the job,
the minute you type into that job,
the other one is you don't have to walk
out of that one.
It just knows you went into this one.
It closed that one.
I mean, we were in mid manage,
which had its own problems.
We went to IFS,
which was an order of magnitude worse.
So I'm not saying mid manage.
Time tracking was decent up.
But I'm just wondering,
I mean be interested to see the mechanics
here around it because there shouldn't be
this.
You know, redundant I'm tracking.
That just happens today.
Just like with a lot of software,
somebody's good is the key point putting
the data right.
Sometimes in a 12 hour share,
I'm working on four projects. Oh,
I worked on one. So guys get a little.
Placing it,
but we have those checks and balances.
Yeah, my department,
the department had to check as well here,
but there wasn't, you know,
the guys have to, like you said,
they have to do it.
And we've tried to talk system for a
while, but then with us being out here,
we didn't have as much IT support back
then.
So there was claw downtime and then we
just, you know, back to paper copies.
But right now we have our facial
recognition. One,
we hadn't got that until mid during COVID
and then we use that as a as a safety
check on our NMA.
Yeah, you got here at 4:15, not 4:00.
Got to document something.
Was that on our system?
It's a little confusing,
but we're to the the pads which I I get
it,
but that's what that's what tech was
designed to do. So they.
They can go in with the job,
got loads of drawings and the other they
need and then they're out and then he's
getting they're getting updates. Well,
this cut's done on this,
the ball's done on this and it's up to
the speed.
Do we need the drawings on that?
Yep. So like if we pull,
how big is that like that? It's set up.
The nicest one I've ever seen is so they
have big job box and the guy's got a big
touch screen, like 28 inch,
a big monitor in there that you could
really.
See all of them. I think in your idea.
I mean,
I don't know how many drives in the
drawing packages,
but this thing is awesome and each.
Workstation, job, you know, job.
So there's a monitor that's touch.
They can really see drawing to the school.
I think each one on our assembly,
it'll pull up each individual one and
then maybe go into further details with
parts.
I have 9 inch tablets and that's what I'm
using in the shop where I was. Um,
guys don't. It doesn't matter.
Everybody is so used to doing this anyway
and moving it makes a zero difference.
We we bought bigger ones for the QC guys.
And they ended up. I don't like it.
They wanted the smaller one just because
it was easier to carry and they can save
them in and out all in one.
Everybody's used to it. So and I'm funny,
I'm a paper man. Yeah, to me,
when I watch these guys put a few things
electronically,
it just happened in the book.
Yeah, well, the the beauty.
The beauty of the tablet though,
is when when a revision is imported,
it immediately,
it immediately updates that draw and they
can't get it all drawn.
So you don't have the bad dash to the
shop,
still find all the drawings and somebody
has one stuck in their toolbox and you
can't, you can't get it. You know,
the flex side of it is, you know,
your notes that you put out there because
it was this.
Yeah,
I have seen standardized iPads and the
Androids. They work further.
I've seen them in shops as well.
It's pretty cool, you know, you'll be.
I was shocked when I first put in place
in the shop. I was new. I was like.
And my guys, I don't know.
That's going to be like pulling teeth for
me to get a place. I want to be in place,
but and I was shocked. They pushed me.
And now that I go around doing this
across the country, I am floored.
Every shop I go to once and then says
what I hear, you don't know my guys.
I'm like, I do know you guys.
I've seen this 100 times.
I'll win 80% of people right out of the
gate, and then I'll win 10 to 15% of them.
And they'll want to go to tablets after
they've used it for a couple weeks.
And then 5% of them just are never going
to like you no matter what you do,
you know? So, but I'm for the Lord.
That how our guys take to it.
I'm I I it's still surprising me to this
day. So like the piece part,
if I had to make a piece part and it's
got 3 features, whatever,
simple drawings like that piece part,
no problem.
But if you're a guy running a job,
it's got.
Hundreds of parts or thousands of parts
and he needs to see how they go together.
I just,
I don't want to see because he's trying
to plan it out.
I haven't really seen that one.
He's giving up all those parts in the
smaller sections. This guy's doing this,
this guy's doing that,
this guy's doing that.
I I, you know,
I got plants running massive trusses that
are that are running the tablets.
Bridge work, I mean mining type stuff,
NASA type stuff and those guys are
running them on the tablets.
It's, it's really. You'd be surprised.
Yeah.
You guys got to understand about this
place is the environment.
So we got the iPads right now.
They stay inside.
The office over here,
which doesn't do us any good.
So we bought a we bought a rolling
charger, post 20 iPads.
Right now we can keep it out wherever it
doesn't matter.
But in the summer we're going to take a
beverage center,
a refrigerator and modify it and that's
what.
We're about to sit because our iPads are
shut down in the summer.
So we we're battling like stupid things
here. I think I told you,
but do you know all things now?
So they're QC lading.
That that handles it.
A freezer for in their shop because we're
looking for our work list for shipping
receiving soft side cooler.
Yeah, yeah. Everything shuts down.
All of the products. Yeah.
It's a because I like what Eric's saying.
That's what I want.
I want screens in the shop.
I want a place they can go. I want.
I'd really like the TV up with the
schedule. Yeah.
So people can see what's going on. Yeah.
And.
Not here, yeah.
Refuse. Yeah, I was all shocked that they,
you know,
they had the dollars of the bonus.
Real time on the floor. Well, guys,
I know it's like they're watching.
It just went down.
It wasn't that real time,
but I think it's day-to-day.
Whether everything was ahead of schedule,
behind schedule, reworked, whatever.
But they kept that real-time bonus up
there. That's intense.
I I used to the shop files that everybody
had a tablet.
It didn't matter who they were.
And for a while I started emailing
everybody because everybody had an e-mail
address too.
I started emailing to everybody
automatically a report of what everybody
did the day before work.
So all the pieces they produced.
So the guys that were killing were like,
look what I did and the other guys were
like, holy ****, to see what I didn't do,
you know,
and it actually was pretty phenomenal.
I've got I have guys on our on our
robotic welder first secretary ship guys
getting in a contest because they're like
oh I can do more than you you know and so
they started getting in the contest.
It's kind of cool.
So but they did that to beamlines.
They'd crank out 3400 be 3 or 400 calls
in one day because they would have
competitions. Yeah, that was pretty funny,
yeah.
Oh,
it's interesting to see what motivates
people. Yeah, money. It is. I used to do,
like, a lot of twenty-them.
And I said to a good welder, I said,
I bet you can't well five days on a day.
Here's 100 bucks.
And the day they were done,
it's 100 bucks. Yeah.
And my kids do that everything. Yeah,
yeah, exactly.
It's easy to kill yourself for one day.
It's hard to do it all week and then come
back and do it next week. That's right.
I tried to get our owner to do the kind
of the new core thing where it's like, OK,
we make X amount of money and it's X
percentage of, you know,
X percentage of profit,
then we're going to take this amount,
this amount of that and just hand it to
everybody.
So everybody's whole mindset was the
bottom line, right? You know,
and I couldn't get him to do it for
nothing. I could not get him to do it.
He's like, well, then I'd have to,
you know, family owned business.
But it's like, yeah,
then we'd have to let everybody know what,
you know, what our income is. I'm like,
who cares? I like the more you make,
the more they make. Who cares?
I couldn't get them to do it.
Yeah.
But I I have seen also people get
compensated for certain things that
actually worked against the company.
Like I'll I'll see a lot where purchasers
and PMS are fighting with each other
because the purchaser.
Purchase the material.
They're they're paying based off of how
well they utilize the material.
Purchase it under budget. Yes.
And then it's so detrimental to the shop
because now all these pieces have to be
save this remnant on here.
It has to go back down the yard for
another sequence.
And so the handling went through the roof
flat because I could and it would have
been a lot faster process it played. Yeah,
if I could have thrown it on a burn table.
Yep.
But now you have to hand process
everything.
Yeah,
is that I don't need bonuses up with any
of the material I work here.
So I go straight into the shop.
How do you want this done? I think, yeah,
you guys tell me where it's gonna make
the most sense for you guys to guys that
are working. Yeah,
it's like sometimes I don't talk to them
and then they come back to me and they
say, yeah,
we need to do to read you the order.
It's like, OK.
I do like the shotgun involved in those
decisions because they actually do this
**** every day, all day.
They know the best way to do it,
and they're going to.
Sometimes you still and the people love
that for me out there.
But like if you prefer the platformer and
that's how it's going to be a problem for
sure, yeah.
Yeah,
we were pretty close to buttering our
shop. Yeah, yeah,
I think it's changed too,
because it used to be all manual layout
and so you want to try to run something
through a laser,
put all the features in it,
embed it into a manual.
But then all of a sudden you have this
little shape, you know,
shape plasmas like you do the same thing.
So now you can go back to the shape.
So you can look like a press brace step,
yeah.
All it still just keeps on changing.
Well, finally,
I think we're starting to catch up a
little bit with the technology that's
been in manufacturing for forever, right.
And it's just that the structural
specifically has been so far behind just
because it's like I just get out a bigger
hammer, you know, I don't need to.
I don't need the technology side of it,
but I I think we're finally getting there.
Just been so far behind.
There is a lot of the layout stuff now
for like even like stairs and rails and
stuff and.
Finally, robotic welding is a thing, so.
That's still coming slow for a lot of
places, though.
I think the last shop I did,
they had one robotic builder and they
sell them and used it.
Even they have steel that we have it a
year and a half and complete it. Yeah,
there's other places they do really.
We had it where I was and we had one for
about a year before I left there.
Since then they bought three more.
But now we were very heavy warehouse,
so we did lots and lots of tube columns.
Just simple, right?
You got a lot of the same parts you can
set up for it,
but I think the vision systems or the
detection systems have gotten to so much
better that you can get the lot sizes.
You don't have to fixture as much anymore.
But it it didn't matter what what the
assembly was. I mean,
they have it now to where it doesn't
matter if it was the same or not.
It doesn't matter.
He knows what it's supposed to do.
So we just ran a lot of that and the
reason it's so simple is because it could
well lose out 100%.
Whereas like some of the more complex
structural things, it couldn't get it,
it couldn't get in everywhere to Weld it
and a guy would have to finish it up.
So it was super simple.
Those everything was welded 100% but but
it it.
It didn't care what it was, you know,
it just pulled the data straight from the
model and in order to pull it into the
welding robots database and it started
running it, you know, So pretty amazing.
I love that robots worked really well.
Yeah,
we have the AVV early version hated it.
Yeah, it was too picky.
Then we got the Lincoln.
That was the newest vision still needed.
I know I found a few times and they can
see what they were going where it was
going. Holy ****.
Yeah,
people like can implement that stuff.
They could go if it is.
I find that the ones that implement that
stuff the best are just stubborn people.
There's a lot of shops that do buy that
stuff and they don't want to put the work
into it to really make it work.
But the ones that are stubborn and
determined it's going to work,
they'll make it work, you know?
I do see a lot of robots sitting out.
I I I think a lot of them just,
but I see the same robot working like
crazy at another shop.
I think it has more to do with the people
running it than it does the equipment
itself.
So now it's adding into.
Yes, yes. And so now we don't have time,
so you have to take HSS and pass to it.
You guys run KPA Flex through the app?
Yeah,
you can get it through your your phone as
well. Yeah, you can.
It's easier with the app if you have CPI.
I don't know. Where is it?
OK.
If you go to your laptop,
if you go to Chrome,
that doesn't make sense. close this.
Yeah,
just don't be surprised if it doesn't
work. Let me see, go there,
select one of those and go up to global
added operations here.
Yeah.
That doesn't make it. Uh,
look at that beams are showing. I mean,
go to ships, grid sizes.
This doesn't make any sense how this
could work.
And go up to drop down and go shake
maintenance.
And now go to SSHSS.
How see the mature groups of these?
Oh my goodness, really? What is this HSSR?
It changed to the same material group as
tubes. That's why it ought to be.
Wow, that's jacked up.
Let me look something here.
Man, man, man,
I'm wanting to see if that's
out-of-the-box.
Did you change SSTS to HSSSSSHSS, right?
Yes, yes. Let's see. Crap.
Holy cow, that is our box.
You're not using it yet, right?
We exchange that.
We we definitely need to change that.
Oh.
Oh,
I changed it to after all that can we
well, can we export it and then?
Deleted and then just reimported after we
add the new post list.
Right. What? Well,
I'll tell you what I would say yes,
because HSS is not. We exported from HSS,
so that'll work. I'm,
I'm kind of just wondering what I'm
saying if we.
Duplicate this one.
Duplicate it and then delete it and then
just add when we have a new one.
Doesn't make sense why you approved.
Anyone gets in my opinion,
but obviously it doesn't return me to.
Yeah, yeah, operations, yeah.
It'll matter. It'll matter for
It'll matter greatly on the instrument
because it will use the beam labor codes
rather than the two labor codes and the
labor operations will be a big difference.
So why they why would they have it set?
I don't think,
I think it's probably a screwed up. Yeah,
probably I've got a I I would get we
probably some of your estimates I've been
going through estimating and.
OK.
I know I knew there were some issues with
the default setup with some of the labor
pins and like as an example,
plate out-of-the-box only does a burner
on width and length, not width length,
width length.
And so I I threatened for a long time.
I'm going to go through all of them and
get all.
I think I'm up to 28 different issues
that I see on labor case.
So that's probably right.
That's just the main side.
So.
I don't think we can just copy.
There's no way to just copy this.
In other words,
because all the all the sizes will come
over.
It's just going to be the format of it.
So what about an export? Can we export it?
Yeah, the text. Yeah,
you said exporting was intacting. Yeah,
if you export this out.
Yeah, that sucks. Holy cow, man.
So now we probably just thought of delete.
Yeah.
I think so.
Just go to the you'll have to go to shake
maintenance to do it, but.
Hopefully it's not used anywhere.
You want to check that first?
5.
Help.
Probably. Or do we just want? Yeah, yeah,
try it.
Labor Standards.
Now that would be that one size though.
Try it. It'll panic as well.
Yeah.
Worst case,
we change it back to SSTS and then just
set up a new one.
Standard.
Um.
So we'd have, yeah, we got to delete that.
We can delete that labor standards and
try it again,
just go up to maintenance and estimating.
Labor maintenance and Labor Standards.
Just deleted out there.
Well,
now you definitely hope it's not there,
not being used.
OK, cool.
So now I'll just go up HSS and copy it
basically.
Oh, that's interesting.
I'm amazing. Love of accents you guys.
I sleep right here, right now.
This.
That small. We have to do that.
I actually need to do that.
I can't remember you got this this
facility is doing landmark revenue that
we were doing. I'm I I'm with you. Like,
you know,
I was down lucid for a little bit and
couldn't do anything.
You'd have to call someone in and a
specialist in the administ in.
You want to work,
but here it's like we serve this, this,
that and.
This.
So it's cool, but at the same time it's.
It's great. It's great. It's great.
It's great at times,
but other times it's like, holy cow.
So we would do the European change our
installer build database.
They gave us all different parts,
but the other shop still have to keep
adding, keep adding.
In a smaller.
That's just like today.
It works great.
What's great about this is I will give
some large fabricators and it's like it
takes an act of Congress to get anything
changed in the system.
It's like we're sitting there. It's like,
come on guys, this is changes.
We can make a change today, right?
You're right. So that's the great thing,
but.
You instill a lot of confidence in us.
I don't do anything. Yeah,
I keep that doing. I'm not. He's not.
He's not afraid to make a mistake. Yeah.
You're here.
The guys in Gilbert are going,
why is our database changing? Yeah,
good video. Or why is it so slow?
Because we're updating the database.
That does happen a lot when I do some
places like everybody is like.
Why's the system so slow a little over
kind of in this right in the middle? Yeah,
staring at the top.
Again,
I think the one key step to learn is only
8 by 8, so Mr.
Billy starts chopping down the side of
the.
OK, they got like the bottom it's.
So we should be able to then hopefully on
day estimating at that point that's
that's.
Yeah,
you want to get a maintenance and
estimating.
Yep.
So now we'll have to get HSS and
hopefully be able to see it.
You'll need to do it the other way.
Right now you're passing from SSHSS to
something else.
Yep.
So you need to select what you want to
pass and then go in to it and select what
you're passing into, correct? Yeah.
And even though we were on like one and a
quarter by one and a quarter too,
it can go to everything else because of
that extrapolation factor makes it grow
for like 8 inch feet, so.
Oh, now SSHSS should have time.
Let's make sure.
What tracks move?
Um.
Go up to maintenance and estimating.
Actually go to go to labor standard
maintenance drop down.
You might be able to get there from here.
Yeah, view labor operations.
And then Scroll down to move right here.
So get piece would be OK.
It's in the yard somewhere.
We're grabbing it.
We're taking it up to the machine to cut.
Move would be pretty much all movement
through the shop everywhere.
After that. So now it's customizable too.
You can do, you can slip ahead,
but that's definition of it, yeah.
And then is it driven by weight?
So move right there.
You see the extrapolation factor says it
varies, varies directly by length.
OK.
So I was looking at the length of it in
order to make that last.
Now some people are like,
I don't care about length,
I care more about weight. Well,
that can be changed if you want to.
So how do you look at it when you guys
saw that you were off on your material
handling?
When do you change? Get beat,
slow or move?
It varies by project,
but for the heavier jobs we did it by
week. OK,
but but you changed the category move or
you changed all three categories?
You just say I just not just you can't
have. They just have more hours. OK,
so handling is in another person, but no.
But what he's saying is cool. Yeah,
handling, but get piece moved,
load unload could be considered handling.
Which one of those factors we can change?
We didn't change that. We didn't change.
Don't change.
That's exactly what I'm saying.
He did it manually, isn't you?
This was what the estimate was given and
then he looked at it and their last
minute was short. So then it was added to.
Oh, so you didn't change it in here.
You changed it.
So that's so what you could really do.
What I'm hearing is if we update it,
if it was the way dependent or like
dependent,
if you mess with get piece login,
it will carry your lessons in the future.
Have you guys done that?
Yeah. So we have,
we have to link it loading stuffs on the
saw and then if it gets,
we get it and get some pieces different.
When you move into the shop,
length has to be to do with the panel and
it's hard because we are a top shop,
so product specific.
Some of these can have three different.
It up inspection depending on you know
how entropy.
So it's really hard to kind of just.
You know,
change it in one area when it varies so
so different, right.
So that's where what I was looking at was
like we're going to be doing an operation
that requires a certain piece of
equipment.
Do we add it into that equipment time?
Or otherwise we have to make a specific
chart.
I mean estimators have to go into adding
next amount of handling for this or move
for this or whatever.
So that doesn't seem very efficient.
Let's dig into that a little bit more, so.
You you're saying that just changing the
time here would not be good because it
would vary so much like give me a give me
a example.
What would make it change on a job on a
job basis?
It could be the intricacy of it.
So we have some beams in the shop that if
we just did it by weight,
it may not actually work out in our favor.
We have a multi-step fit and Weld column,
so I have to fit and Weld this area
before I can add the secondary phase to
fit and Weld.
So I'll make up to seeing additional
handling time because of the stop start
of a fitted Weld, you know, as an example,
just for additional handling that
wouldn't necessarily equate back into
like a weight, you're you're saying OK.
I've got parts on this size side of the
column,
parts on this side of the column and
because of that I should have more
handling time,
specific to how long our shop is set. OK.
And so it it does that because it gets,
it puts handling on the parts as well as
the main piece as well. So it does.
Do that so.
In in general,
I would just change the the handling in
here in order to make it go up.
The more parts you got,
the more handling you got,
which is the case and that's what it does.
So if you go through and change it then.
OK.
Is some channels we want to run on our
ACPC and then some we don't because if
they're just straight cuts,
it makes so much more sense to run on the
saw, right?
But your handling is gonna be so
different,
drastically different handling it on the
ACPC machine versus.
At the sum.
So how would you the point and that's my
question.
Can you attach handling for unique
handling for operation or for? You can,
but the the fact of the matter is that
the point of the estimate,
you have no clue where you'll go, right?
So you almost have to.
We can dictate that. Once we have that,
yeah, we know where we want to send it.
If if it's got no holes,
I mean it's got if it's literally just
straight,
that's we're sending it to the salon 90%
of the time.
But like you're saying in the beginning,
I mean,
you aren't estimating you're done for the
care book. You run it. Yeah,
as long as it's recovery.
Yes,
you you either are going to take an
average of that over time.
I know the average is somebody are going
to be here,
somebody are going to be here and you get
an average for that and and apply it or
some some shops will just say I'm taking
the worst case scenario and if I if I go
over to the other machine.
It's a savings for me.
So I'll put that down for our action
items.
Our lab money this year didn't get around
to it. Yeah,
I wouldn't build it so that if I cut it
here, it's going to be this time.
If I cut it here this time,
because you're just not going to do that.
That at the estimate level. So, yeah,
yeah.
So you have to build an average into it.
So you just have to, yeah.
Is the concept of first and second fit
system the software? I mean,
you can back build anything you want.
So are you talking about like a super
assembly where you've got,
you've got basically assemblies within it
that make up a larger assembly?
Translate structural.
Like if you're throwing flat plates on,
that's easy. First,
but now you're going to try to make
something more complicated.
That's like putting two big columns
together, so.
I don't think they'll create routes based
off of our review.
So if we come across a project that has a
multi-step fitment well,
they'll designate or create a new routes
project specific to where you have state
one fit well, then you go and tailor it.
They should be well and then they can
carry that.
But is the labor factor set up in the
system to handle the the the labor is is
100% customizable.
You can make it that way if you want to
by default it's looking at.
Everything on a part by part basis.
So if I put a shear tab on a column,
then I've got fit up for that particular
shear tab.
Now if I've got 2 columns that then I'm
going to Weld together into a double
column or something, then no, that's.
I could build something for that if it's
a common thing,
but if it's not a common thing,
I wouldn't build a legal thing for that.
Yeah, separate assemblies,
because if you tell Techlove that it's
each its own assembly,
it's not going to understand that it
needs to be over.
Just created in the setting where it has
all of those on. Yeah,
you could and that's what I'm saying.
The answer is yes,
it will handle that out-of-the-box with 0
customization of anything.
There's not one in there that's gonna
handle that type thing.
But if I'm doing that type of stuff all
the time where I've got that.
Double fit up, basically. Oh yeah,
I can build that in it for sure.
I just wonder what the estimates here
know.
There's more they can do here than do in
the field. They don't know it,
so you can get off quicker.
So yeah,
the estimating is extremely customizable,
so you can build really about whatever
you want to in there. So yeah.
Yeah, it is.
It's it's really the beauty of it,
but it's the it it it makes it harder to
implement, right? Because it's like,
I mean, it's still.
Why shapes and sizes aren't just stand
that that's to me,
just it's not as frustrated. I mean,
it isn't doesn't make sense quite.
I mean you mean like my one detailer use
A500-B and another one A500-GR dot B and
see even that I feel like.
If they were using exactly the lean
method, right? But yeah, our.
That club was already set up on a
standard and obviously when you go to the
important it's telling you pay,
you know it's only A500 or A500B whatever.
So you could just make that one simple
adjustment. Yeah,
every time you see that it needs to be
this A.
100.
But it it just gets so granular where
it'll have the size to be different where
they'll put instead of a four by 6,
they put a 6 by 4 and a half. Yeah, yeah,
I think a lot of companies have a
standard, but it's a standard.
This is how we do it.
Everybody must do it.
The person that actually doesn't locks
that thing down because otherwise you
have what you sounds like you guys have.
The reality is most detailers don't know
what it should be,
and so they'll put it in as a four by 6
rather than a 6 by 46 by 4 is the
standard.
Right.
Yes.
I need to order this. Oh,
that doesn't exist. Yeah.
And then I have to go back to our PES,
our engineers and say this doesn't exist.
We wanted it to. Yeah,
so we we have a whole.
Oh,
the details and the standards and the
details.
So that's something you might be able to
look,
but I agree that we need to have set
standard cannot. It has to be this way.
That's it.
That's how you solve those problems.
We just deal with it.
You get 4 characters here, 2 characters,
2 characters. I mean, it's to that level.
So it's character to character.
It's perfect.
We don't have standard detailing
standards. We do. We have all the details.
If I look at it, well,
they're about Carday.
Somebody has to fix that.
We'll be living with it forever.
Ingredients. Look,
you're screwing this up. You got, yeah,
when you got like a dozen,
there's six of them per time.
Yeah, they're third party. Yeah. Yeah,
at least they want the standard from the
other. Yes. Yeah,
I signed that straight on up here earlier.
I have the ability,
but it's only the last one of those.
That's not you know going back to like
like you're handling.
Do you do you manipulate all the time?
I'd say, yeah, that's a good investment.
We should probably think about changing
it in here.
You don't have to change it here in the
estimate. You guys know how to do that.
Well, us personally, no,
we can take a dive if we can help out.
You don't want to look at how to do it.
So before you get out of here,
don't get out of here. Yeah, go back,
go back in there a second.
Those operations.
No, no, close that.
I wanna go to view labor operations.
You leave that open to go to the drop
down at the very top labor standards,
maintenance and go to view labor
operations.
Never set that side by side with the with
the labor standards, yeah.
Never change this without knowing this
extrapolation pattern because I if I'm
looking at like the one in the 15 minutes
for that team, OK, is that 15 minutes?
Like your load here is varies directly by
length. Cool. So that's 15 minutes.
What's my length? Well,
my length is 40 foot.
So that's what I'm thinking about.
I'm thinking about putting that 15
minutes.
I'm thinking what's 40 footer will take
me because it's varies by length.
Whereas if it doesn't vary,
I'll just change it to whatever, right?
It doesn't matter.
So you got to know your extrapolation
back to whatever you're whatever you're
changing your times. So is it linear? Yes.
So a 20 footer is 7 1/2 minutes, correct?
Yes.
So you put it in your estimate a 20
footer of that you're going to get.
It's in that, you know.
You know.
So in a sense,
it doesn't matter what your standard
length is,
it's just a factor to get a rate is all
that is now.
So if we were going to adjust the
handling,
you're talking what would you consider
handling?
You consider unloading and loading.
I'm talking about unload, get piece,
load all these moves that are down
through here.
You see where the clips move,
you see plate welded move.
There's a lot of stuff there.
So you need to that that has to be
figured is there's a lot of those.
There's factors in there that need to be
changed.
So if you came to me and said Ricky,
our handling is 15% low across the board
in general,
I'd probably start out by just going to
unload, bump that up about 15 minutes,
go and get me, not 15 minutes.
15% go to get piece, bump it up by 15%.
Anything that that hits a handling factor,
I'm going to bump up by 15% and then I'm
going to pass that to all of them,
all of the like shapes.
Does that make sense?
Yes.
And you can see there's like the reason
why we do so many investments. I mean,
there's a lot of 0 sums there, right?
While the, you know what I mean?
Chat is also part of our standard EISC,
just typical shot, right? Look at,
look at welded clips move.
Or, excuse me, weld eclipse layout. Well,
that doesn't even make a whole lot of
sense. Go to the plate welded.
Go to the plate welded layout on the
operations here.
All right.
You see that the extrapolation go one
more down 13. There you go.
See the extrapolation factors varies
directly by the number of holes in a
standard clip.
Look at the number of holes in a standard
clip up there for the two. It's zero.
That's why we got no time.
Because that extrapolation factor,
they probably pulled from AB to say,
look at the number of holes in a standard
clip. Well,
the number of holes in a standard clip in
a tube is not really a thing, right?
So you can see the holes in a standard
clip is 0.
So that's really where the extrapolation.
Factor for these tubes be looked at,
readjustment, put new time on so.
That's a lot of power here.
There's a lot here,
but I'm hearing is we don't use a lot of
this time. Is that right?
It's not that big, big Dome.
In my opinion,
I think it's that we don't utilize it to.
So let's say we look at the job that's
here building box meetings.
Is it built with this power or are you
adjusting it at the end or how's that?
Do you like this very specific job that
you're doing right now?
It's estimated intact.
That's a good question. Interesting.
I don't know about that.
That's pretty much all that all that box
project. I did a manual tape off.
My manual take off and I went put it into
the system and then I called the precon
and click the review based off of my
physical experiences here with the shot.
So knowing our capabilities are happening
process that may not be what our data may
show because again it's.
And skewed based off of shopping,
I can get it, but again,
what you really want. Yeah,
100% is it to run through,
to run through technical with all those
steps in there. OK,
it's something checking the time.
It's to do stuff and bring it back to
tech. So we do time studies,
you do time studies and then no time
studies getting input into your then the
the information from those time studies
all the time study is accessible through
our work packages because we do a one for
one.
So that and we'll run based off of that
activity. Yeah, it'll show.
So then the the last part of that is
after you show an open one,
does somebody go in to here and update it?
No, that's the stuff.
But it's probably need to, right? OK,
got it. The whole thing,
I don't know if somebody say it's a trust
and verify system, right?
Because if you don't do it,
you'll be finding this with the rest of
your life.
Each overrun has to be looked at in
detail as to what was really wrong.
So if there's if they go over and we go
back and review and find out.
Something happened out of the ordinary
and we don't take it. Yeah, right.
It's like everything was perfect and we
went over just that's your thought.
That's nothing there.
That's the part that we have to be
careful on. Yeah,
it is gatekeeping that and making a
determination of,
but it's time saves and the day you take
the time saves.
And they're in here.
That really needs to be done by you guys
here, not by the estimates, right?
Because you guys are the ones that
actually know it took this much to do
this. And here we probably, yes,
we we have the historical status of the
background we already only have is the.
The change in the data, yeah,
my own point is it's not something that
you have to be able to do.
It's something you have to be done here
because you guys have the knowledge the
activator does.
I would say though our our one key point
is project closeout. So if.
We typically don't do that unless I'm
enorrhaging and here's why.
But if it's on the head or under,
if it's never, you know,
you don't have to vote.
I think you're a very good estimator.
That's what I predict.
I think you're a very good estimator.
You've probably done this for a lot of
years.
The guys that are in may be pretty new
and they've probably got to ask a few
1000 questions.
They may never even step in the shop.
They're counting on you to have the data
because they can say one of these three
of these, four of these,
and these six of these done. Data is good,
done. It's your brain.
It's in that system and that's what we're
trying to get to. Yeah,
that's to make it not to do really.
And I bet you got lots of time to do this
here. They they've been.
I don't think the estimate has access to
this.
It's that's what we own it. That's good.
We own it. That's it.
I personally believe all that should go
out and spend an hour or two in the shop,
three weeks, an hour or two in the field.
So they they were really good at what it
takes to do ****. Yeah,
every shop I've looked at,
I've always put that.
Because they need to know.
They need to at least see it.
It's only for now. We need to say, oh, oh,
now I understand why we have to take this
long to do this.
Because I'm sitting here watching them do
it, you know,
the estimators are going to deal for it,
but the work is being stuck here.
One thing we could do right here,
by the way, with all those zeros, HSS,
if we would go back and look at it,
every single tube has holes and standard
clip of two.
So if we wanted to make this match what
HSS is right now,
we can deliver the land at the holes and
standard clip and make everything too.
Repass the plan and then these will get
filled in with what's currently on HSS,
which may or may not be right,
but that would make it the same if we
wanted to do that.
So we just change it here. So go,
go to the drop and see.
The top one, Bill, it holds the same.
So again, just SSHSS.
And then OK at the bottom.
So now we'll get back to HSS and it will
redo what takes off of this whole,
she said.
It's live whether it's right or not.
You need to go to HSS first.
It's something because you see all those
have times for layout,
feed out and whatnot there.
So now you do blood blended operations.
Yeah, there we go.
What do you mean?
It's not there. Oh, that's right.
They do feel any shots.
So now this is HSS should get more times
in those other fields. There you go.
And these to us, maybe shot.
So it's like really updating where it
says it's something old in there,
but all they do is good job doesn't just
make the document.
Yeah,
the one of the next two is the chart
right here where it says I'm gonna put
those back together. Yeah,
I can change that. Yeah,
we can change it all that. Um, no,
unless we recap stuff on that.
So yeah,
so you went through and changed that
whole. Truthfully,
what I would probably do is change the
stripolation factors based off of the
holes in the state of the clip because
it's really not.
It's really not the right, right thing.
I I think what they did originally was
they took the they built the beams which
made sense for like the welder clips to
be based off the holes of the center clip
on a beat, right? The bigger the clip,
the more time I'll have to play it.
But and then they just kind of said,
let's mimic that for twos.
It doesn't really. I mean,
you're not sure you might every once in a
while live on a on a on a two,
but not often, right?
So are we looking at the can?
Numbers here from PowerPoint.
I don't let you know if you change that
at all. I'm not sure.
We'll have to go back and compare.
The 12 minutes looks familiar to me and
move 18 minutes.
I wouldn't doubt that it was out of box.
And I'll I'll say this about the
out-of-the-box times. By the way,
normally when I go to somebody that's
fresh with this,
the main things that I'll change are well
times are generally very slow in here.
Burn times need to change because
technology has changed.
Handling gets manipulated,
but the layout fit up are generally
pretty close in the ballpark.
The cutting times a lot of times are just
little alert,
but most of the time the layout fit up is
not too awful bad.
If I were to,
if I didn't know what my shop was doing
and somebody told me that, it's like,
what should I adjust here?
I'd say let's go change our weld times
and let's run with it. And honestly,
that's what I do a lot to.
To evaluate the labor here versus what
they're estimating,
I'll change the well times and then let's
grow an estimate and see where it ends
and a lot of times we're in the zip code.
We're probably within 10% of where they
want to be. So how easy is this?
Let's say we finish a job, any job,
and we will close out and we have the O
bridges. You go in and update everything.
I assume you can now run the model back
through estimated to do a checksum.
You could,
you could run it back through there,
but you have to have.
So these labor standards are built into
what's called a land code, a labor code.
Think of it as a recipe.
That's all your ingredients right there.
And the labor code says this these are
ingredients, right.
So all the pieces have to have a labor
code on us and the system knows what what
hours to apply to it, right.
So if the system says it's got a 16,
it's going to grab whatever line 16 says.
Yes, yes, correct. I get that. So,
so when you bring if you were to.
Pour the bottle into estimating.
You still have to put the proper labor
codes on it in order to see what labor.
But yes,
you can because my goal would be like the
last three jobs.
And I don't care if they're over,
under or whatever. Yeah.
And I would run them back through to see
if they estimated correctly for each
operation.
Then I know that my database was behaving,
yeah.
Yeah, you push for morning.
You know he he does the your checkup on
the job more broad than that.
We we do postmortem this project.
Lots of grass and we made a lot of money.
You got this report. So what do you get?
I think we all,
we all did those reports too,
but I think all I say for us we never
went back and updated the standard and so.
Right. We just got to do that. Yeah,
I've done that. Look,
you're welding rates this this many
minutes for you to fix it right now.
That's over. Yeah.
Probably should for you. Well,
I think you're about to kill this box
being done. You're about to kill it,
right? And you said it's a 3000 hour.
I don't know what the number is and it's
going to take 2000,
so much different number, right?
And it's probably because you did 28 of
them and you learned a lot of little ****.
Along the way,
switching process from manual analog to
cell part. So you know,
things like that may be progressing,
you know,
beating based off of our manual load time
versus because you don't necessarily want
to change it because you might not have
to clear the new method and might have to
read it exactly. But again,
I do think you want to change it because.
The sub arc welding is a new operation
that is totally going to change the game
of how you did that.
Yeah, because if the FC Maker sees,
I got 28 of these,
he can choose to run somewhere around.
Yeah, it will be done.
But yeah,
it's a pretty good definitely too, yeah.
Yeah.
And now I I talked through how to change
this. Do you want to change one? Yeah,
let's go back to the labor standards over
here on the right here and click on that.
I don't know if we want to check.
We could take like you're not using PX,
right?
We can change PX without screwing up
anything just to show you how to make
sure you know how to change it so.
OK,
so let's say that we wanted to bump up.
Handling by 10%.
There's a bunch of items here that are
considered handling.
So like unload is currently at 12 minutes.
So and this is like Rob Russian.
I just want handle going by 10%.
Cool at that point.
I'm not sure I care what the
extrapolation factor is.
I'm just going to take all the times.
So so now there we would need what 13.
2 is that correct? So change it to 13.
2 say only for PS18.
Yes.
And then we'll change it on PX18 and then
we'll pass the all the others,
all the other PX, but not to the WTS,
correct, correct.
We'll be able to choose that.
So they're going to get paid to do the
same things.
Change it to no,
just go down to get piece over here on
the right.
Yeah, right there. Change that to 13.2.
Go to move down there. Well,
load would be the next one I guess, right.
So that would be we're adding a minute
and a half to that. So 16.
5 move then is going to go up to 19.8,
right?
You have the idea, right?
Then you would go to the, well,
the clips move, the plate building move,
so I'll set for it all the way down and
you're looking, right? Yep. OK,
so the moves are not 12 is not related to
seven.
Correct. Yes.
So you got to move general overall,
but then the welded clips move would be
the clip itself. I'm going to go get it.
So, so I assume we did all that right.
We went there and did move all the way
down. So now you know we got 1/8 fixed.
We're going to pass that to everybody.
Things.
So now we're going up to the drop down at
the top, global ended operations.
We had 1/8 selected,
so now let's pull over PX.
Notice 1/8 is not included over here
because we're passing from 1/8 to then
yes. So we'll say OK,
now we're going to pull over the unload,
get piece, move.
All those things that we want to affect,
yeah, load.
Cool.
And we would have done all the other
moves, right?
Hit OK and now that has just had all the
other sizes. So I've got a question.
What's the column being here? W 1240?
What about the column?
Give us something to the column.
WB. Can you pull up the W8 by 24?
All right.
I think you're using out-of-the-box stuff
for all your operations. Those 12 minutes.
I think that's out-of-the-box.
Let me look here. I can tell you.
I just want to see if they've been
changed. They haven't been changed.
Eight at 24, so we've got 1212.
Well now cut is 6.
68 out-of-the-box paints 14.981501853.757.
52.63 so it looks.
Kind of what I'm seeing.
Everything's out-of-the-box except cut
has been changed.
That's why the sense I get is we're not
really using the database 'cause it feels
like we're not.
Other practice too,
like unload how it comes in.
We have no, no control over that.
Are they interlocked? You know, are they?
Are they separated with dunnage?
Big difference. Massive. Well,
that's definitely one of the things that
drives me crazy. For example,
in ponies we start,
we start doing estimates on blasting and
you say, OK, the.
The wheel greater can run so many feet
per minute.
If this wheel comes in at this grade,
it doesn't come in,
it can take hats to run slower,
but you have no control over that.
So the estimated will go in the middle of
getting an average.
Yeah. And it's like you're still gambling.
You really are. I mean,
there's just no way you can notice some
of that stuff up at the estimate level.
So you almost have to just say
historically, yeah, you know,
you're an average or a high average. Yeah.
I think something that's not going to
allow here is they they estimate it a
certain way and it comes in and stacks of
inner dogs, you know, like ****,
we're screwed.
That's not that is to be notated in the
jobs somewhere.
So do we make adjustments to it? No,
go to this.
The number of is specific and you know,
but when you say it comes in,
are you saying how do you bought it from
Brown and Strauss? Yeah.
Can't you control our brand of Cows
Prince to you?
I know you've said that,
but if virus screws me,
I'm going to Samuel.
I'll go to whoever until they comply with
the way I want to get it.
I think they're under the same notion
with us. They have a second criteria here.
Why would I spend 10 hours living this
when I can spend 2 interlock it and you
hear everything on your.
Time to, you know what I mean? So hey,
can we make the request? Yes.
But then we're also driven by their
deliverables and I may get a release
today that I need to procure order and
how about my next Monday? So I get it,
you know what I mean? So,
but I think it's percent, it's 80%.
You're going to create a way that it is
standard.
There's going to be the 20% or whatever
oddballs and I I wouldn't exactly sweat
those until they started moving the
needle.
But I think these times you got to build
up for the 80% and basically you got to
build it and you got to build it for the
average guy.
Yeah, Ryan, you got your A guys, you guys,
you got a building for your average guys.
That is why the postmortem is really nice
to have to to be and say, OK, cool,
we we find on the last three jobs,
we are blowing it on unloading or
whatever you you you pick,
pick your metric, we're blowing it.
Now we're going to update these. I,
you know,
I'll go to some shops and they'll want to
adjust all their labor based off of
looking at one assembly. No, no, no, no,
no.
Do 123 jobs and see if you see a tree and
if so, then now we'll go change it.
And do it on a macro level rather than a
micro level,
which is kind of why I I kind of said OK,
handling these go up by 10%.
I don't know that I'm going to fight too
much over whether it's plate welded move
or not. You know,
I'm just going to say all of it's going,
you know, because.
It's a.
It's the 80%, so.
But it and if we have those numbers,
I think they have, we can,
we can make some changes here. Yeah,
I think it's a little database that needs
to have here, yeah.
So it's really pretty easy to change.
It's just you got to know what to change
and you got to know what it is.
What's your?
Are you a good data base user?
I have a good data base user.
Like if you were to go on,
these guys have got 100,000 things to do.
You know,
I don't know what we're doing yet. Well,
I got a pretty good idea. I'm getting it.
I think we need to be the ones having the
data because I think it'll help me learn.
I got enough data. I mean,
mine's outbased team,
but I've been doing it since. I get it.
I see it since 79 and I started sweeping
the shop and everything,
which I'm going to say.
This dollar is ********. That's right.
I didn't even say that. You're right.
I've been to other shops and and even
more metal shops. OK,
stainless aluminum and brass. It's like,
and I know it's either physically done or
watching being done for four or five or
eight years. So yeah,
I am going to look at it as I get deeper
into the system.
So we say, well, that number is ********.
That number is ********.
This one needs to go up. This one needs.
I think they're asking for help.
But but see,
it's the same experience that these guys
have because they're doing out all day.
They know what it takes.
I'll do whatever it takes to help the
company, whatever.
Todd still asked me to do it.
He asked me to help out basically when I
was hired. Look,
I want you to help out a bunch of young
project managers since you can have me
involved in their projects and give them
feedback and can help out doing their job
and he wants to be heavily involved.
In the pre-construction of the that's
what he very specifically told me.
He said, no,
I will be involved in exactly what we're
doing here.
You're going to think that should start
way half and anyone in the third thing
you must be involved in anything that's
going between the shop and the field.
I mean I've account all aspects of it.
I only do the obstruct.
It's still only for six years. It's like,
yeah,
so I kind of understand all aspects of it,
but I can't do everything all at one
season.
But I think you understand closing the
loop. Yeah,
and I think we need to teach these
project managers that when they close the
jobs out,
I don't know who to feed back to right
now.
That's why it sounds to me like these
guys here are the ones that are going to
update this after the rest of the shot,
right?
So then we had to have the same
conversation with the field people
because I'm sure there must be field
superintendents or something.
They need to be involved in the same type
of discussion regarding the field, right?
No, no, not the field.
We have the conversation, but build this.
It's just shot. Well, don't be estimated.
Don't be estimate the field to use.
But eventually, aren't they?
Are they going to want to estimate field
hours through this as well? No, no.
If you have,
you did and then you have to work. OK,
I think there's I know there's no one
that tech was not the field at all.
It's all shot. Really.
They just want to be.
And I've been,
I've been really did use it.
I worked at Bragg training starting with
the rating department.
That's all he did was install it.
They used it for that. It's not possible.
It's just we don't do that here.
So that's fine. Why don't they do it?
I'm sure I'll be involved in this. OK,
look,
show me what program you use for your
field. Let's look at it.
Then they have to sit down with their
field superintendents or their some of
their the perform and their key people
and say, look,
how long does it really take to do this?
How many sticks can you put up a day of
this type of work? I mean, you know,
regularly to.
Yeah, the ones that operate the smoothest,
what are they doing differently?
You mean like on the estimated size,
is that what you're talking about?
Yeah. Are you tired of the other? Well,
that's a pretty broad question.
So what do you mean?
Like the ones that are doing the best,
what will operate in the smoothness?
Is that what you're saying?
Are they using type of to estimate the
field,
but not to estimate the field generally,
OK.
Generally, that's outside of it.
Now I've done it when I've done it inside.
But if you were to put time right here,
it's going to mix it in with the
fabrication hours. No, no,
I think it's going to be separate.
I in there. We need to take, OK,
here's all my shop stuff.
Now there's on my field,
so it takes as much time to set a column
as much time instead of being as much
time to do a brace there.
I've built it into where because I've
seen that.
I've taken one of those parametric
assemblies. Yeah,
I've done it where it's like, OK,
how many columns you got? How many?
If it's like so much per column,
so much per being,
whatever and you put it.
You're quantities and then it it spits
out the number.
So you could build it in here,
but it's not separate labor weight for
that too.
It's like here's my here's labor weight
and all the field stuff.
That's what I've seen in the past.
It's like, OK,
so here's all the shop stuff and then
over here's my field stuff.
It's all done in the same program.
It's it's pretty.
It's going to be estimated in three
different programs. Yeah, it seems a lot.
What a lot of shops will do is it might
be it. Yeah,
the field is a different critter, right?
Yeah.
So a lot of we'll do it in a different
one,
but then bring the numbers back in here.
Sure. So.
But I'm I'm the ones that do it the best.
It's all-encompassing.
I've got my numbers in one spot. Yeah,
I I might generate some of the numbers
outside,
but I'm going to bring them back to this
spot. I agree.
I think it all should be within tech.
So that estimate summary would be the
place you do that,
bringing it into the estimate summary and
I've got my correction numbers in there,
whether they're calculated there or not.
To touch back on what Eric said,
he would be more than accepting mental
help for sure. And our plan,
what I'm thinking is first and foremost,
we need to get everything else corrected
and then we need to implement sooner than
later the.
The constant feedback with the checks and
balances of showing your data as we move
forward on all of these items. Yeah,
but right now, if we had somebody,
we'd start. I agree with you. If not,
we can't get that help.
We're going to take this other route
where we focus on getting this stuff done
and doing.
June.
I don't know how much time we have this
week, but I would like.
But good job in that job. That's done.
Completed. Shop only for now.
Let's keep the field with your stuff.
Good job in that job and we run the model.
I'll run it through here and see what the
estimate says it would do just on a
baseline case.
So we're looking at the estimate that is
apples to apples with what you actually
fabricated. Yeah,
the answer is and the answer is it's
within 10%.
Cool. Then that's great.
The answer is it's something completely
different and we could probably look at
it by operation.
We very quickly learn all of the data
once we work that as a standard.
I think life gets better.
Would it be easy to take two or three
jobs that in fact work estimated through
Tekla so that you only got to come up
with the postmortem stuff.
That's exactly what I want. Yeah, not.
I don't want to be myself starting fresh.
They went through the.
Do you have some jobs that you're
completed that they go to a bad?
That that actually were estimated within
that. Well,
we could do kind of the combination of we
got the estimate,
but let's literally take the IFC model,
import it back in as an S as an estimate
because if there's differences between
the estimate and the actual.
Yeah,
we we we kind of want to account for that
as well, right.
You're talking about changing or because
all this stuff change on the job possibly.
And yeah,
I I don't know your your specific work,
but some shops I go to estimate there's
going to be differences by the time we
get to fabricate,
but if it's very similar then we can't,
we could just.
One month, five months, a month,
three weeks,
something about the system and how to put
that together.
And then I don't know how long that's
going to take. I was hoping each day.
The day we kind of look at what's gonna
happen next day,
estimate how much time we have. Yep.
So if we have enough time,
we can fill in Wednesday.
I really think Thursday, Wednesday,
Thursday is gonna be really tied up with
the electrical stuff. Yeah,
it's the kind of.
But how do you say electrical?
How do you say electrical even? Well,
well, let me, let me, let's get this.
I want to do what you said.
So I want to figure that. Yeah,
do the easy part.
I want to figure when we do it or we can
do this on Friday.
We'd like to try to run a demo.
Go through the podium.
So either we can do this comparison,
this analysis that Eric's talking about
tomorrow eventually or Friday. So yeah,
how long does it take?
It's gonna take 10 minutes.
No, no, that that's going to be, well,
it depends on what you want to change.
We just want to look at it.
We just want to look at the data.
If it's an estimate's already in there,
yeah, looking at it,
there's nothing to it.
That's not a big real problem.
As long as there's the data on the back
end to look at,
we're putting it off for Friday. Yeah,
yeah, OK.
We have the ISC pod starting tomorrow,
March,
and we'll kind of sign in with that.
So I'll just put it in there,
just send it in for Friday and I'll
resend it out.
Just keep in mind checks and downs.
Job close out post mortem post mortem
review Friday. My flight's at 3:40,
so I just need to be out of here in time
to get to the.
I'm going home, North Carolina. Yeah,
yeah, we want to. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, yeah,
I mean that that would be great to do.
If we can make some major strides there,
that would be tremendous, I think.
So if you get it early,
I'd love to see it earlier.
I've got Tecla.
I want to see if I can make it. Yeah,
yeah,
I think we're going to be really
surprised to see how long it can take.
You know he. Yeah, he's right next to him.
Oh, he can't get to you. I asked him.
He didn't.
I acted like he didn't know how to do
whatever it was. Well,
he's just advised I really ought to.
I'll ask him.
I bugged him Thursday and he finally got
to me.
This morning, when I started Friday,
somebody else invited me in this week.
That's it. You know,
I'll put in the request.
The request got good Friday.
I sent in a second request this morning
because I didn't see a response from the
first one and all I got was, yeah,
we received a request. OK, still good.
We'll see how long it takes. Yeah,
I bugged him Friday because I haven't got
the class love that has it,
but I think somebody else can send it out
via like IT support. Yeah, send it. Oh,
I sent it like this. I sent it. OK,
I'll get one. Yeah, I sent.
8 feet away from the piece of office,
but I think somebody here was having a
problem because he said he was working on
eight different using upgrades.
It took me 3 days to get the movie and
the only bad guy was.
But Keith, he's that.
Give me about 2 hours.
He did contact and saw about three months
ago and still on. Oh, nice.
And then after a movie,
it took me another hour to get my mark.
Now all the dropping back,
you'll have to finish out all the
stainless shapes, right?
And get all those in there and everything
and make sure it pulls everything over.
But even being the stainless.
Is going to be identical to identical
times to the carbon right now, right.
So then those need to get adjusted
appropriately as well.
So that's something that I'll have to be
thought about as well,
but certainly it takes a lot longer to do
a lot of that in statements than it does.
In in carbon, yeah.
So far it's the material shape for each
size basically. OK,
just the point of any activators yet.
Like,
I know they got pretty backed up with
their training last week. Yeah,
actually they did.
They're probably picking up slack today.
So do you personally work with Exactly to
do an estimate or are you using your
experience to do it? I'll use my.
Experienced to do it and then uh, yeah,
who's our new techno Tesla?
Coordinator, if you would, he'll input it,
do his,
do the takeoff based off of there and
then we'll compare it from one to one.
So he's doing the takeoff,
utilizing the import files and then I'm
doing mine based off of physical
experience with the shop. Yeah.
And then we'll make adjustments based off
of it. Yeah.
So we need to get your brain there and
then, yeah.
That was that was the problem in the shop
where I was.
I couldn't get my brother's brain 45
years of experience in this kid's head.
So I took it from his head into here,
right?
And so then that kid could get the same
thing. So there's so many.
Everybody wanted to know my brain
estimating a certain thing,
but I always said it's always different.
And I finally just gave up and said no,
I don't need to worry about the special
case. That's where you get hung up.
Everybody does want to talk about the
fringe of stuff that.
Well, what if?
Stop talking about the what if,
get the 80% in there and there. Yeah,
it it.
It's hard enough to realize that this job
is more difficult than the average job,
and this one's a lot easier than the
average job.
The other way we should be able to look
that and go on to the job.
OK, I can use all the regular numbers.
There's there's what you got. Well, yeah,
you've used this a little bit,
but there is what's called the efficiency
factor. So you can say, hey,
I forget what the I don't believe what
you guys using efficiency.
It's at 100%.
It's like bring it down to 85. Yeah,
I had a big argument.
They moved us to 100% efficiency. I said,
well,
nothing is 100% because there's always
that factor.
So are we in the decision from the
standard 75 to 85? Yeah, right.
Be more.
Competitive,
but also I don't know who operates at
100% anything, you know, I love it. Well,
some shops I go to,
they'll run it at 100% because they got
their flood,
their inefficiencies built into the
numbers in the back. That makes sense.
So we have to use the efficiency factor.
I sat with you, you know,
like number estimated.
I sat with the estimator and he said,
oh look, I have the efficiency factor.
I'll put in X amount.
So it adjusted this numbers.
Usually the guys that use the efficiency
factor,
the norm is somewhere between 75 and 85%
where they generally fall.
I've seen as low as 50%. So, but yeah,
I got two. Yeah, uncertain items.
We're going to use twice as many hours as
I pay. Yeah, I think it's also the 28.
That's how you play with.
There's 28 of them, right?
You're gonna get better.
But if you leave yourself 100%,
you got no room doing.
You don't want to screw up too many.
You're going to get every job or you're
going to get no jobs depending on where
you said that, right?
OK.
Well, and I guess.
Question. Yeah,
based off of what we were planning for
today, do well,
we didn't talk through some of this other
stuff. I was going to say,
should we grab a job or do we It seems
like we have time and it's only 2:00.
I mean we we we talked about,
you know how to do the aluminum and and
stainless, it just has to be done, right?
And we did some of it,
but it just has to be done.
Push labor to do the added aluminum
stainless sizes. You know how to do it.
It just has to be done.
Add and adjust labor codes.
We didn't really talk through that a
whole lot.
The codes are what labor to apply and the
rates OK.
Would be it's applicable to that.
But if this is, hey,
I need a new labor code for sheer tab on
one end, clip angles on the other,
that's not already in the system.
We can build customer stuff, right?
Or we can build like a double column
labor code if we wanted to.
You need to get everything,
but then that means it easily won't open.
The best one I can't stand.
I'm using five different spreadsheets or
somebody's did this, this,
these programs like.
When you say here new codes exist,
but some do not generate labor correctly,
you want to look at that or you have a
specific example.
Yeah, we need to wait on Gavin for that.
Yeah, I think we'll OK, but I got B&
C circling back of the Gavin. OK,
D talking face fill, this restriction,
low pressure last time.
Yeah.
You're thinking about that one.
Which one's the visit date code? No,
because I don't know how they're,
how they're what?
Are we running into character
restrictions on the basically?
In the.
Or or a stupid question for me since I
don't have anything. Phase codes,
are these the operations that you're
pushing in the Vista?
That's what Vista will generate from that
estimate.
So if we take the next floor and we have
these line items.
It'll have, let's just say for instance,
if I broke that out,
it would have a move and labor code,
you know,
3010 and then it would go 3010 dash,
dash one, dash two, dash three.
So it's just a way that we communicate.
From what we're tracking to our ERP
software for financials,
are you pushing Tacla to Vista or is
Vista keystroking things in or what's
this?
We get the data from Vista based on
export and then we translate that into
your per base code.
Uh, correlation. Some of this,
some of this will send to Vista,
some doesn't.
So like what what what can go from here
into Vista are POSPO receipts,
inventory transactions.
Other than that,
nothing else flows automatically.
What's what's first?
Do you set up a job in Vista or set up a
job in Power? It it doesn't really matter.
But yeah, is that how you do it?
Basically,
that's how we generate the job and we're
coming from that software.
Beard and are the ones that set up.
So they set up this stuff and then you
guys come back and do your thing. Yes Sir,
but you've done the estimate in check,
correct?
But we cannot get this into the database
until we have a job number.
The job number comes from a generated at
Vista.
My brain is saying you estimated it in
Tekla and so you've got everything set
the way you wanted to tackle,
which should drive.
You get the job you want it. Got it. Boom.
Vista doesn't say everything's perfect
because we know what Vista wants.
Is that an evidence or does Vista cause
an extra step for you guys?
So the extra step is this isn't our end
all, be all for the estimate.
This gets exported and either.
To proboard heavy bid and then that is
exported and then sent to Vista and then
it comes back to that correct.
Well,
the never ending thing program's not
talking to each other. Yeah,
that's what you have to hear. Yeah.
Do they use all exporting or is there a
lot of manual? I'd say it's all export,
but again, that's done.
Yes.
You I don't know how long we would change
that.
Are you exporting the POS from here to
build Vista?
Because we generate the PO,
the PO numbers specifically in Vista.
So in order to create the PO in tech,
I've got to generate a Vista purchaser,
you know what I mean?
So why does it have to be that way?
Did we talk about this accounting?
The county went through. Yeah, they they.
I mean, they dictate it.
They they're on set. So I've used,
I've used tech ones specifically for
fields and they have to put it
specifically to everybody else.
Hand the the report from and I would say
accounting for the but I think the reason
we do it from.
Vista to technically I'm not the expert,
so it's not our PO.
So is so we follow a number lately. Yeah.
Do you have,
do you have to manually type out the PO
in Vista?
So you're doing it twice.
You're doing it in this and then after
that and you're doing it again.
That sucks.
So I I and I I'm emulating type out half
of the PM, yeah,
because it it auto generates.
The number portion, yeah,
because this is what they wanted and we
changed our PO configurations to match
their their number system now.
But what they realized in in our old
system used to work so much better was.
Our job number came before the PO number
and the PO number used to only be three
to four number with you know digits.
Well then they realized now if they only
have a six digit code,
so we're in the 400,000 tradings.
400,000, well,
they don't know what ******* job it goes
to until they go back to try to look into
and then they have to hope that.
So now what we have to do is is again,
so I create the PO,
I add the job and then I take that job
number like the AZR file number we're
looking at.
And I add that to the PO and then take
that full PO including the job number and
then add it to Tecla.
So the PO that the PO in Tecla PO number
does match the PO,
the PO number in this because my because
my.
So have you have you tried the export?
So have you tried? OK,
it's creating your I created in Tekla
then tried to export it. Will it?
Have you tried to see the line items good?
I'm wondering if you can see your the PDF,
the best one and dump it in tech. Yeah,
I I save the.
I save the tech surely because it's so
much cleaner.
Either that or I'll take the quote or
dump it into Vista.
A lot of people just take it.
It's it's I'm going back and forth
between the I'm.
I'm curious if it will actually be
employed in that area. I so with Vista,
I just do it as a I don't.
I don't include everyone.
You don't you don't.
What you received? No, it's the lump sum.
Oh,
OK cuz I mean this much money that you're
actually typing in the tech in tech.
I was making an assumption. Yeah, yeah,
sorry, no. So I'm not doing. OK, OK,
but if you wanted to go over.
I'm wondering if if we could still do it.
If you wanted to do that, you know,
I think it'd be great for that, yeah,
but I I mean.
Can you define PO for me?
Is the PO coming?
Is the PO coming from the customer? No,
we we issue the PO to the vendors.
The vendor purchases the vendor and
supplier.
You guys are talking here about
purchasing material material from.
Whoever. But yes, what you're talking,
I might be wrong here is.
This is all this is internal.
You're not buying.
Are you buying on a second or you're
buying on the Vista?
Yes, he gets the,
he gets the number for Vista, the job,
he gets the number, the PO number,
the job number.
Then he takes all that and he enters it
into Tecla and he actually writes out the
person in a text if I understand
correctly. Where's the customer PM?
That's your contract. I mean, Bob,
you have to work the customer orders.
Now when you say the customer,
like the people we're doing the work for,
yeah, that'll be, OK,
so the work comes in.
There's a spot for it exactly.
Once you get a job,
you can turn your estimate into a project,
if I'm not mistaken, right?
You get the job. So we got this job.
So now we got to pull the building from
an estimate to a project, right?
It doesn't pull the data,
but you got to set up the project. Yes,
I set up the project in there.
Yeah,
that's why you guys can't start it in
Tekla because that's that has to be done
before anything gets done.
Right.
You got to have a quarter in Vista before
you can give it in.
That's like I think what you're saying is.
Creating the PM,
but not finalizing it so that there's
essentially just no information other
than the PM number and then the backer
and then seeing all the line by the line.
Yeah, I don't know if it would do.
I don't even know if you need to do it
cause actually you probably put one other
item in with the total maybe even quicker
than trying to export.
Yeah I mean I wasn't going to say how
much time is to add to my work flow,
but I mean if this is what it needs to be
done to like if it's simplifies somebody
else's job.
Wait, what is?
This is how I'm procuring this. Yeah,
let me hear me as well as the PC for the
shop, yeah.
So we don't have a dedicated programmer
procurement. Yeah, all of that.
Everybody here, you buy all the material,
all raw material, all raw material. OK,
so let's say the PO.
They get the invoice in.
I'm not sure of the total process,
but they get the invoice invoice in.
Let's say it doesn't match what you have
on the PA. What do they do with that?
Do they come back to you? Yeah,
they get the but typically he adds a
snippet of the detailed one in Tecla
because that's also how we set up our
overdue schedule.
By that item,
you have to attach it to the one. Yeah,
to the one.
I guess you have to do the one item and
attach that into the.
Just so you guys know, Tammy,
as soon as you have access to Vista,
you can talk to him.
It's kind of weird here,
but and everybody can talk to you.
So like, if I'm putting this,
it's a fund by a new drill board or they
wouldn't buy into a drill middle,
they're not going to.
The way when I got here is like great for
all.
So when I'm doing one thing I do if I
have a guy in the warehouse,
he is doing all the funneling,
all procurement for receivable and OK and
trying to minimize everyone else not not
so much.
From the perspective of control of cost,
but more of taking those responsibilities
away from people so they can focus on
other stuff. Yeah. So ideally, and yeah,
so this is where we're talking,
we're not always as much at all,
but we're getting,
I believe we'll say no more than
consumable price, right.
Well.
Correct. Right. I do for my work.
If that is the case, he doesn't mind.
I would have it. I would have it.
I would have the issue.
I'd say everybody's job waiting. Yeah,
automatic reports can be dependent.
Hey, Cortana.
Just our It varies.
It depends on the moving some jobs.
Good job. Yeah, I understand.
The next thing is to have. Yeah,
that's right.
Taking the information from that one,
supporter, letting you know.
True bits. Everything is at least three.
And then I get the and then I'll reach
out and have a guidance.
Sometimes it's only one field.
It's like it's three. Who? Who asked you?
It's I don't know.
You're nesting too. Yes.
This is programming all of the the play.
Wow. I've never heard of the procurement.
I'd be a nesting guy. Well, I I hear you.
I hear you. There's one.
Instances of it happened because I've
been researching here.
I've been researching your your role and
all the stuff in there. For example,
project coordinator,
project coordinator typically doesn't
have.
No, no, never.
But there's jobs out there that you can
look up when you tell them it's your
little shop that they're only operating
three guys. Yeah,
that's what it's like other place that
they.
You know, you got a project manager,
a project engineer, a project coordinator.
They turn around and they say, oh,
you know what? I need this part.
They gather,
they hand it over to the purchasing agent
and that guy just purchasing it and then
track and let him know.
That's the minority of the shops I go to.
I mean, vast minority.
I I would say 95 to 98% of shops I go to,
the purchasing agent is doing the nesting
as well. Yeah, totally.
By far, because instructional,
it's supervised. Yeah, the system does it.
The system does it for you. Yeah,
I get it.
Wait until you start getting the complex
stuff. Yeah, so, but going back to this.
It compliance. Yeah, yeah,
but I'm talking nesting it to this,
to our actual systems,
to our actual machines.
How many times last year we could program
on Java in there?
Did all of them required?
All of them required?
You're you're talking about.
Doing the combining and then also doing
it basically for the machines as well
because of no integration. Pronis,
you're in Pronis there, right?
And that was on the thing, right?
And that was really the thing I was
working on Friday,
but we'd still have to see the dronis
first.
But then for it to pull into, yeah,
checkpoint. Yeah,
that's how we provide how much sheet we
need. Yeah, sure. Yeah.
So like what I do now because vendors,
not to say that they're, they take,
you know,
time to gather all their information
before they give it back to them.
I'll find it out.
So at least they're working on something
for me 'cause it's a lot easier to say,
hey, I thought I needed two sheets,
but I actually need 4 sheets. So yeah,
so I send it out to them.
I go back into our system, figure out, oh,
I actually do need these many sheets or
actually instead of sheets is I'm gonna
go with A5X instead of.
4 by 8 because of the primers of our our
machines.
We give them kind of an advanced building
type of thing so they don't get some of
this stuff and we start working.
But you yeah,
you could even nest nest the plate in the
system for ordering purposes.
And then for,
but you're going to do it in progress to
see what you really need.
This is real numbers. You offer this.
Yeah, you guys are getting ripped off.
There's some big numbers for standards.
Oh yeah.
I mean the 260 looks OK,
the 810 for a channel.
688 for a piece of.
Those are some big numbers and that was
our speaking approach.
OK.
Well, you're buying a four by eights.
Nobody loves that.
You're buying from post.
It's not the low bid stainless guy.
They were lower the price. Really.
So if you guys have connection,
we're going to take, you know,
whoever you're using on your price.
Particularly going back to this.
So if you want to give me,
we can look at trying to get that in
there because it is supposed to import.
Now the general flow is they're saying
imported to Vista, imported to Vista.
Yeah. So if it's a benefit to you, cool,
it's gonna take more time.
I don't know that I if it's working now,
don't break it, right? You know,
so I don't know that I I I would,
but we will see if you wanted to.
Either way I I still still I still have
to create the price.
It's not going to limit you need you need
Vista creating the number then yet.
But what I'm saying is can you just
create the PO without anything and then
we we push the line items over.
No,
created in Vista just with no lot items,
no nothing on the PO.
You've created the PO, just don't.
You're not putting any. Yep.
And then and then you created it in
Tackler, right?
And then you push from Tecla over to
Vista and all the line items go over with
the. Yeah, you can make a.
The typical flow would be you create it
in in Tecla and you push it over.
It creates it in this.
Yeah, so,
but but you got to have the numbers.
I do know that Vista,
if if anything changes on the PO,
that's a problem, right?
Like you ordered a 40, they ship,
they ship you a 45 footer, right?
That that's a that's a problem.
You got to go manually change that,
but I'm going back and manually changing
the lump sum number. Yeah,
if they do that to me. Yeah.
So so if you want to look at it,
I don't let's see.
I'm not.
I'm not as much of an expert there,
but we can we get the right people
involved if that's a benefit.
If it's not a benefit, don't do it.
I think it's at least worse if it can do
that. If it does, I agree. Alright, I see.
So if if if that is the case,
phase codes are critical cost codes in
here,
they are critical that you end up on
everything.
So I think we're just looking at is it
easier for you to.
Yeah,
take a PDF at a tech down to to Vista or
as he's here to transfer, right?
Yes.
If it's if, if it's working the way it is,
I don't know that it's any better,
but if it gives them more information and
less questions back to you, maybe.
Person.
Gosh, that'd be really possible. Maybe.
Maybe we don't do it. Yeah, don't do it.
Everything's all good.
Let's don't create a problem.
Just know it's there if if down the road
you there's a needle. Well,
you probably need to check your projects.
And there is like 3, two, one.
206 a pound and three or four,
one and three were just a couple.
That is really high numbers,
like $8 and $6 a month.
Were they an oddball size? Did you notice?
That's nameless,
isn't that much like we've worked with a
lot, so yeah.
It didn't seem that on all I mean,
but they probably aren't just stocking
distributors,
so they're probably getting it from
somebody else and you're paying to get it
there. He definitely, yeah,
he's got another plan that he offers,
but it it was.
So I just really look at the totals that
you're buying.
They bought it from his guy at Ryerson
and resold it to him.
And I I think that's, you know,
I think Ryerson knows I don't all operate
that way.
Maybe the more volume you do with them,
the better they're priced against them
essentially. And they all sort of.
If he was, you know, if you,
since I don't think that you're doing,
I'm really, I see you all,
I see you all around in any look,
all of it has to be shot. Yes, yeah,
but if it's not, if it's not.
There are some instances where the guy's
gonna be able to ask me to work here
something. Yeah,
if it's going to the field directly,
that's that's outside. Who does that?
They were PM.
How do you like to do the PM? The PE?
The PE? The PM will task the PE.
Like I said, sometimes they.
Reach out and then ask me to either
provide a vendor or.
I'm just surprised it's not like one that
everybody feeds them on data. Yeah, right.
It's surprised what happened.
Every other product company I did that.
So the plan was, yeah,
recon here at rotor system that's coming
about and that would be there would be a
preparing the person in there to prepare
for this facility and all the other
facilities. So I guess what's the?
Yeah,
because that's how you make it easier for
one person to do it all.
You're actually going to save money
because instead of having 10 different
people going to all these places to buy a
little bit here and over there,
one person is buying everything he may
say, even though he's probably in here,
may have said, oh,
I think he can buy a beer for his rights.
Well, this guy is purchasing every day,
all night for a living.
He knows he can get a better price on
that big item.
He can work all of it for 500 jobs at the
same time. Not really one.
Our can you get a better price our.
Processes require me to reach out to our
PDS and PMS if there is an overrun on
material, but yeah,
but that's purely the customer I see.
I see under the budget.
Sure.
There's the few instances where it's very
tight and I there's only so many vendors
and so many strings I can ask to hold.
Yeah, that's good.
Who's your biggest vendor?
Currently, probably.
Uh, it used to be born in anything,
kind of like what year and a half ago,
but not rice.
The problem with brown is to be able to
play. So sure, they're great on, you know,
beams and HSS.
But if that vendor been acquired by Delta
Steel,
they are pricing it's that they're eating
brown for recasts.
Even on the even on the we've got a
really good relationship with them.
So I mean and I tell all of my my vendors
like listen if you want our business like
it's it's price.
That's all the time.
That'd be great if it. But it's, you know,
I've got no problem like making them
compete though.
I'll tell them like I'm getting it for
this price.
I won't tell them we want them to get it.
Yeah, yeah. And if you can either, yeah,
yeah, 100%.
I say that I said, you know, you're close.
I don't know.
I'll never tell anybody anybody's price.
It's a it's a line. That's the words.
Those are the words. That's what I use.
That's the ones I use.
I like playing games with me,
so I play games with them.
This is the price and that's what.
We have to have you take,
there would be this out and any problems
with you during this time.
I'm just surprised you are. Yeah.
You're all and all the other stuff you do.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, all of them.
All those things carrying everything on
the shoulder. Well,
then it's saying we got all these BB's.
We just right. We just the coding project,
yeah.
But as you get to the PM's and the TD's
are all right in the first order too. Yes,
hereby all the pain too. Not right now,
but will eventually. Yeah,
they want me to do that also.
That's really simple, though we need.
So it's like, that's not something.
That sounds like still.
It's produce for us really easy.
It's very delicious. It's simple.
You know, we're seeing,
we're seeing the difference with our
consumables and our tools by finally
living with one guy,
trying to stop everybody else from
purchasing.
It's a nightmare because everybody has
access and control right now.
Through this building program, yes,
we'll get to that. Oh,
they can't have that back say, hey,
who wants out of the business?
You gotta go to Skype.
But you can't have vendors, right? I mean,
though,
some there's gotta be a control where.
The vendors are rather at a higher level.
They are, but it's. I can ask.
I can just send it to every nine vendor
and send it over to OK,
they're in and they'll have it. Yeah,
no questions asked. OK.
It depends on the what it is,
but there's some requirements,
but it's just 79 two.
I'm assuming they negotiate payment terms
with each vendor,
they this many days or whatever, no.
That's what you know.
They'd like to pay you and you might see
if you're not, you know, pay for six.
You should be able to get suppliers.
So if you don't want to get paid in 30,
you don't pay you in 19.
If you want to get paid in 19, we pay you.
We're in the transition period where
things are changing.
So because there's some intricacy.
So we just now know we can go in and make
notes.
I think they desire to be director
procurement to saw that last week.
What is the director? We have to.
Good question. Thank you, thank you.
Did he agree with the purchasing?
I don't think so.
Right now warehouse is kind of he's been
talking directly with the management is
long. They've been guiding him.
They got him through this acne tool,
the tool crit.
And they're he's staying in line with
that.
Ideally we would have to be one person
here to do that.
My biggest thing is we're not coding
everything correctly, so we have to again,
it's extra work for people at Mark and
I'd like to resuse purchases.
Was.
And you're sure that you've been totally
correctly.
It was aimed at and we had to use that
one.
Everything seems to stretch to fault
sometimes when purchasing games for a
year to date.
It's like now I'm like the day supports.
This is the question.
Was it better or worse last year before
the acquisition?
What's that? Well,
it depends on your definition in that
case. I mean,
I know it was better because everything
was kind of local,
step up and local and now things will
become more, more,
more time constraints on these things,
you know, and they're.
We work for accountants,
that's their their accountants at the
core.
So everything in financial language more
or less.
So that's the biggest problem here and
there's no change like.
The spoggles, we tell them, you know, hey,
these are awesome,
but we're going to just throw them and
it's hot as **** in the summer and these
fog up and they said bad, but that's,
you know, you're getting fired.
So it's like they they don't really
respond well to certain things.
So we've had to try to navigate and do
things.
Figure out.
But no,
we don't want to keep purchase these.
But no,
we know there's there's some people that
are over.
But do we have other things or it's just
open floor? I you know,
if we're done with the J job,
it's a full job.
I'd love to full job if we're done.
For a job from this.
Go ahead.
Who? Who here is under Wells is the best?
That when Arizona wouldn't this adjust?
That's.
I'm going to tell you,
all things Bell does a really good,
good job. All things Bell. They're small,
but they they run real, real.
They're pretty custom about something.
They they do a lot of structures.
They're short on this slide.
I was cutting edge. Do you know them?
I don't know. I don't know.
I'll do 90 minutes. Sure.
I was just looking at jobs like that.
Well, so let's, I guess The thing is,
let's look and see what the labor is for
this comparing what it what you.
Did and then see what we if we determine
what we would want to adjust.
And I guess one of the questions I would
have is does the estimate really match
the actual, in other words,
where the big changes between the
estimate and the actual to where we
really compared apples and oranges.
You know if if if what the estimate is
similar to what you actually did,
we can adjust off of it, but.
That's what we're doing in the post war.
Yeah, yeah,
I need to stand up because I can't.
For shop now,
are they actually entering in weld time
versus cut times versus, you know,
general fabrication and layout?
Are they not separating that and shopping
them? No, we've separated all of that.
And that's what's getting reported.
That's correct. So what happening? Yeah,
that's solver.
That way if it's a normal run on one
specific thing,
that's how we got accounted. Yeah,
that makes perfect sense. Yeah,
because if we look at it,
you can see a lump sum.
We should change the S.
Is that how you look at every job?
Handling cuts off? We should change the S.
So it just gives you those tones instead
of.
All the breakdown of get piece move,
all that jazz. Yeah, that'd be nice. Yeah,
I see this.
The the hours fields aren't showing on
here. You want to.
Is that what you're looking for?
Just I'll bring up the column.
You go down at the bottom Gantt chart
display settings.
And hit the little arrow and then Scroll
down in that list and then you can check
the the hours and stuff there so it'll
show up.
I don't know where the years are linked
regular or overtime or whatever, but yeah,
total I appreciate it.
So is he knowing you need is 12 hours for
each one of those categories that we
talked about? OK,
so he's got a far right with the size of
12 hours. Yeah, yeah.
OK.
Hey, do do what? Check one other thing.
Scroll down in here. Go. Um.
Do you put it in original estimated,
I'm assuming,
or you just put the hours in adjustment?
I believe.
The adjustment. OK, so that's the. OK,
cool.
So you're saying 30 was basically your
estimated hours and 29 is your actual.
Yeah, that's pretty good. OK,
so I got a question on that.
Show me that item.
Give me a give me a line item.
Or is that particular? Is that one piece?
No, that's the entire piece. I know.
I guess you're super close on the whole
thing. Drill down for me a little bit.
Show me a piece.
Scroll to the right to cause.
Are we seeing the whole picture here?
Yeah, that's it.
So it's just sequence one.
How come it has the base hours is 0 on
the left and then you end up having total
hours on the right.
Base hours are supposed to be pulled from
check. OK, yeah, it it pull.
So the way this can work is you can leave
the production control job to the
estimate and it will say OK,
based off the estimate,
here's hours per ton and that can be
broken down in many ways.
It will apply it to the material that's
in production control and it will flow in
as base hours.
That can then be compared to estimated
hours. So it might be OK,
I have 150 hours of of estimated,
but my base hour says you really got 200
hours of work.
That's what I'm using to plan for the
schedule.
So it's kind of like base hours is kind
of like a re-estimate.
Actually use.
You're telling me this is accurate?
You guys are that close on it.
That's pretty damn good. Yes,
I like this is only have 30 hours, right?
120 hours.
What we're looking at right here at the
top, it's going to take all of those.
So you have well fed up. OK, I see.
What I'm missing is shows are spot on.
Yeah, I'm looking in QC time. Yes.
So QC time,
which is highlighted at the bottom there.
So it's my project.
OK, I get you there though,
because everybody, I mean,
you got a job for like 4 or 500 hours.
What I'm missing though is where is the
total estimated in the total?
Actual Can you bring up the Gantt chart
display settings again real quick? Yes,
Sir.
And Scroll down do total planned hours.
And now scroll. Holy cow.
How's it that close? Yeah, that's hard.
That's why they bring up a big job.
So you'll see like we went over.
But by now we're not. By now we're not.
We say 10 hours on and now we're saying.
I can't believe that happened on the
majority of the jobs.
We can bring up the moment here.
These when they're smaller,
you can look at it down to take off of
the.
No one will do it.
I'd like to see something with several
$100 in it.
So did those estimated hours actually,
are they residing in that estimate or is
that the here's what I think it's going
to?
I guess move. Very good.
Those that's how long it would be
whatever was given to me.
So I would assume that that's.
So then let's give the estimate and let's
look and see what the estimate came up
because if the estimate came up with 25
total hours,
we got a lot of adjustment to do.
So yes, 7119.06. Now is that the same?
Are we comparing the same material to the
same material? We got 8700 panels here.
What was it over there, do you know?
8800 essentially a second so.
Oh.
So 119 hours versus what was at the end
of. So let's do this.
Go back to the SM plan.
And go to the uh, click anywhere.
There we go.
Now go to the drop down at the top
estimating drop down.
3rd from the bottom view labor details.
Right click, dump that out in Excel.
We'll kind of sum this up to get it in
the same chunks as what you got on your
schedule.
You want to export it to something you
said? Yep.
What percent of the job that you
estimated you went?
Most I'd say 98 OK,
what percentage of the job that you
overestimates? I'll win 5050, which, yeah,
any less. I hear the win rate is 4%.
Yeah, yeah. So I got it. No, no, exactly.
Yeah, I got you.
A lot of what I do is the the bridge
planning runways,
which are pretty regular, pretty regular.
So you know,
you know you're going to get before they
even give me.
But they also build it more regularly so
they know how long it takes because it's
a repetitive product.
So you got a 98% get rate. I'm good.
We got to fix the 4%,
4% is not unusual for it's it's.
Very, very low.
I've seen 4 or 5% of a lot of,
for example, ASD,
because they're so automated,
they have like 20% because they have,
they can get any job where they want to.
They're more set up to do the work.
They can do it cheaper.
Did you get this? Yeah.
So let's what's what's the breakdowns on
the estimate?
It's what's the what's that breakdown you
have? You got cut, fit, weld or handling.
Yeah.
So I want to get that that total hours
called.
I I want to get that in the same
categories as what's on the schedule.
So like take maybe down here,
down at like a 25 or something,
put in like him on it and then we'll get
on this cut and then we'll tell the
buddies down.
Is this a comment? This is me. Oh,
comment is a little bit different. OK,
yeah, yeah.
They don't bother me and it's a it's all
a problem.
OK, so let's let's get those totals.
You want the tolls from the any. Yeah,
from that column,
anything that's going to be considered
handling, I guess so.
6.
So my guess would be this one.
I'm assuming receiving material handling,
move layout. That would fit up, right?
That'd probably fit up, I would imagine.
No, I think that's about it.
They're handling. I mean,
if you have another problem,
you put handling in,
you can just sum it by handling.
It's interesting move isn't in there.
Load would probably be part of it too,
right? So I would,
I would assume receiving material
handling 16.
2014 I say about 20 hours,
which category do you sum up? So layout,
pinch, fit up, starting,
will clean material handling be part of
handling? OK.
Right, but.
You got, yeah, 14150 both.
I'm saying smoke this for you.
It's not doing.
You got to put a cost in after each month,
right? Yeah, or click one at a time.
After equal sum,
put a left a left bracket and then click
on one.
And then left bracket. Yeah,
add all the numbers we arranged from.
This this new people. Yeah.
Get ready to be slow.
Get rid of the sun.
14 load that would be part of the way.
Say it right. Looks like it. Yeah.
The cut is probably anything we're
processing. Is that correct?
So probably cut all those and everything,
right? So cut, you mean? Yep, Yep.
Um, you probably won't search.
OK.
Here. I think it's down there.
That's it then, right? Think so. OK.
We left it plus at the end, but OK, OK,
we're good. So yes,
it's not really like 54 plus 570.
It's just because it's too big to take
the width.
Not pretty.
There you go.
Format cells to use in place, is it?
Cool.
Like tell me about.
Yeah, you are. We already got cut.
We already got cut in the cut.
So you want to do just the burn,
just burn,
just burn and burn because you put cut,
burn.
In cut.
Ask your point before.
That's it, right? Yeah.
But it would be in layout right there.
Philip and Philip.
Voice FP. Well, yes, it's very well.
That's a full pen, full pen. Well,
that's under well.
Oh yeah, yeah.
And then well, there's 9 and 10.
You're talking about QC before,
that's what that checking is.
So it it is calculated in there,
but what's the total of that?
Does that equal our 119?
We didn't put check in anywhere.
I don't think so. It's 90.
Yeah,
I think we're missing check and we're
missing that other down there or that
other might be.
On this job, this is all 100. Yeah,
super close. Yeah, this is the breakdown.
This is the breakdown of your estimate
level.
Yes.
Yes, it is. That's too good for me.
I think people here know what they're
doing. The estimators don't. Well,
but I think there's also some control
issues.
There's there's a lot of issues.
So the only thing we're missing is the
other and the check.
That's those two add up with 113.19119.06.
That's what we're missing.
So with the check or layouts or we
haven't pick out spot.
I think check was one that added
separately down on the schedule somewhere
else. Is that correct? No,
it was it's tracked but not added. OK,
so it's it's direct under QC time. OK,
but it's not it'll give them a a number.
They just,
they just apply as many hours as they
work on the job.
We'll leave it out to go back over the
into the schedule.
Let's get the hours from the schedule
line up right next to these and see what
how they actually compare.
QC is not estimated.
Is that what you're trying to get? Yeah.
And then when we're doing financial
reviews there,
you know if you go over there,
but QC is an estimate,
that's that's what that check is. So.
But it's not. Well, it isn't in tackle,
but it isn't in any of the other.
It's we're gonna be looking and even then,
even when it's shown in,
it's not a number that we.
It's just zero.
They apply them if they need to check the
material. I mean,
Mark can touch more on that than I can.
Is that is the QC time added during the S?
Yeah, OK, by the month, but it is intact.
That's that's what that's what I'm not
getting.
I mean because we had so we were giving
up the basing hours out of the Tecla that
take off right.
Well so we put it to one point none of
those hours which it should have been I
believe it's like 5 some change.
Should have gone to QC.
They utilized almost 30, so.
But it's all that feedback looks like
working. It'll never get fixed.
I'm I'm still missing though, so to be it.
Check.
They have so many different steps that
they're checking,
but there's 119 to take on.
That's what you used on the schedule.
120 is what we utilized. So but then,
but if you include QC, right,
so five of those should have been so
technically 5.
Over. Mm-hmm. But if you include QC time,
we were over. I think it was 140. OK,
yeah.
What we've asked at minimum if they're
not comfortable giving a number,
it's just how does there are some buckets
so that they can kind of start getting an
average,
whether typically it's like 3 or 4% of
the project budget is what a larger job,
right? It's what they should use.
And the rest of that,
do you guys have to wait on QC? Yep.
And who pays for that time? We.
And so do you guys use a flagging system
to flag those up?
QC got 5 minutes and drop them. Yep.
No, we don't want to talk to you.
It could take me 5 minutes.
It could take me 20 minutes. OK, well,
you know what happens. Well,
if you're standing waiting for a quality
check in shops that push this flag goes
up, the flag needs to be down.
Because of all understanding. Well,
we've done,
we always just have another state that
they move to to. Yeah,
but that is definitely not always had the
luxury of saying go to this next skid.
I get it. Same thing.
Sometimes you're waiting.
We're doing.
So is that the same breakdown as what we
had on the estimate? Yeah.
So the the aspect of course that we know
gets a little more granular with like
load unload and we kind of just
consolidated.
Well that's that's what we just did was
we consolidated.
So I want to I want to yeah see how it
compares to it.
And that's what I'm saying.
We can go ahead and set it up so that it
automatically breaks it down like that if
you want to.
Right now we get the lump sum and then
we'll break it down on a sheet like is
our initiation sheet. We said, hey,
you have 120 hours,
here's how we want to see it broken down
and all that stuff.
So handling we showed roughly,
you guys have a matching schedule with
your total hours available and the hours
you're doing each day or you're not using.
I have one that I specifically use. Yeah,
Excel, Excel Wise,
but what we want to touch base on this
week is.
Incorporating our work packages that
we've been doing for several months now
and seeing that on a master.
So that breakdown is all backed out.
It doesn't match. So what how did,
how did you get the breakdown of 3012840
and 30?
The breakdown will come from the project
engineers. After they get the export,
they'll consolidate it and then give us
those.
We consolidated it from the estimate,
right?
But Gap would have been the one in this
specific instance to consolidate it for
that specific instance, so.
Moved. But what I'm saying is,
if this is what you're looking at right
here, if that's what's on this,
how do we get these numbers?
How do we get that right?
The project manager project in here said
I know here's what we think it's really
going to take.
We're going to use this many hours here,
this many hours there.
It's different from you.
Yeah. But some of this, yeah, yeah,
I understand.
They just broke up how they saw fit.
If you look at fit and well, historically,
we know that that was, well,
it wasn't taken for me now versus yeah,
what we're heading.
So that's why you would have taken.
All of those 12 hours and allocated them
to.
Is anybody else saying to DS that they
got that that right? I am.
That's what I want to see a job he did
because he knows what he's doing.
I want to see a job done by the
estimators.
Sitting over there in Gilbert with 500
hours.
So I want to see how that's not doing
this. It's being done by hand.
But but what I'm saying is OK,
so we took the 100,
we took the total hours and I'm just like
you may be telling me at the end of the
job. They broke this down so tight.
So rematch 100% of what happened in the
shop? No.
I don't.
I'm I'm just wondering how that happened.
You know that's that's really damn good
that they did that before you know flag
started getting raised so.
It's nice to see you.
You want to look at this one.
Do you have a 5 minute one?
I want to look at what you've done by
this.
I want that right in right view so that
we so that we can see an average as well.
I get a different area,
so it's never going to match until the
estimates are.
Estimate. OK,
then I guess what I'd like to see is one
of the project engineer and project
manager did versus actions.
Can you look at that?
It would be good to see their estimated
tech lab versus their.
You know their set up, it will match.
Well, that that's what's interesting.
So like you know our larger project,
we did 600 tons for LG.
Our pre-car team treated me as a stub,
so I went in and reestimated it all
myself. Yeah,
so that they could sell to me if it
aligned with their budget instead of
shocking it around me.
So even the ones that are in here that
are larger sounds,
I'm still on my back and redoing the leg.
It was already done, you know what I mean?
So it's kind of hard to.
Hold that loop.
I'd say they are all all been similar,
but closer, closer minus.
I'll tell you what,
I'll do this real quick because what what
I want to do.
What I want to do is I want to set these
if we can get 241025 hundred jobs,
the more the better lay them out side by
side like this so that I can see.
The trend so that if we see the
handling's always under by 20%,
then you know that's what I'm wanting to
see.
So it's been 2019 and I'm still worried
another.
Alright, so we'll gather,
I'll put it down as an extra and we'll
see by let's say by the end of this week
to give us some time to consolidate that
that fair.
I'm impressed that you guys are really
that for estimating to your job's done.
You did everything,
but you just that's pretty good.
I've never been in a company that's done
that before. What do you judge on?
Are you judged on what you do here or is
it judged on what pre prom?
What's Wonderbuck looking at?
Wonderbuck is not looking at.
The job is sold for $1,000,000.
They decided to use you because you were
cheaper.
So you were even cheaper than their
estimates.
So they you beat their estimate by 10%
and you beat your own estimate by 3%.
I'm kind of wondering where the judging
is being made.
Because I can see if you do your wonder
book, you're judging against yourself,
but if you're part of a bigger piece,
then I assume that bigger piece has its
own wonder book. Well, on on that one,
I think we're still trying to establish
that good by using the algae. Again,
it was an 8 million project.
OK, I have 4 million of it.
So until I was done with my then the
build portion started and I just kind of
have it off. We left, you know,
it all rolled up on her.
But that'd be a great question. You know,
when you're speaking with Mr. Robino,
you know a lot of it changes,
especially since we're kind of really
getting to the group with Bowen Broad, so.
Yeah,
I'm just looking at a lot of data and
just curious about how these numbers roll
out.
What was that other job name? What was it?
99 L OG20LX.
The 25, OK. And that's the sitting. OK,
I'm just going to set all these side by
side as we do them and see what that
actually is.
Um.
So on this one then.
So if we could do the same thing here,
I would like to see what the estimate is,
the estimated hours,
what your breakdown was and then what the
actual are same same type deal on this
one.
You want what we stand to 15 projects to
do?
Do that 10 to 15 projects you'd like to
see or well, the the more the better.
The bigger the sampling, the more.
Like I'll sometimes do this with 567
different ones and you'll find this one
job that is just totally whacked and it's
the outlier. I'm not.
The rest of my labour based off a bit,
right?
But the rest a lot of times follow to a
general pattern where it's high over 20%
over 20% under.
2% for the whole audit. Yeah,
that's crazy. That's amazing.
And that was like one of the estimate.
That's good, right?
That's that's unbelievable. Really.
I'm actually unbelieving ****.
And like a lot of what we've done,
we started implementing, you know,
this in 2020 and I can say, you know,
probably within the last 14 months
everything has been, you know,
a lot more teasing.
But if you go historically,
I definitely have some bumps and bruises
and scars.
I mean, you see,
you worked with me on Shout Pavilion on
that project. So you know what I mean?
I remember coming here twice as big for
about 6 or 8 weeks meeting with you. Yeah.
So can we get the breakdown of handling
cutburn fit well?
Um, overall.
We give you this.
Skewed because we had where we have eight
different lots and each lot have anywhere
between one to three, 8 sequences,
one to three lots per nine sequences.
So he's one of the, yeah,
he's one of these, OK.
That's cut saw, but I was just.
I'm trying to think how we can get the
total.
Get see where it says task up there.
And on the header going down, go down.
Right there. All right.
Over to the over to the right of it.
There's a little arrow.
Hit that and on handling in there.
It did not give us just a breakdown of
handling, did it?
Yeah,
but what if you do a full dump into Excel
of all this data and then run a pivot
table to consolidate the data?
Have you put the tables?
We have, yeah,
because it would be pretty quick. Well,
the problem would be getting this out to
Excel.
Well, that's that's what I'm saying.
Get me into Excel.
How am I getting it into Excel?
Cause it doesn't export.
You go up to the project schedule drop
down, go to export.
You got an export into Primavera or
Microsoft Project.
Is the camera on it with AI? Oh,
I see what it may be slow.
Do it in APDF and then have it look at
PDF to to do it.
You take a picture with the phone.
Um.
Try reports.
Actually close this,
go hit the report down at the bottom
right.
There we go.
Save that as a PDF.
I've never seen any place before. Yeah,
that's why. Yeah, that's amazing.
There's probably some.
You've been around.
You don't see any bugs do that right now.
You're up by 230% either way. Yeah,
it's there's big swings. Yeah,
depending on the day.
I don't know what's in the shop, dude.
Can't you pull up? That's awesome, man.
Exactly, I guess.
That's awesome. It it's awesome.
So what does at the end of John still
hits my labor building?
It's like Alan's procurement time. Yeah,
the project set up.
QC time,
all those numbers are not signed into
here. So once you incorporate,
you know the six month project,
but they're ahead of time,
then you're probably looking at that 20%.
Is they're ahead of time to get charged
to to the job? Is it job custom? Yes, Sir.
OK, so it's not like overnight, right? No.
I've been told to target to the project,
not to reduce.
But how are you supposed to do this?
Those numbers though,
are reflected right here though on the
schedule. No,
this is just my my guys in here because
those are, you know, that's not a count.
There's not.
Well, with that, his time, his, you know,
your guys is not. It's it's not.
It's not estimated.
So when you pull this job up in Vista on
the work report,
you're going to see those numbers skewed
because we have indirect costs that still
is associated with the job itself.
So when you look at it, you probably,
Oh yeah, it's about 20%.
Well,
this is just a a a labor basis for
production.
The fact that their labor is that close
to any place they've been a lot of it on
here too that also does pretty well is
all our beans come in 90% on this project.
So this is just labor. You're thinking,
well, they come free process. Oh,
so if I don't have to do all that,
then I'd probably be in a lot.
Closer to what you're when it when it
gets estimated,
they do figure the the beam line work.
I'll call it right the the beams cut code
you know mark sometimes if they know I my
limitation with the W30 and thought as
work if you run into issues resolved.
So, but if not,
I'll go take my dollar amount for labor
and transfer that over to a subcontractor
about you. Oh yes, Sir.
So like this one, it was all lump sums.
But when I see the project,
how can I make sure we're successful?
How can I make sure we get schedule and
get the budget?
Then that becomes about me for needs and
methods. Well,
I don't want to take these beans,
so fall out, take my dollars.
They're charging me 95 bucks a bean,
but I'm doing it for 150 on the shot.
So you know what I mean? So.
There's that in consideration when we
when we get these released as well.
So when they estimate,
they don't know what's going to be about
or not. No,
they just estimate the time in there.
Did you get cited or print or would you
be right? Just to see if I can export it.
I'm going to say it as the by the way,
kudos y'all are doing this schedule.
That's awesome. That's really,
really cool. It's really great.
Is that was that sarcastic or towards me?
Because I'm the one that, you know,
has him do it.
Do you want to work with the other?
Yeah, like this. They have to be a person.
You have to do this for. OK, got it.
We we've gotten this.
It was difficult at first,
but I think now that we have a lot of
them already preset, yeah,
it's not so bad.
Now that we've worked in the work
packages,
that's one of those lovely ones where I
get to my reports and they start bringing
them up and.
Are not including what I'm saying.
I'm going to realize time and then do my
work package.
You can break this down by work packages
too. Now by the way,
I don't know if that helps, but you could.
It can be a breakdown item as opposed to
sequencer a lot or in addition to
sequencer a lot.
So what percentage of the work that they
do in their UX and bio?
No, we're getting to have it here.
I'd say about maybe 25%. When you do that,
you can say whatever money,
whatever they pull out,
they deduct that from the office in here.
Yes, Yep.
So in fact, like never see those.
That can see the the deductive amount.
They you know the time you put it into
the system,
we've already made that call on
adjustment. Yeah, got it.
Are you plugging something in the base
hours? Because like in the other job,
base hours was completed,
but there were no hours in production
control.
OK.
I wonder where the base hours came from
because on the other job there wasn't
anything in there were no hours in the
production.
Sometimes it pulls base hours and
sometimes it doesn't.
So where I kept the adjustment is.
You can bring it, right? And sometimes,
like I said,
technical holds it over and it's not.
So I have to subtract those numbers.
Sometimes I just hold it over something
over and it's low. So then I pull it.
Yeah, enough hours to to correlate.
But your plan hours is what you're going
by, is that correct? No,
they deduct the hours that they're going
to buy out first. Well,
what what I'm saying is the adjustment is
the adjustment plus the base hours equals
the plan hours, so.
I know that's what it calculates,
but what are you going by?
What is the correct estimate?
Well,
total hours would be your your actual,
yeah, the actual work.
I think we're going to see that
consistently because I can say we never
linked the estimate to this.
It's always our input data that we
received.
Ease that give us that breakdown that we
manual input.
So I believe that's why it's always
adjusted hours instead of base out, right?
Because we don't need the estimate to
this. So but this one had both.
So like if you had 1000 in base.
And -250 in adjustment and you're going
to have 750 plan dollars.
Got into Excel.
I don't know if you want that Excel. Oh,
you'd have made it. Yeah,
that would be beautiful.
Just take a picture with AI.
Is that what you did? Yeah,
I turned it into a test file.
Good for you.
What's your last name? Chris?
Can't tell you. OK, I might.
How about that? ****.
Oh, can you spell that? GAR.
I'm sure you do this every day. GARGI.
Councillor Bravo, KRJWLOW.
You want to make some.
Yeah, he starts.
I think I can call you by another low.
So yeah, I know. No, this is the team.
Yeah, I'm here.
It's too cheap. I'm too old.
You better have Gray hair. You're too old.
I don't know. That top was looking sus.
I mean, I see the roots coming in.
You got to read it again.
It sounds like my kids and grandkids.
Come on, check that room, bro. You know,
it's going to HR.
Did you?
It's not easy to deal with this.
You see, you know.
So now he's going to look for you,
but it's masterly.
Office admin 712 to.
They don't, but I wasn't.
This thing, yeah,
it's because it seems small.
It's a large problem that's going to
factor. Yeah,
he's right about the direct to indirect.
It's like 11.
You did it.
Yeah, I got some.
Yes, we probably can just run a.
We could probably be like a pivot table
or something.
Mhm.
And then.
That's what I have a video.
You know how to hit the table here to get
that?
You have a good thing first. Can we do it?
Yes, Sir. OK.
In all times, I think it was 1990 million.
You can do that **** anymore, man.
I have a formula to get.
I can do formulas in this form.
I can't remember that we got in the
system, right?
I think we got some from the libraries.
We've got the talent.
We've got the talent. I like to say it.
That's it. So you guys are talking.
Is this Office 365 or something? It's not.
You're in 30 million. Yes, that's.
I got kids over using.
I didn't know there's supposed to be
traveled. Yeah,
I didn't travel that on the beach a lot.
See, I can double your age.
Yeah, I have no idea.
And it's weird as as I get older,
you know, 25 years old at one point,
even when I can get 30, I'll see.
That's all.
That's when you pick your blocks.
Good.
I follow them.
So it's going to find out if you're
fitting into logs.
Tomorrow you'll spend a lot of time in
the codings. It'll be fun.
But are you only going?
Usually we take from stock stuff.
Do you guys have a pretty good inventory
and then we're using take from stock and
time to put stuff in the job or you're
not doing that? Yeah, I'd say we are.
It's been a little stagnant since we lost
our main material and haven't looked at
inventory before us, so.
We do.
We try to do anything that totally
updates the verifications because if we
can save, you know, we try to take the,
sure.
I'm sorry. So is this what? What is?
Is that the 20th right there?
So there's base.
So this would be base hours plus that.
So is this what we need to say that's
that's.
Yep, basically the estimate.
And then that's your actual hours,
correct? Is that for multiple jobs?
If you go back to the tech,
this is for the marketing that we just
looked. Oh, oh,
finally got one different for instance 85,
not designed for you, right?
It's not right on.
He only did one page. I like this.
This is one board that I was expecting.
That's what I was expecting.
I see multiplexes. You got to tell me.
Well, it's pretty damn good though. Yeah,
I can see.
I feel like where's history you both did
a good job.
They have a pretty standard dwelling time.
I was trying to say that I try to get
them to know that position for size,
you know, based off of what we have,
like this past month,
he just upgraded all the things that
continue ability.
That we can. Let's go. Yeah,
that's it wasn't. That's what.
That'll be the one thing that usually
gets us cause I think was great except in
my opinion for the CJDS cause some
estimators are overloaded.
They'll do a stigma task and I'm like
this is a 3 inch plan or something.
You guys took over a CJD on one side of
the page.
It's like, you know,
it's like you got a whole bunch of
cabbage.
Exactly. Clean up and it's ground flows.
How you doing? Yeah, like,
are you guys getting golden connections
here? Yes. Yeah, those estimated. Well,
yeah, it should be CJP multiple correct.
Yeah, it should be 13% on CPU.
H.
Speak.
See,
This is why Alan takes so long to get
work back to work.
Next meeting would be and next meeting.
It's better.
This is Ronald House, you guys.
This is hello. OK,
because specifically since we've been
doing our migration,
it's it's been a bumpy Rd.
for the last three months. I mean,
you've been here for me. How many?
Did you have any issues last week?
I'm not doing anything big in terms of
little, right? Right.
But just it takes a long time and
sometimes we'll have service issues
because we're out here, you know,
Internet will crash and you will be down
for that, you know what I mean? Sure.
It's like you need to have Starlink on
your desk. Yeah, I mean, thanks.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's not a chance where I'm comfortable
last week.
I grabbed one with some panic on that.
No kidding, he did,
but I still need to stand up because it
kind of can't support.
It's this simple one of those over here.
What time are you starting on me? OK,
we'll be in here.
What time do we need to quit?
I'm good online. I'm down with it.
Let's do it.
I'll just go back and have a table.
I get a board. Please do it. I don't know.
Now you're moving my apartment.
Yeah. So you ran an apartment close by.
I did run across next 10 minutes away.
I did that today because I ran a
department over 7 months and we got ready
to buy a Honda and then I got a call and
said, hey,
you want to work in East Arizona?
He's gotta go be sure.
And then we negotiate.
Then I canceled them. I failed.
This will be my first load and I'll do
the rest of it next week or so.
Basic stuff. But yeah,
I'm keeping my house in Tucson.
But I got,
I got the white here on the left.
It's a slightly chopping kids and
grandkids 5 minutes away. So yeah.
What do you get online?
Maybe I can't walk up.
What do you shop at? I don't see.
Are these the work packages or the the
hours of the payables? We can check.
I'm going to run into my apartment
because I need to check.
That's our response.
No. Oh, it's hard to say.
I guess this is a the while I have a
place. I don't know. That's OK.
Leave it like this.
OK.
It's just well.
Are you going to build one?
Is that what you do?
Or in the environment? What's that? Oh,
it's right now. It's already built,
but the ones that we walk by,
they're in the city store.
I wanted to verify.
Are you sending the update?
Just get it.
This is what he's going to be Friday.
We're going to do on which day and what
night, right?
I'll send that e-mail to a recap,
update that.
I'm going at the end of the week,
but we'll just do it.
Get me to be out of losers if you don't
mind.
You could be almost 300 lbs at least.
I'm not doing much data and it's hard.
That's it was amazing. Really,
really helped. I just try much to. Yes,
the face it. I'll.
We got off the seating bags.
That's 100% true. It's all portions.
I said, but I'm not told for the line.
I got something more. I see. I see. I see.
I see it's candy.
I see it's candy and pizza.
I have to wait. I've got some shoes.
Goodbye.
Alright, so how about you?
And I can copy this.
So.
Do you do you get all meets?
You need something like that.
It's the best one committee.
Look up tomorrow morning.
If I come in the half hour floor this
week,
you kind of walk around the chat room.
Yeah, that's fine.
Oh, I was going to. You're shot.
So yeah, just bring the schedule back up,
filter for handling and then I'll just,
I'll just get the numbers real quick.
I we'll do all of them,
but if you can get handling and I'll just
do the total of all that real quick and
then I'll get the then we'll filter for
cut and then we'll filter for the other
one.
Yes, so.
OK, so.
To 12.
9615440 All right and then 29131050.
6920 That's it. I need to get.
On handling, yeah, that's that's good.
I need to get that was the planned hours.
I'm gonna need to get the actual as well.
Yeah, the total. So 00.
035 K got that.
OK, cool.
And then we did cut saw, cut saw.
OK, let's see. I'll do that. OK, 211, Yep.
What do you think is?
Thank you.
I got more one more than.
Yeah, I can see that. OK. Yeah. Well,
it should have should have been a call.
Yeah,
we got one more of cut saw than we did on
handling for some reason,
but let's go down through the total hours
on here. Make sure I got the same,
get the same thing then.
Uh.
So.
Alright.
Yeah.
What do you want?
Uh.
16.5.
Yeah, that's the same number. OK.
Tools.
616 OK 57.
211.831 and one.
OK.
Yeah, 68.5.
Sorry, 151617.
6452.
2.
17.75 OK.
Yeah, 36979.
84.05643730 whoops.
Hey.
OK, I see.
101.43.5 point.
82.5.
7.7 file.
36.75 and 20.
It was the arrow that probably. Oh yeah,
AJ. Yes, I did.
It was my job when I was there.
I was the senior.
Anytime anybody, I,
I required or to run into big problems,
they reject me. Yeah, I'm going to.
It's 34,
but the prison job for the building in
West Valley 87325 started the same time
top.
Fill building in Texas. One is 77.25,
including three of our own, and one is 77.
25. This is taking 18 minutes to go.
86 and 32 that they had. OK,
is that all of them? I think that's it,
right?
Respond to their e-mail process.
That's not for like 4 or five days before
he would respond to the budget.
6 projects all in one location,
but and I forget the name of the other
two companies.
So crap, I really need that over here.
So actually go to the job in Utah Monday
through Thursday.
That was the whole time.
That's why I did all the problems.
And it was a big astronaut or a difficult
job. We're giving that what you call it.
But I've done that my little career area.
Yeah, that's how I got that.
It's called arrowhead. Yeah,
that tells me, yeah.
Yeah, that one was through.
That was a great one. Yeah, yeah,
because it's technically all the same,
but yet. Oh man, that's, I don't know,
that's right. Oh, is that right?
Problems if you're losing money.
Is that right? Or did I? I did.
There we go. Yeah, that looks better.
And so I was part of that.
And so I was like,
I was struggling with a lot of jobs.
And they asked me to go to Texas because
they were really focusing on more jobs in
Texas. They said that expanding area.
Yeah. And I said no. And they said, OK,
they they asked me about long ago. I go,
no, I'm staying here.
Is it where I've got to work?
And I said OK.
Let's go see what the estimate is now.
Let's go see what the estimate was now.
Oh.
Beans area.
I was continually going to home on these
little shops,
but we're going to buy the columns over
here and the beans over there and stairs
over there. Yeah, there's there's three,
three of them.
So it's the boys have 5D adaptable and
the shoot.
OK, go back to the production from the.
The team.
Hold on a second.
See the same as this one.
So the total hours is like 434600.
And that's 1800.
Why not the right move, baby?
11,000, yeah.
8400.
I guess I don't understand how.
How's that so far?
Alright,
so we have to reestimated from one to
take off those because then it's be
cheaper than the pricing.
I bet you see that's like 2.
42 hours per ton of you over.
This just wasn't labored out.
You see the the rest of the guests a
little bit.
So 7.
Repeat.
Hit see see the filters on the.
That's the same job.
There's something graphically changed.
It's the hours per ton.
This was drastically different.
Go back to that one that was 2 point
whatever hours per ton.
Go to labor code on the left hand side on
the filters.
And open that up. Yeah.
So it's not labored.
It A is the default on this that
basically handling and cutting and that's
it. This doesn't have any labor to it.
I think it would be somewhere else in
another estimate meeting,
reach out to the estimate meeting, so.
She can't smile at issues.
That's another reason we haven't really
obviously something that's on our list to
delete this back. Yeah,
obviously that's correctly. Yep,
it's great.
For sure.
I think we had just left when they're
basically helping. They have to be an org.
And then I said, hey,
let me see your last three years worth of.
So nominal. What's that nominal?
Something. It's it's why the other days.
Let me see your last three years worth of
estimates versus actuals. They go,
what do you mean? They go, well,
I want to see, you know.
Drafting hours, shop hours,
give it out and you have to spend, right?
And they go, we don't have that. They go,
what do you have? This is,
I can tell you this job 800 last night.
That's all.
You can't tell me if it's made money or
last money because people are already got
shop hours.
Or material. No. Oh, great.
So I implemented the last couple of
months. Dude,
you have to have that job costing,
real job costing,
and you have to have estimates.
The owners of the company,
you only have that been for 35 years.
Oh yeah,
this cheap land looks about 75 bucks a
square foot and this handrail is 500
bucks the land a foot. OK, well,
where's the computer right now? How much?
We just know this is what we can sell it
for.
It's been 5 years now we've been doing.
So in the last seven months,
all I did was implement job passing
program and fix their estimating and I
left at my board because I want to come
back home, right?
So when I turned in my notice two or
three weeks ago, he said,
what can you do is come favor?
What's that?
They also had five estimators,
all 5 estimators in different labour
rates in different markets.
So it completely screwed it up, right?
From scale and location, he said.
Can you give you our estimators and kind
of say on those three guys? Sure.
So I have time studies that I have
personally made-up since it takes this
many minutes for folks to do a a wire for
them to take one of this many minutes for
folks to do a take one of this many
minutes for work to do a Polish this many
minutes to do this many minutes to make a
panel on which should bend,
should form it.
And it's been as much time.
So I made a cheat sheet off of my memory
and I said I would use these times and I
would actually enter the measured costs
and shop fabrication times and erection
times all based on the things that I've
given you. And so now they're doing that,
but they wanted me to explain all that.
The day before my last day,
it's like I was very friendly and I could
actually go back to work there,
but I was really trying to get these guys
up to the 20th century.
So you get a great shape to wear it back.
That's not the hard part of me.
That's awesome though.
You said it was a 1099. No, no, I had it.
I was working as a as an employee, but.
Yeah,
but I actually offered to estimate or
consult for them after I left,
because it does not conflict with what
we're going to do is polished brass,
polished stainless are a real super
trusted. If you guys don't do that here.
By often they didn't take me up on it,
which is fine, but like, you know,
it might, yeah, yeah.
Personally, bring your chair.
You're on the screen.
You should talk to somebody.
Oh, $300 chair. Yeah, a good one.
Mine's like found like 7 bucks. Yeah,
like a $25 Costco room.
It was funny before.
They used to.
I'm going to fix that tomorrow.
Bring some good ones.
I just bought a chair for a home,
but I looked at the most comfortable
office chair is Aaron's chair.
$1750 So I started looking for used ones.
I found one for the 400 bucks last
weekend and bought a big home.
Is it the best chair you're going to sell?
You know what? It's pretty damn close.
My wife's bad.
Can you pay 400 bucks for a chair?
I paid $400 for a $1700 chair for a used
chair.
Yeah, yeah. But you know what?
It's real comfortable.
It does. So this job is wrong, right?
We're missing information.
Looks like I'll have that information
full waiting for the estimator every
second scene, but.
Yeah, we done today. Looks like it. Yeah.
See you guys in the morning.
I'll be here 7,
maybe 7:30 in the workshop.
I need to come on. Thanks, Sir.
And by the way, I hope nothing.
I would like to look at it to see if we
have a disagreement because I was going
to bring it up, but no, we'll be good.
It was all good. Appreciate it.
I'd like to.
I'll screw up something like that.
One person that threw me out, I guess,
is we had a conversation with.
With Jim Blair and we lost that
discussion. Yeah,
but he knew Jim Blair and I.
Do not make that dial. Yeah, I see that.
I never. Yeah,
it was one of the things where.
Because even more like this is what's
happening.
What is it you can take it or you're not
going to have any business in the valley.
Yeah, it's small. I really have it.
Smoothly. Yeah. Not more into.
Let's try to work together to fix this
one and that's it.
It's all looking forward.
It's just the same.
Yeah, that's good.
You too. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I see a lot of videos. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jason, he said. He's looking up. You know,
he's all over. I've got stuff for.
Clients send me questions. I'm like,
I've answered the same question five
times. I'm like, I do video,
just do a link. So I'm like,
might as well make a YouTube channel and
send it up there or so. Yeah, yeah,
there's a couple people.
Utilized all stuff. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
All the guys, they really dug into it.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. All right.
See you. See you tomorrow.